OKAY. GOOD MORNING WE'RE GONNA
START TODAY'S.
SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A.
THAT KIND OF A HODGEPODGE OF
TOPICS TODAY'S WE'RE GONNA
BOUNCE AROUND.
THIS OF COURSE IS SUBCOMMITTEE
WERE TWO ON EDUCATION FINANCE
WE'RE GONNA START. OFF FIRST
WITH.
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW.
HASTINGS FOLKS HERE YES
HERE THEY ARE.
START WITH ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVEN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW.
THE MORE INJECTS WALT FROM
FRANCE I THINK FOR GIVING THE
OPPORTUNITY DISCUSS.
HE SINGS BECAUSE OF LOS BUDGET
WITH YOU THIS MORNING.
I UC HASTINGS IS AFFILIATED WITH
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
BUT IT'S GOVERNED INDEPENDENTLY.
BITES ON BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
LOCATED IN SAN FRANCISCO
PRIMARILY SERVES STUDENTS
SEEKING ADDRESS DOCTOR DEGREE
BUT ALSO AS A MASTER OF LOS
PROGRAMMING A MASTER STUDIES IN
LAW PROGRAM. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN UC HASTINGS AND ROLL
NINE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS OF THOSE
NINE HER NINETEEN WERE JD
STUDENTS.
ANNUAL TUITION FOR ITS JURIST
DOCTOR PROGRAM THIS YEAR IS
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN DOLLARS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN HE
UC HASTINGS TOTAL BUDGET FUNDED
PRIMARILY BY GENERAL FUND AND
TUITION AND FEES. IS A ONE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS WITH THE
AMOUNT OF GENERAL FUND BEING
TWELVE POINT SEVEN MILLION.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN KNIFING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES A TWO
PERCENT AUGMENTATION TO UC
HASTINGS THIS REPRESENTS AN
INCREASE OF ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
GENERAL FUND ONGOING BRINGING
APPROPRIATIONS TO THE COLLEGE TO
TOTAL THIRTEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION THANK YOU.
JASON CONCENTRA CELILO.
I WANT TO TOUCH ON TWO ISSUES
FIRST AS THE BASE INCREASED SERB
ADMINISTRATION JUST BY
INTRODUCED AND THEN I'D LIKE TO
TOUCH ON.
THE HASTINGS BECAUSE SCHOOL
ARMED BUDGET CONDITION WHICH
ISN'T A TOPIC THAT WAS DISCUSSED
AS PART OF.
LAST YEARS BUDGET.
DURING THE BASED INCREASE OUR
MESSAGE HERE IS SIMILAR AS IT IS
TO YOU SEEN CSU WHICH IS TO
REVIEW THE COST INCREASES AT
THAT BASE INCREASE SUPPORTS
INDETERMINATE THOSE ARE YOUR
HIGHEST PRIORITIES FROM SCHOOL.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TWENTY FIVE
OF YOUR AGENDA.
YOU'LL SEE A TABLE THERE THAT
DISPLAYS OF FUNDING AND SPENDING
INCREASES FOR THE SCHOOL.
ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE OF IT IS
ARE THE FUNDING INCREASES
INCLUDING THE BASE INCREASED.
SPENDING INCREASES.
IF YOU NOTICE THERE THOUGH THE
TWO LARGEST OF SPENDING ITEMS
WOULD BE A COP.
FOR.
STAFF.
AND EAT UP BECAUSE.
FOR HE SINGS.
PROGRAM.
ONE THINK.
RECESS.
LARGELY.
WHILE SOME.
IN ALL.
SCHOOLS.
COMMITTEE MAY RECALL.
THAT DEFICIT IS LARGELY DUE TO
A.
COOL.
A GOAT.
SCORE PART.
IN WEST.
GETTING IN TWENTY.
SCHOOL WOULD BEGIN A MULTI YEAR.
THE SENATE.
A KEY ACTION.
IN THIS BUDGET YEAR.
THAT DECISION WOULD AFFECT
STUDENTS.
STARTING FALL TWENTY
TINA WOULDN'T OF.
ACTUALLY PACKAGES FOR.
ENROLLED IN THE SCHOOL SO THE
FISCAL AFFECT.
AND WOULD BE.
IN ADDITION TO THIS YEAR THE
SCHOOL DID SOME
SEVERAL LONG TERM
SCENARIOS IN WHICH YOU WOULD
REDUCE.
AND ELIMINATES DEFICIT OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS.
THOSE PLANS GENERALLY CONSISTED
OF A BEGINNING TO INCREASE TO.
AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWO
WHICH IS BEEN FLAT FOR ABOUT SIX
YEARS AT THE SCHOOL.
THE THE SCENARIOS ALSO INCLUDED
VARIOUS COMPENSATION CREASES IN
OTHER OPERATING COST INCREASES.
THE DIFFERENT MATERIALS DEFERRED
IN WHAT THE ASSUME SOME
SCENARIOS HAD ALL.
HIGHER TUITION INCREASES FOR
STUDENTS AND HIGHER COST
INCREASES.
OTHERS HAD ON A LOWER TUITION
INCREASES AND SUBSEQUENTLY LOWER
COST INCREASES.
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO
ASK THE SCHOOL ABOUT ITS LONG
TERM PLANS ABOUT A PLANS
REGARDING TUITION COST INCREASES
AND TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH THE
DIRECTION IN WHICH THE SCHOOLS
HEADING.
THE SCHOOLS BUDGET CONDITIONAL
LIKELY AFFECT YOUR DECISIONS I
BUDGET DECISIONS THIS YEAR AND
ON THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
SOME QUESTIONS YOU COULD
CONSIDER ASKING OR WHAT ARE THE
SCHOOLS PLANS REGARDING TUITION
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS ARE YOU
COMFORTABLE WITH THE LEVEL OF
INCREASE OF THE SCHOOLS
PLANNING.
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH THOSE
SCHOOLS LEVEL OF COST INCREASES
EACH YEAR. A GIVEN THAT THE
SCHOOL US STILL CURRENTLY HAS A
BUDGET DEFICIT THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS YOU CAN THROUGH
ASKING TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO MY NAME
IS DAVID SOARED UP CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER AM ACCOMPANIED
BY MORSE RATNER OUR ACADEMIC
DEAN.
OF FIRST WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THERE OF
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF OUR
OPERATIONS.
SO WE ARE IN OUR FIFTH YEAR OF
THE MULTI YEAR FUNDING PLAN THAT
HAS ALLOWED US TO.
ENGAGE.
IN THE LONG TERM FINANCIAL
PLANNING AND AND IN THE CONTEXT
OF A VERY.
.
CHALLENGING MARKET LEGAL
EDUCATION.
OF.
WE. EMBRACE THIS LONG RANGE
PLANNING PERSPECTIVE AND WE'D
ADOPT A NUMBER OF ASSUMPTIONS
THAT WE REFINE AND TEST AS TIME
PROGRESSES.
OF THE LEGEND WAS MENTIONS ONE
OF THEM OF FEE INCREASES WE ARE
GOING INTO OUR SIX YEAR.
FLAT FEES.
BASED ON OUR DISCUSSIONS LIVE
JOURNAL AS WE HAVE MODERATED THE
INCREASE PLAN FOR.
AT NINETEEN TWENTY WHO EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
ONE NINETEEN TWENTY. A NINETEEN
TWENTY TO BRING ABOUT A FIVE
PERCENT INCREASE AND PINE WHICH
IS THAT WE HAVE FEE DISCOUNTING
WOULD STILL BE APPLICABLE TO.
AND WE. MAKE ASSUMPTIONS ON
STATE FUNDING A COMPLETE
COMPENSATION WHERE IN THE MIDDLE
OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES.
ARE NON REPRESENTED STAFF HAVE
GONE FOR OVER A YEAR AND A HALF
WITHOUT A OF THE COMPENSATION
INCREASE IN THIS PART OF OUR
PLAN GOING FORWARD. TO ADDRESS
THOSE NEEDS.
SO WE DO LOOK AT IT.
AS.
.
YOU MANAGING WITHIN THE OF THE
MEANS THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE USING
THEIR RESERVE STRATEGICALLY. AND
THOSE RESERVES HAVE BEEN
DEPLOYED TO A SUPPORT OUR OUR IN
OF STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
OBJECTIVES TOO AGAIN ATTRACT
QUALITY STUDENTS IN A VERY VERY
COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT.
WE.
OF ENGAGE IN TUITION DISCOUNTING
IN ORDER TO BE COMPETITIVE WITH.
OUR COLLEAGUES IN BOTH THE
PUBLIC A LAW SCHOOL SPACE AS
WELL AS PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS.
AND WE WILL BE RATCHETING IT
DOWN BEGINNING IN THE NEXT.
IN THIS UPCOMING BUDGET CYCLE.
FROM FORTY TWO PERCENT ABOUT
THIRTY SEVEN POINT FIVE.
SO.
.
WE'RE ALSO ENGAGED AND.
CAPITAL PROGRAMS TO INCREASE.
.
STUDENT HOUSING STOCK AND
SERVICE ARE TENDERLOIN.
WHO ARE PARTNERING WITH OTHER
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS SO SHARING
RESOURCES?
TO PROVIDE HOUSING THAT'S
CRITICALLY NEEDED IN THE BAY
AREA A OUR STUDENTS HAVE TO
COMPETE WITH EMPLOYEES OF OF THE
MID MARKET TECH COMPANIES OF.
PUT HER. IN THE COMPETING FOR
THE SAME MARKET RATE HOUSING
THAT OF WORKERS THAT WORK IN
HOTELS ARE COMPETING FOR ANSWERS
A. POINT DEAL OF FLUX.
WHILE OUR COST OF ATTENDANCE
CONTRIBUTE TUITION HAS REMAINED
FLAT HOUSING COSTS ARE BECOMING
INCREASINGLY PROBLEMATIC WHO ARE
WORKING VERY HARD.
TWO OF THEM. INCREASE THE
HOUSING STOCK TO.
REMOVE A BARRIER TO ENTRY INTO
THE LEGAL DUCATION THE
CURRENTLY IS PROBLEMATIC FOR
HASTINGS AS WELL AS MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA'S SAN FRANCISCO.
OKAY.
QUESTIONS.
NOW I THINK WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND AS.
HAS THAT THE STAFF NOTES WE KNOW
CONCERNS ON THIS PROPOSAL BUT WE
WILL NOT TAKE ACTION TODAY WILL
HOLD THE ISSUE OFTEN AND TAKE
FINAL ACTION A FEW WEEKS.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY.
SO WE'RE GOOD NOT ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT.
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH.
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION LEARNING
LAB.
AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES TEN MILLION GENERAL
FUND I'M GOING TO CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION LEARNING
LAB. AN INITIATIVE FOCUSED ON
INTEGRATING LEARNING SCIENCE
INTO INSTRUCTION IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF ONLINE HIGHER
EDUCATION AT PUBLIC COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES.
LEARNING SCIENCES AND
INTERDISCIPLINARY FIELD SEEKS TO
FURTHER OUR UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
PEOPLE EARN THE PROCESSES OF
LEARNING NOW LEARNING CAN BE
SUPPORTED OR ENHANCED BY
TECHNOLOGIES INSTRUCTIONAL
PRACTICES DESIGN. AND LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS AND DIFFERENT
CONTACTS.
A PRIMARY GOAL OF THE PROPOSED
INITIATIVES TO CUSTOMIZE
LEARNING AND INCREASE CHANCES
FOR PERSISTENCE AND LOWER
DEFENSE LOWER DIVISION STEM
COURSES. THROUGH THE SUFFERING
SCIENCE.
LOWER DIVISION IS OFTEN WHERE
STUDENTS HAVE EXPRESSED INTEREST
IN STEM MAY DROP OUT AFTER ONE
OR TWO COURSES. MAKING IT AN
IDEAL TIME TO INTERVENE TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES.
THE FOCUS OF THIS INITIATIVE
WILL BE TO READ DEVELOPER
REDESIGN ONLINE HOWEVER COURSES
TO SPECIFICALLY INTEGRATE
ADAPTIVE LEARNING I TECHNOLOGIES
IN THE PRINCIPLES OF LEARNING
SCIENCE INTO THE CURRICULUM.
THIS DIFFERS FROM THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS THE SEGMENT EACH ON
THEIR AGENDA.
THOSE PROGRAMS SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF COURSES.
WHILE THE LAB RESEARCH HOW
STUDENTS LEARN TO OPTIMIZE
ALMIGHTY HYBRID COURSES.
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT
LITTLE ATTENTION HAS BEEN PAID
TO THE SCIENCE OF LEARNING AND
HOW TO IMPROVE THE DELIVERY OF
STEM EDUCATION.
OUR MIND EDUCATION PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF EDUCATION ACCESS FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS.
ACHIEVEMENT GAP GAPS IN COLLEGE
PREPARATION OF AGREE ATTAINMENT
IN STEM FIELDS EXIST ACROSS THE
COUNTRY INCLUDING IN CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO STUDIES BY THE
CITY.
AMERICAN MILITANTS STUDENTS
MEET.
COLLEGE READINESS AND STEM
BENCHMARKS AT HALF THE RATE OF
THEIR WHITE NATION PEERS.
THESE DISPARITIES ARE NOT CLOSE
AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL AFTER
AMERICAN WITH HOUSTON'S EARN
SIGNIFICANTLY FEWER STEM DEGREES
THAN THE ORIGINAL ACCOUNT FOR
COUNTERPARTS BOTH UC AND CSU.
FOR EXAMPLE WHICH INSTANCE IT
SEE IF YOU MAKE A FORTY PERCENT
OF ALL STUDENTS BUT ONLY TWENTY
SIX PERCENT OF STUDENTS AWARDED
AN ENGINEERING DEGREE.
SIMILARLY AT THE UC.
AFTER AMERICAN STUDENTS EARN
PHYSICAL SCIENCES AND
ENGINEERING DEGREES AT HALF THE
RATE OF THEIR SYSTEM I
POPULATION.
BY EXPANDING OUR UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW PEOPLE LEARN AND
LEVERAGING ADVANCES IN
TECHNOLOGY THE STATE CAN
INCREASE LEARNING AND
ACHIEVEMENT AMONG THESE GROUPS.
THESE TECHNOLOGIES INCLUDE
ADAPTIVE LEARNING SOFTWARE THAT
DYNAMICALLY RESPONSES SINCE WHEN
THEY STRUGGLE WITH THE CONCEPT
AND PROVIDE INSTRUCTORS WITH
DATA ON WHERE STUDENTS A NEED
ADDITIONAL HELP.
BUILDING LEARNING SYSTEMS THAT
PROVIDE CONTINUOUS FEEDBACK AND
ASSESSMENT CAN ACCELERATE
STUDENT LEARNING.
ANOTHER KEY GOAL THE LAP IS TO
FOSTER COLLABORATION AMONG
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION.
DEMAND FROM MY COURSES IS
WINNING INCREASING AND AT EVERY
SEGMENT.
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE
CSU PROVIDED ONLINE INSTRUCTION
TO A POPULATION EQUAL TO FIVE
POINT FIVE PERCENT OF ALL FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS.
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN MORE THAN
FIFTEEN THOUSAND STUDENT A
FALTERING SIXTEEN WHETHER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN ALL MY COURSES AT
THE UC.
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE
SHARE OF ONLINE INSTRUCTION HAS
NEARLY TRIPLED IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS AND ALTHOUGH EACH OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS HAS ITS OWN ONLINE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE.
COLLABORATION BETWEEN SEGMENTS
IS LIMITED AT BEST AND THERE'S
NOT A FOCUS ON THE EMERGING
OPPORTUNITIES LEARNING SCIENCE
REPRESENTS.
TO ACHIEVE GREATER COLLABORATION
CONSORTIA SEEKING GRANTS MUST
CONSIST OF AT LEAST TWO TWO AT
LEAST TWO INSTITUTIONS FROM
DIFFERENT SEGMENTS.
BASED ON CONVERSATIONS WITH
FACULTY
WE HAD DESPITE THE FLAP WITH
PHONE SIX OR SEVEN PROJECTS A
YEAR AROUND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS EACH WITH EACH
PROJECT CONDUCTING ITS WORK OVER
THREE YEARS.
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH OR CONSULT WITH EXPERTS
ALERTING SCIENCE AND STEM TO
IDENTIFY QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS
TO SERVE ON THE SELECTION
COMMITTEE.
THE METRICS BY WHICH THESE
PROJECTS WILL BE EVALUATED WILL
BE DEVELOPED THROUGH THE REQUEST
FOR PROPOSAL PROCESS. BUT COULD
POTENTIALLY INCLUDE REDUCTIONS
AND FAILURE RATES IMPROVEMENTS
AND GREAT PERFORMANCE AND
PERSISTENCE IN GRADUATION
INCREASES IN MAJORS.
THE FIRST THREE YEARS OF THE
INITIATIVE THE SCOPE OF FINISH
OF WOULD IT WOULD IT WOULD
EXPAND.
AS PROGRESS IS MADE IN STEM
DISCIPLINES ADDITIONAL
DISCIPLINES IN MAJORS BABY ADDED
DEPENDED ON DEPENDING ON
FEEDBACK A DEVELOPMENT FROM THE
FIELD.
THE LEVEL ALSO CARRIED A LIBRARY
OF OPEN EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES
THAT CAN BE USED BY OTHERS
WORKING DEVELOP ONLINE AND
HYBRID COURSES.
LA A REAL QUICK AT. THAT TIME
OUT TO GROW PLEASE.
MCCARTY.
CHAVEZ.
MEDINA HERE.
VOEPEL.
OKAY THANK YOU.
HOLSTEIN HOUSING WITH THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THE GOVERNOR'S PURPOSE FOR
TREATING THESE LEARNING LABS O.
TO WHICH IS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS FROM
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
GROUPS THAT EARNED STAND
BACHELOR'S DEGREES. IS AN
IMPORTANT GOAL THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST CITED SOME DATA ON
HOW STUDENTS FROM HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS. HAVE A
LOWER STANDARD ROMAN PERSISTENCE
IN COMPLETION RATES THAN
STUDENTS FROM OTHER GROUPS.
THAT SAID WE HAVE SEVERAL
CONCERNS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
FIRST RESEARCH IDENTIFIES A
NUMBER OF REASONS
FOR LOWER PARTICIPATION AND
SUCCESS RATES AMONG STUDENTS
FROM CERTAIN GROUPS.
THESE REASONS INCLUDE
DISPROPORTIONATE ATTENDANCE AT
K. TWELVE SCHOOLS WITH LESS
QUALIFIED MATH AND SCIENCE
TEACHERS.
I AND LESS ACCESS TO ADVANCED
COURSES.
.
LACK OF IT ANOTHER REASON IS
LACK OF EXPOSURE TO ROLE MODELS
OR MENTORS WHO WORK IN STEM
FIELDS OTHER. REASONS FOR
DISPARITIES ARE COULD. INCLUDE
PARENTAL EXPECTATIONS
AND THE FACT THAT STEM DEGREES
SUCH AS ENGINEERING OFTEN
REQUIRE MORE THAN THE TYPICAL
HUNDRED TWENTY UNIT A DEGREE
REQUIREMENTS WHICH SERVES AS AN
ADDED BURDEN TO LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS.
TO PURSUE THESE DEGREES.
GIVEN THESE UNDERLYING CAUSES
IT'S UNCLEAR TO US HOW THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SOLUTION
ONLINE AND HYBRID COURSES THAT
USE LEARNING SCIENCE WILL
ADDRESS.
THESE DISPARITIES IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY.
SECOND THOUGH ENROLLMENT IN
ONLINE COURSES HAS BEEN
INCREASING OVER THE YEARS AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY AND YOU SEE. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS CONTINUE TO
TAKE THEIR COURSES IN A FACE TO
FACE ENVIRONMENT.
IT'S UNCLEAR THEN HOW CREATING
REDESIGNING ONLINE AND HYBRID
COURSES.
WOULD RESULT IN A WIDESPREAD
IMPACT
AND IMPROVEMENT.
THIRD AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES ON
PAGES TWENTY SEVEN TO TWENTY
EIGHT. THE STATE ALREADY FUNDS
ONLINE INITIATIVES THAT EACH
SEGMENT.
AND THESE INITIATIVES ALL FOCUS
ON CREATING AND DESIGNING.
ONLINE AND HYBRID COURSES AT THE
LOWER DIVISION LEVEL SO AS TO
INCREASE STUDENT LEARNING.
GIVEN THAT IT'S UNCLEAR TO US
WHY THE STATE NEEDS ANOTHER
STATE FUNDED PROGRAM THAT ALSO
FOCUSES ON CREATING INNOVATIVE
LOWER DIVISION COURSES.
FOR IF THE PROPOSAL REALLY JUST
LACKS THE JUSTIFICATION OVERALL
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE PROPOSED
FUNDING LEVEL TEN MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR ON GOING.
AND HOW SUCH AN AMOUNT WOULD
ACHIEVE PROGRAM OBJECTIVES.
SO WE RECOMMEND.
THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
INSTEAD THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
WANT TO TAKE SOME TIME TO
IDENTIFY THE ROOT CAUSES.
OF STEM DISPARITIES AFTER THREE
SEGMENTS AND BASED ON WHAT I IS
IDENTIFIED. OF THE STATE COULD
CRAFT SOLUTIONS THAT ARE EITHER
TAILORED TO THE SPECIFIC
SEGMENTS.
OR IT COULD BE INTERSECTING AT
ALL OR INVOLVED THE K. TWELVE
SYSTEM.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY DANCERS.
OKAY.
QUESTIONS.
CHAVEZ.
IN ARE KNOW ONLINE EDUCATION AND
STEM YOU KNOW THOSE ARE THE
SHINY OBJECTS OF EDUCATION
TODAY.
BUT.
FROM AN ORGANIZATIONAL
STANDPOINT.
THE COR COM RECEIVE EDUCATION
THE STATE AS WE SET UP HAS SET
IT UP IS INDIA. KATIE TWELVE
SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
A C. ISSUES IN THE UC'S.
WE.
WHAT CHART COR COM TO SEE IN
THIS I DON'T I DON'T SEE WHY
WE'RE DOING THIS?
BUT WHY YOU TAKEN LEAD IN THIS
WE'RE IDEA OF INSTITUTIONS.
THAT ARE TAKEN LEAD IN THIS.
IT'S ARE QUESTIONS CHAVEZ OTHER
REASON WORK IN THE STATE'S
TRYING TO TAKE THE LEAD IN THIS
AREA. IS BECAUSE ALTHOUGH THERE
IN INDIVIDUAL SEGMENTS HAVE
THEIR OWN ONLINE EDUCATION STEM
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS THIS
LIMITED CALL A COLLABORATION
COOPERATION ACROSS SEGMENT
SOMETHING THAT THEY'VE INDICATED
TO THE STATE. THAT THEY THEY
THEY LOOK TO US TO OUR.
TO TAKE THAT LEAD AND AND WORK
WITH THEM TOO TO FOSTER THAT
THAT SPIRIT COLLABORATION AND
AND THESE.
AVAILABILITIES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US SEGMENTS TO
COLLABORATE AND THIS
SPECIFICALLY.
FOCUSING ON LEARNING SCIENCE
EACH SEGMENT HAS ITS OWN
DEVELOPMENT AS THE EARLIER NOTED
HAS ITS OWN. PROGRAM FOR
DEVELOPING ONLINE COURSES THIS
FOCUSES ON INCREASING THE
QUALITY OF THIS COURSE IS BY
USING NEW TECHNOLOGIES ADAPTIVE
LEARNING SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
PILOTED YOU SEE IN OTHER
CAMPUSES. TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF OF ONLINE EDUCATION SO YOU'RE
CORRECT IN SAYING THAT YOU KNOW
WE HAVE THESE GREAT SYSTEMS OF
EDUCATION AT THE K. TWELVE
SYSTEM WITH THE THE PUBLIC ARE
AT SEGMENTS THAT ARE DEDICATED
TO. ASSISTANCE ACCESS.
BUT THE STATE HAS A ROLE HERE IN
CLARA AND FOSTER COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE SEGMENTS AND OUT
TRYING TO PUSH THESE THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN. WE CAN ADDRESS THE.
THAT THE NEED FOR QUALITY HIGHER
EDUCATION UP IN THE ONLINE
SPHERE AS STUDENTS CONTINUE TO
AND SHOES ON MY EDUCATION AS A
WAY TO AND TO RECEIVE
INSTRUCTION.
YEAH I.
I'M SURE IF WE HAD THE.
TOM TORTURE NOT HERE WE HAD
CHEN IN THE PALATABLE BE SAYING.
THEY'RE PUTTING QUALITY ALL THE
TIME IN THEIR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS.
AND.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S THE GOVERNOR
HE'S EXECUTIVE BEGINNING CALM
UNDOCUMENTED ON THE WANTS TO.
BUT TO FORM AN ORGANIZATION TO
DO THIS.
TO ME DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE AND.
.
THE GRAND THIS IS NOT A LOT OF
MONEY IN THE IN THE IN THE
BUDGET WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT BUT
IT IS MONEY THAT COULD GO TO.
ANY OF THESE INSTITUTIONS TO
FURTHER THEIR EFFORT.
SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I. I'M
NOT SUPPORTIVE OF THIS I THINK
IT'S.
.
ITS A SHINY OBJECT CHASE AND.
THE THE ELEMENT IS THIS.
EDUCATION.
AND THAT'S NOT OP ARES OR THE
GOVERNOR'S JOB THAT'S ACTUALLY
IN OUR EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
HE VIEW WHAT'S GUIDANCE TO. GIVE
ALL THE GUYS WHO WANTS TO.
BUT TO FORM AN ORGANIZATION.
TO GIVE GUIDANCE OR WILL
COORDINATE THINGS THEN WE GOT
THE WRONG PEOPLE RUN IN THE.
THESE EDUCATION AND THAT'S
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE SO I WON'T
BE SUPPORTIVE OF.
MR MEDINA.
NOT TO. FOLLOW UP BOTH FROM THE.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S.
AND OF FROM MY COLLEAGUE OF MR
CHAVEZ.
.
I LIKE THE COMMENTS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S THAT THAT
OTHER THINGS COULD CERTAINLY BE
DONE. TO HELP.
STAND.
IMPROVE STAND WITHIN A LATINO
AND AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS. A
AND I APPRECIATE THE.
VIEW THE.
RECOMMENDATIONS OR SUGGESTIONS
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
AND I AND I WOULD ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
YOU KNOW HOW HOW MUCH INCREASE
WILL WE SEE TO PROGRAMS LIKE
WENT DAY.
MESA.
THAT THE DO JUST THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT WORK WITH A
MINORITY STUDENTS.
TO IMPROVE THEIR COLLEGE
PERFORMANCE
AND.
COULD YOU ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
MISTREATED I'M NOT AS FAMILIAR
WITH THE WITH THE OTHER SEGMENTS
BUDGETS.
.
HOWEVER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOES INCLUDE BROAD GENERAL PACE
INCREASES TO ALL THE SEGMENTS SO
THAT THEY CAN MANAGE THEREAFTER
RESOURCES EFFECTIVELY. AND FOCUS
ON THE PRIORITIES THAT THEY
THINK ARE IMPORTANT CONSISTENTLY
STATE GOALS.
.
I I WILL MENTION THAT MY FATHER
WAS A CIVIL ENGINEER AND A
GETTING A DEGREE IN CIVIL
ENGINEERING OF THE TIME WHERE
THEY WERE PROBABLY NOT A LOT OF
LATINOS GETTING DEGREES IN CIVIL
ENGINEERING.
AND SO I'VE ALWAYS HAD BEEN
CONSCIOUS
OF LA AND YOU KNOW HOW WE DO IN
EDUCATION AND ENCOURAGING. A
MINORITY STUDENTS WOMEN TO ENTER
STEM STEM FIELDS AND I AGREE.
WITH THE COMMENTS OF
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THAT IT'S A GREAT GOAL BUT I
ALSO. AM.
.
A CAUTIOUS APPREHENSIVE THAT
JUST TO INCREASING A FUNDING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR IMPROVING
ONLINE IS GOING TO ACCOMPLISH
THE GOAL AS IT SET OUT.
AND AND I VERY MUCH AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER CHAVEZ THAT.
JUST BECAUSE IT'S A SHINY OBJECT
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S THE BEST THING
AND SO I AM VERY.
A DUBIOUS ABOUT.
APPROVING THIS AS WELL.
OKAY.
I DON'T THINK HAVING MORE TO
ADD.
AS WAS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS BY
OUR STAFF AS WELL YOU KNOW THIS
IS THAT INTRIGUING PROPOSAL BUT
WE WANT TO WAY THIS ON ALL OF
OUR REQUESTS YOU KNOW WE VERY WE
HEAR FROM OUR. CSU AND YOU SEE
STUDENTS AS FAR AS FUNDING MORE
ACCESS.
AND.
DIRECT SERVICES THE CAMPUS
LEVEL SO WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS IN TOTALITY.
SO WITH THAT WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN. BY WE'RE GOING TO.
GO NOW TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
THE STATE LIBRARIAN.
FOR WAITING FOR A FEW MEMBERS TO
TALK ABOUT ISSUES AND ONE AND
TWO SO WE'LL.
.
PROCEED NOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LIBRARY.
PLEASE COME UP.
OKAY WE WILL BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER THREE.
DAN OR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY
SERVES A CRITICAL ROLE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT BY SERVING AS A
CENTRAL REFERENCE POINT FOR THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE.
ADDITIONALLY THE STATE LIBRARY
PROVIDES CRITICAL ASSISTANCE IN
DISTRIBUTES FEDERAL FUNDS.
TO THE ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR LIBRARY JURISDICTIONS
HERE THEY HUNDRED LIBRARIES
ACROSS THE STATE.
OVERALL THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES THIRTY FIVE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS. IN GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT TO THE STATE LIBRARY IN
DOT THIS YEAR. AND.
THIS INCLUDES A PROPOSALS
TOTALING NINE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS YEAR OF WHICH THREE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING.
THESE PROPOSALS ENABLE THE STATE
LIBRARY TO FURTHER ITS MISSION
TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS WITH
GREATER ACCESS TO INFORMATION.
THE FIRST SET OF PROPOSALS
ENABLE THE STATE LIBRARY TO
ASSIST LOCAL LIBRARIES WITH
INTERNET CONNECTIONS.
THE STATE LIBRARY HAS A CONTRACT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
EDUCATION NETWORK INITIATIVES.
AND CALIFORNIA BETTER KNOWN AS
SCENIC.
TO PROVIDE INTERNET FOR LIBRARY
PATRONS.
TELL MAXIMIZE THE EFFORTS OF
THIS CONTRACT.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
BROADBAND EQUIPMENT GRANTS TO
PROVIDE WHAT.
GRANTS DELIVERY DISTRICTS TO
CONNECT.
MORE LIBRARY BRANCHES TO THE
BACKBONE.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET PROPOSES
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME GRANTS.
IN ONE TIME FOR BROADBAND
CAPACITY GRANTS THAT WILL HELP
TO EXPAND.
THE LIBRARY CONNECTIVITY LEVELS
ARE BRANCHES ALREADY CONNECTED
TO THE SCENIC BACKBONE.
ADDITIONALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
ONGOING SUPPORT.
TO FUND THE FEES AND SURCHARGES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SCENIC
CONTRACT AND A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
ESTABLISH AN EERIE CONSULTANT
POSITION. THAT WILL WORK TO
SECURE STATEWIDE FUND.
STATEWIDE DISCOUNTS TO THE
FEDERAL EDUCATION RIGHT PROGRAM.
JASON CONCENTRA SELLING NO.
AS NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA ON PAGES
FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN THERE ARE
FOUR ISSUES BEFORE YOU.
OF THE THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
EXPAND INTERNET CAPACITY FOR
LIBRARIES THAT ARE ALREADY
CONNECTED TO THE SCENIC
BACKBONE.
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EQUIPMENT GRANTS FOR ADDITIONAL
LIBRARIES TO CONNECT TO THE
SCENIC BACKBONE.
AND THEN THE FUNDING FOR IT FOR
SCENIC OPERATIONS AND THE
FUNDING FOR A NEW POSITION AT
THE STATE LIBRARY. SAW ALL WALK
THROUGH EACH OF THOSE IN THAT
ORDER.
ON THE THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE INTERNET CAPACITY GRANTS.
AND IT'S A PROPOSAL TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE ADMINISTRATION
NOTED THAT LIBRARIES ARE
UNDERGOING A MULTI YEAR PROCESS
TO REVIEW THEIR LIBRARY NEEDS
AND THEIR LIBRARY CAPACITY
NEEDS.
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
WAIT FOR THE THOSE ASSESSMENTS
TO BE COMPLETED IN AND REVIEW
THE FINDINGS OF THOSE
ASSESSMENTS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE NEED THAT LIBRARIES HAVE AND
THE ASSOCIATED COSTS.
WE RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL IN THIS YEAR IN
REVISITING AT ONCE THOSE
FINDINGS ARE AVAILABLE.
ON THE TWO MILLION DOLLAR.
PROPOSAL FOR THE EQUIPMENT
GRANTS AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES WHEN
WE RODE OUR ANALYSIS WE'RE
WAITING ON SOME ADDITIONAL OF
FINALIZE DATA OF LIBRARIES THAT
WERE INTERESTED IN CONNECTING TO
SEE NAKED TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
THAT DATA WAS RECENTLY MADE
AVAILABLE TO OUR OFFICE IT'S A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO LIBRARIES
AND FOURTEEN JURISDICTIONS.
OVER NINETY PERCENT OF THOSE
LIBRARIES ARE REALLY LOCATED IN
THREE JURISDICTIONS.
COUNTY OF LA SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN
OAKLAND.
WE'RE STILL REVIEWING THAT DATA
AND WE PLAN TO PROVIDE YOU A OF
A MORE A MORE FINAL FISCAL
ESTIMATE OF THIS PROPOSAL. A
CLOSER TO BUDGET CLOSE OUT.
ON THE REMAINING TWO PROPOSALS
THE SCENIC OPERATION COSTS AND A
NEW POSITION AT THE STATE
LIBRARY WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
LACKS SOME OTHER CRITICAL
INFORMATION TO FULLY ASSESS
THESE PROPOSALS.
IN THE CASE OF THE THE SCENIC
COSTS LEGISLATURE LACKS BASIC
UNDERSTANDING OF SCENIC BUDGET
THE VARIOUS COST INCREASES THAT.
THE ORGANIZATION FACES OVERALL
EACH YEAR.
AND THEN SECONDLY.
OF HOW THOSE COSTS SHOULD BE
SCOTT SHARED AMONG THE SEGMENTS
THAT YOU SEEN ACT THAT INCLUDES
YOU SEE CSU THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SCHOOLS.
WE DO KNOW THAT BASED ON WHAT
WE'VE BEEN. WHAT'S BEEN REPORTED
TO US FROM YOU SEEN CSU THAT
THOSE SEGMENTS PAY FOR A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S THE SAME THAT THE THAT
LIBRARIES ARE EXPECTED TO PAY
THE LIBRARY SURE THAT COST HALF
WITH THE GENERAL FUND HALF WITH.
A STATE SPECIAL FUNDS.
THAT DIDN'T SEEM TO BE MUCH
RATIONAL TO US THERE IT'S LIKELY
THAT YOU SEE IN CS YOU HAVE
HIGHER USAGE ESPECIALLY YOU SEE
GIVEN THAT IT'S A RESEARCH
UNIVERSITY. HOWEVER WE DON'T
HAVE MORE A BETTER DATA ON A
CURRENT USAGE TO FULLY ASSESS
THAT'S WE CAN'T REALLY ASSESS
WHAT LOOKS STATE LIBRARIES
PORTION OF THOSE COSTS SHOULD
BE.
ON THE NEW POSITION OF STATE
LIBRARY LIKEWISE WE THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE A MORE
DETAILED ANALYSIS OF THE VARIOUS
WORKLOAD THAT EXISTS. AT SCENIC
AT THE STATE LIBRARY AND THE
KHALIF ANOTHER ORGANIZATION THAT
PROCESSES PAYROLL ON BEHALF OF
LIBRARIES. OF FORCING NECK.
THAT WORKLOAD ANALYSIS WOULD
BETTER ALLOWS TO TO IT
UNDERSTAND THE VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES THAT EACH SEGMENT IS
INVOLVED IN WHEN IT COMES TO.
DEALING WITH CERTAIN SCENIC
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING. A
LEVERAGING <c.green>RATE DISCOUNTS</c>
AS WELL AS I UNDERSTAND IT
EXISTING AND NEW WORKLOAD FOR
ALL THESE ORGANIZATIONS MOVING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
WELCOME BACK.
STATE LIBRARIAN.
YOU BACK THERE THANK YOU OKAY.
NICE TO SEE YOU MISTER CHAIR YES
WE LIKE TO SAY ANYTHING ABOUT
THIS SPECIFIC.
PROPOSAL THERE'S ALL LAID OUT
ALREADY.
YOU KNOW THE NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION THAT DAN LAID OUT A NINE
POINT SEVEN. MINUTES THE PRODUCT
OF CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION BETWEEN.
SCENIC.
AND AND THAT CALIFORNIA LIBRARY
ASSOCIATE.
SORRY.
AND SO.
MEAN IS IT A.
I MEAN IF IT WAS UP TO ME.
RIGHT I TO I WOULD RECOMMEND THE
STATE SPEND TEN TIMES THIS
AMOUNT ON AN ONGOING BASIS AND
TO SUPPORT PUBLIC LIBRARIES.
BUT POLICY THAT POLITICS IS THE
ART OF THE POSSIBLE AND SO THIS
IS A GOOD COMPROMISE THAT MOVES
FORWARD.
INITIATIVES THAT HELP THE
LIBRARIES ALL OVER CALIFORNIA IN
EVERY DISTRICT.
THE JEWEL REPRESENT
TO BETTER SERVE THE PEOPLE THAT
WALK IN THE DOOR.
QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IF YOU TRAVIS.
THE SCENIC CONTRACTS FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
WHO IS WHO IS RESPONSIBLE TO
MANAGE IT IN MY OTHER LIFE WE
USED TO CALLING COURSE?
YOU KNOW THE CONTRACTING OFFICER
HOOTON POSSIBLE TO MANAGE
THE FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR CONTRACT TO SEEN ACT.
WHO'D WHO DOES THAT.
WHAT?
WHAT WILL CARL AS JASON SAID
THERE'S EACH SEGMENT PAYS THE
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS?
RIGHT RIGHT A LIKE I THINK OF
THEM AS DO ISTHAT WE PAY TO
PARTICIPATE IN SCENIC EVERY
YEAR.
SO IT.
WHO MANAGES THE CON TRACT A MAIN
WE OVERSEE OUR?
THE FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
THAT'S PAID ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
LIBRARIES.
WHO PUBLIC LIBRARY PAYS FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION DESY NECK THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PAYS THE
MONEY HALF THROUGH THE GENERAL
FUND? AND THE OTHER HALF THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA CAN TELL CONNECT
FUND.
RIGHT.
OKAY SO WE'RE GIVING THEM FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS RIGHT
WE'RE GIVING THEM FOUR AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU IS TO
AUGMENT THAT BY THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND I KNOW THAT. CAN
WRITE
A QUESTION I'M TRYING TO GET TO
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE.
TO ENSURE THAT SEEN ACT.
EXECUTES THEIR AGREEMENT
VISIT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS AT THE LIBRARY IS.
WHO WHO'S THE PERSON HAS GOT THE
BELLY ON THE BUTTON?
I DO THIS.
THAT WAS SPENT AND A FOUR POINT
FIVE OF THE FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS CORRECTLY.
WHO'S THAT PERSON.
YOU KNOW FRANKLY WHAT WE DON'T
HAVE GREAT INFORMATION ON SEE
NIX OPERATIONS WE DON'T OF GREAT
INFORMATION ON THE LEVEL OF
OVERSIGHT THAT. EACH OF THE
SEGMENTS PROVIDE I CAN'T REALLY
SPEAK TO THAT AT ONE OF OUR. ONE
OF OUR CONCERNS HERE IS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A GOOD UNDERSTANDING
OF THE EXISTING OPERATING COST
FOR SCENIC AND SO THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE A PART TIME SERVICE TESTING
THIS PARTICULAR SCENIC IT'S HERE
DID YOU WANT THEM TO COME UP AND
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
YEAH WE'RE GOING TO GIVE HIM
FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION BUCKS
ALIKE KNOWS WHAT WE'RE GONNA
MORE THAN THAT IT'S IT'S FOUR
POINT FIVE PER SEGMENT PER
SEGMENT THAT'S RIGHT SO THAT HOW
MANY SEGMENTS. THOUGHT WHAT'S
YOUR PUBLIC LIBRARIES COMMUNITY
COLLEGES STATE UNIVERSITIES IN
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SO
FIVE TIMES FOUR POINT FIVE.
YES SO YOU WANT TO BRING
SOMEBODY HAPPEN BUT IT.
PRESENT FIRST.
BRIEF MOMENT.
SO WE'RE TALKING TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS A.
MORNING CAME LESS REPRESENTING
SIMAK AND SO THE CONTRACT IS
ACTUALLY BETWEEN SCENIC IS WITH
COOLEY FACTLY BOTH THE
AGGREGATOR ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE LIBRARY. WHO MANAGES THE
LIBRARIES PARTICIPATION INTO
SEEN THAT?
I'M WITH THE ALLOW LIBRARY
PORTION WE'RE ABLE TO DRAW CTF
TELECOM NECK DISCOUNTS ON BEHALF
AND SETS TO AUGMENT THE GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION. AND BECAUSE
OF THAT WE ARE REQUIRED TO PAY
IN TAXES AND SURCHARGES ON THAT
AMOUNT WHICH YOU SEEN SINCE YOU
DO NOT HAVE TO BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT. I'M THERE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
CTF FUN BECAUSE IT IS ONLY
ELIGIBLE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
K. TWELVE. LIBRARIES AND CBO SO
BECAUSE OF THAT WE'RE SAVING ON
THAT SIDE BY NOT PAYING THE
TAXES AND SURCHARGES FOR YOU
SEEN CSU. BUT WE DO HAVE TO DO
THAT FOR THE OTHER ONES IN ORDER
TO RECOUP CTF COSTS.
SO THAT'S WHY IT'S SLIGHTLY MORE
TO PAY FOR THOSE TAXES AND
SURCHARGES BECAUSE IN ORDER TO
ACCESS THE CTF WITH ONE THE
RULES FROM THE. PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
BOY.
HOW? WELL NOT AT ALL BUT IT
SOUNDS TO ME IS JUST RAN THROUGH
THE AYE HYDRATE AYE ME THEM. CFI
DIFFERENT PEOPLE GIVEN THE
SUPPORT PENA FIVE IN THAT ONE
HALF MILLION OR FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION BABIES.
YOU JUST GAVE ME OUT A SPAGHETTI
DEL FOR SOMEBODY. THE. AND THE
OTHER FOR GAS TO DOING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
THIS IS THE SAME FOR CAPABLE
LIBRARIES AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
SO THERE FIVE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE EXECUTION OF THE
CONTRACT. BUT MAY I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING IS FOR EACH OF THE
SEGMENTS WHO RIDE SHOTGUN OVER
THIS CONTRACT YET. ABUSE WHO
MAKING SURE THAT SUBTLE MY NO.
DON'T DON'T PROMISE TO GET YOU
JUST TELL ME. THIS PERSON
RESPONSIBLE HERE THAT'S FROM THE
KHALIFA MANAGES OUR CONTRACT FOR
THE STATE LIBRARY. AND SO THEY
REPORT TO THE STATE LIBRARY BUT
IT'S DIFFERENT FOR THE OTHER AND
THEY FOR K. TWELVE THAT IS
THROUGH THE IMPERIAL OFFICE OF
ANNA FORWARD COMMUNICATIVE THREW
BICU COMMUNICANTS.
I AM THREE CSU IT'S THROUGH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND YOU SEE
THROUGH THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
GOD ALMOST SEEM LIKE BE BETTER
THAT EACH ONE OF THEM WOULD BE
BRIEF QUESTION THE MONEY SIR.
RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING IT
VERSES I JUST DON'T TWENTY
MILLION BUCKS OUT THERE AND
SAYING.
DO DO GOOD AND GO FORTH.
OKAY.
VERY CONFUSED THANK I'VE THIS
NOTHING LIKE I'VE EVER SEEN
BEFORE AS TO DO CONTRACTING. FOR
ME GO OVER TWENTY YEARS IN THE
MILITARY AND WE HAVE A VERY
CLEAR. BEFORE WE'RE GONNA COMMIT
FEDERAL FUNDS TO SOMETHING WE
HAVE A CONTRACT IN OFFICIALS
RESPONSIBLE EXECUTING EVERYTHING
WHERE BAND FOR. IN THE THIS
APPEARS TO BE FIVE DIFFERENT
PEOPLE IN A CONTRACT.
AND IT'S DIFFERENT WITH THIS
GROUP DIFFERENT OF THAT GROUP
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE THAT LITTLE
AT.
YOU KNOW TEXAS HAS A* HOUSE
IN A LITTLE HAT DANCE AROUND.
YOU KNOW YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SO.
A.
THANKS.
OKAY ON.
SHARE WHAT'S.
OKAY. WE'LL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN
WILL NOW PROCEED WITH THE NEXT
STATE LIBRARY PROPOSAL RELATES
TO RESOURCE SHARING.
BERMAN A FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
ONE POINT FOUR FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND.
GO BE USED TO DEVELOP TO ONLINE
SERVICE SYSTEMS.
ONE MILLION WILL BE USED TO HELP
ESTABLISH A ZIPLOC SYSTEM.
THIS ALLOWS LIBRARY PATRONS IN
MORE THAN A FAT IN MORE RURAL
AREAS.
TO PURCHASE MATERIALS THAT WOULD
THEN BECOME PART OF THEIR
LIBRARY'S COLLECTION.
FURTHER FORTUNE FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS WILL BE USED TO CREATE
MORE LOAN PROGRAMS BETWEEN MY RE
DISTRICTS.
THE COUNTIES NORTH OF SAN
FRANCISCO HAVE AGREED TO CONNECT
THEIR ONLINE CATALOGS.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD PROBABLY
PROVIDE THE INITIAL.
SET UP BE IS NECESSARY TO
ESTABLISH A CONNECTION.
THE HERB YOU HAVE TO ISSUES
BEFORE YOU HEAR THE ZIP PROPOSAL
AND THE PROPOSAL INVOLVING THE
AND A CONSORTIUM IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA BOTH ACTIVITIES. TO A
SEEM PRIMARILY TO HAVE LOCAL
BENEFITS IN OUR LOCAL ACTIVITIES
THAT LOCAL LIBRARIES CAN.
ALREADY PART YOU CAN ALREADY
SORT OF ENGAGE IN. SO IT IS THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDING WASN'T CLEAR TO US ABOUT
TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE AN ORGAN. PRIDE
A STATE FUNDING FOR THIS.
BUT UP O. THESE PRIORITIES WE
WOULD NOTE THAT.
THE STATE ALREADY PROVIDES
THREE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO THE A CALIFORNIA
LIGHT THE LIBRARY SERVICES ACT
ONE OF THE KEY. OF.
OUR REASONS FOR THAT AT ONE OF
THE KEY.
REASONS WHY THIS ACT EXISTS IS
TO FOSTER RESOURCE SHARING
ACROSS THE STATE AND SO YOU
COULD OF APPROPRIATE THAT
EXISTING THREE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THESE. ISSUES IF
THEY ARE PRIORITIES FOR YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU STATE LIBRARY.
COULD AGAIN I I WOULD SAY WHAT
WE WHAT I SAID BEFORE IS THAT
THESE ARE PART OF A GROUP OF
PROPOSALS THAT WERE MUTUALLY.
AGREED UPON AND CREATED BY THE.
BY THE ADMINISTRATION BY THE
SCENIC ROUTE HAVE LIVE ON THE
LAST ONE AND BY THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION THE VALUE
THAT I'VE SEEN.
IN VISITING PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES IN RURAL AREAS THAT
BENEFIT FROM ZIP BOOKS THAT TO
ME THAT DEMONSTRATE SAY.
PLOT PLENTY OF STATEWIDE VALUE
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU'RE
LIVING SOMEWHERE NORTH OF.
IF.
BACKING UP
SO A PRIMARY PURPOSE OF
LIBRARIES IS TO ON RAMP PEOPLE
TO WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING FOR
RIGHT TO PROVIDE INFORMATION.
SO HERE'S A ONE TIME EXPENDITURE
OF IT WHAT IS IT AGAIN THEN IT'S
LIKE FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
GRANDER OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THAT TAKES THE CATALOGS OF ALL
OF THE SMALLER LIBRARIES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA LINKS THEM
TOGETHER SO THAT YOU CAN SIT AT
YOUR LAPTOP FIND LOOK FOR A BOOK
THAT YOU WANT.
AND HIT A BUTTON
INCOME DEAR LIBRARIAN GET AS
OPPOSED TO GOING HERE SMALL
LIBRARY WITH THE SMALLER CATALOG
IN THESE ARE THE SORTS OF
MECHANISMS THAT HELP. LIBRARIES
DO A BETTER JOB OF FULFILLING
THEIR MISSION IN THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY.
OKAY AND.
RIGHT DUMPING AGAIN IF YOU TAKE
EVERY SINGLE THING ON THIS LIST
NINE POINT SEVEN MILLION.
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THAT IS THAT
IT'S LIKE LESS THAN ONE ONE
HUNDREDTH OF ONE PERCENT OF THE
STATE GENERAL FUND?
SO.
IT'S NOT LIKE WE'RE BREAKING THE
BANK AT MONTE CARLO HERE.
WELL SET OKAY.
MR MEDINA. TO THE STATE
LIBRARIAN COULD YOU JUST GIVE ME
A LITTLE BIT MORE EXPLAINED TO
ME THAT ZIP BOOK.
PROGRAM AS IT LOOKS AS A
DIFFERENT IT'S A DIFFERENT
METHOD OF DELIVERY THAT USES THE
ONLINE MARKETPLACE SO NORMALLY
YOU'D WALK INTO A LIBRARY IN
YOUR DISTRICT AND SAY I WANT
THIS BOOK THE LIBRARY SAYS WE
DON'T HAVE IT. WILL BORROW IT
FROM ANOTHER LIBRARY SO THAT CAN
TAKE UP TO TWO WEEKS BASICALLY
OF THAT PUT IT ON A TRUCK AND
DRIVE IT TO YOUR LOCATION.
THIS IS THE OPPOSITE OF THAT SO
YOU COME OF THE LIBRARIAN SAID I
WANT THIS BOOK THEY SAY WE DON'T
HAVE IT. WILL BITE FOR IT WHEN
IT SHOWS UP IN YOUR MAILBOX A
DAY OR TWO LATER BY USING THE
ONLINE MARKETPLACE WHEN YOU'RE
DONE. YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
LIBRARY.
AND.
THEY PUT IT ON THE SHELF THEY
ADDED TO THEIR COLLECTION.
OR IF THEY'VE ALREADY GOT YOU
KNOW.
PLENTY OF COPIES OF IT THEY THEY
SELL UNDER USE THAT.
IN SOME OTHER WAY TO BENEFIT
THE LIBRARY AND THIS WOULD
PROVIDE SIXTY THOUSAND OF THOSE.
IS WHAT IN IRAN'S ACTIONS RIGHT
TRANSACTIONS
IT DOESN'T A YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
GONNA TAKE THE PLACE OF
BORROWING IN EVERY CIRCUMSTANCE
I MEAN IT WORKS WITH.
LIKE WHAT YOU CAN GET EASILY ON
THE ONLINE MARKETPLACE SO IF
YOU'RE IN TWO IF YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR SOMETHING TECHNICAL THEIR
ACADEMIC OR.
.
AND GET YOU KNOW LIKE
GENEALOGICAL SORT OF SOMETHING
VERY SPECIFIC YOU SEE THE
LOANING THE TRADITIONAL LOAN
PROGRAM IS REALLY. ALL THAT YOU
CAN USE BUT THIS AN ALTERNATIVE
AND WHAT THEY FIND IT WHAT'S. GO
FIGURE IS THAT MOST OF THESE
BOOKS THAT ARE BOUGHT THROUGH
ZIP BOOKS RIGHT CIRCULATE MORE
THAN THE OTHER ONES BECAUSE IT'S
LIKE WHAT PEOPLE WANT TO READ
THROUGH THE ODDLY ENOUGH RIGHT.
THEIR SETS THANK YOU.
OKAY.
THANK YOU WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE.
OPEN AS WELL.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE.
LIBRARY LITERACY SERVICES.
ABOUT.
WHAT IS YOUR IN TWENTY FIVE
LIBRARY JURISDICTIONS
VOLUNTARILY PARTICIPATE IN THE
STATEWIDE LEIBER'S LIBRARY
LITERACY PROGRAM?
THE SERVICES PROVIDED BY THESE
LOCAL LIBRARIES COMPLEMENT
EFFORTS BY OTHER STATE PROGRAMS
TO INCREASE LITERACY LEVELS
AMONG SAW AGE GROUPS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES.
PROPOSES PROVIDING TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
GENERAL FUND TO EXPAND THESE
PROGRAMS.
THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING PROVIDED
IN THIS PROPOSAL. WILL INCREASE
BASED NINE PER CAPITA AND MATCH
FUNDING PAYMENTS TO LOCAL
LIBRARIES PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM.
OKAY LA OF.
WE HAVE FOUR CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL I WANTED TO WALK
THROUGH EACH CONCERN YOUR HONOR
THE FIRST CONCERN IS.
THAT THE STATE ALREADY SPENDS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON EDUCATION
AND ADULT EDUCATION THROUGH
THINGS LIKE THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
DON'T EDUCATION THROUGH.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
APPORTIONMENT OF PORTION MINTS
ADULT EDUCATION BLOCK GRANTS.
SO WASN'T CLEAR TO US WANNA AN
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION OF A FEW
MILLION MORE DOLLARS WOULD HAVE
OVERALL IN THE STATE'S I'M GIVEN
THIS SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
SPENDING ALREADY.
SECONDLY OTHER LOCAL LIBRARY
PROGRAMS DON'T APPEAR TO BE
NECESSARILY WELL COORDINATED
WITH EXISTING STATE EFFORTS.
FOR EXAMPLE EXISTING LAW
ENCOURAGES LOCAL LIBRARIES TO A
PARTICIPATING THE ADULT
EDUCATION OUR CONSORTIA BUT DOES
NOT REQUIRE THEM TO ANECDOTALLY
REFER TO NEXT SOME SOME
LIBRARIES DO PARTICIPATE SOME I
DO NOT.
I MEAN IT'S IT'S IT'S SOME WITH
SOME THAT WE'VE HEARD SIMILAR
THINGS ABOUT.
THEIR INVOLVEMENT WITH LOCAL
SCHOOLS.
THIRD THE STATE ALSO LACKS A
CLEAR GOALS ON ADULT LITERACY
OVERALL IN STATE OF FOR ALL OF
THESE PROGRAMS SO IT'S DIFFICULT
TO ASSESS VIA. A WHAT MICHAEL'S
THE WAY IT WENT WITH THE STATE'S
A ACCOMPLISHING WITH THESE
PROGRAMS ON HOW THE WEATHER NOT
WE'RE ON TRACK TO ACCOMPLISH
THESE GOALS.
AND FINALLY THE STATE LACKS A
CLEAR POLICY ON O. HOW SHARED OB
PROGRAM COST BETWEEN THE STATE
AND LOCAL FUNDING.
THE RELEASE REASONS WE RECOMMEND
YOU REJECT THE PROPOSAL.
HOWEVER IF YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE AN AUGMENTATION WE DO
HAVE SOME SUGGESTIONS ON ON WAYS
YOU COULD IMPROVE THE PROGRAM TO
ENSURE ITS MEETING STATE
PRIORITIES.
THAT INCLUDES AYE RA REVISING
LOTS REQUIRE LIBRARIES AS A
CONDITION OF RECEIVING FUNDING.
TO PARTICIPATE WITH A CLUB WHO
OTHER LOCAL EDUCATION BUT A
PROVIDERS OF PARTICIPATE IN THE
ADULT EDUCATION CONSORTIA FOR
EXAMPLE. WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT
YOU ESTABLISH AN ADULT LITERACY
GOAL FOR THE STATE AND THEN OF
REQUIRE PERIODIC REPORTING.
TO ENSURE THAT A WERE MAKING
PROGRESS TOWARDS ACHIEVING THAT
OF ADULT LITERACY GOAL.
THE FAMILY RECOMMEND THAT YOU
HAVE A MORE FORMAL POLICY IN
MIND BOUGHT SHARING OF COSTS
BETWEEN STATE AND LOCAL FUNDING
SO THAT YOU HAVE A BASIS TO.
SORT OF THE TERM THAT EACH YEAR.
THANK YOU.
STATE LIBRARY.
WELL ALL OF THE SUGGESTIONS AT
THE END OF JASON'S PRESENTATION.
WHAT WOULD?
CONCEPTUALLY MAKE A LOT OF SENSE
RIGHT THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
STATE ENTITIES THAT.
FOCUS ON IMPROVING LITERACY
THERE'S A LOT OF NON PROFITS TO
FOCUS ON THAT THERE'S ANY NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING
TOWARDS THE SAME GOAL. AND
BETTER COORDINATION.
WOULD BE A GOOD THING.
THE TWO POINT FIVE MILLION HERE
THIS IS A PROGRAM IS DANCE SAID
THAT COMPLEMENTS SOME OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT LIKE AN
ADULT THAT WE'VE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION AT PREVIOUS
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS.
WHERE THE?
THE.
.
THE COURSE WORK THE CLASSES THE
EDUCATION THAT HAPPENS AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL. OR AN
ADULT EDUCATION IT YOU OFTEN
NEED SOME BASIC.
LEVEL OF LITERACY TO BENEFIT
FROM
AND THAT'S LARGELY THE SORT OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING INTO THIS
LIBRARY PROGRAM
PRIMARILY WOMEN. IN A PRIMARILY.
LET LATINO WHO ARE WHO ARE
LOOKING FOR A WAY TO.
IMPROVE EITHER THEIR ECONOMIC
CONDITION ARE PROVE THEIR
ACADEMIC STANDING.
WE ALSO FOUND THAT.
INCLUDING FAMILIES IN LITERACY
PROGRAMS IMPROVES THE.
SUCCESS RATE OF THE ADULT
LEARNERS THAT FOR ALL THE
REASONS YOU WOULDN'T THINK OF.
AND ALSO BY INVOLVING KIDS YOU
CAN YOU HAVE A BETTER SHOT AT
ENDING THE CYCLE OF THE LITERACY
IN FAMILIES WITHOUT THE EXPENSE
OF CATCHING SOMEBODY. YOU KNOW
SORT OF THEM ADULTHOOD.
AND AND YOU'RE LIKE YOU KNOW IF
IF YOU STOOD ON MY SHOULDERS AS
A STACK OF STUDIES THAT TALKS
ABOUT HOW KIDS NOT READING AT A
THIRD GRADE READING LEVEL BY
THIRD GRADE. ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS
TO THEIR LIFE PROJECTORS.
OKAY THANK YOU I I KNOW WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING THIS ISSUE FOR A
FEW YEARS AND I'LL JUST NOTE
THAT TIME. YET WE DO HAVE.
THE LITERACY PROGRAMS AND.
ADULT EDUCATION COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
BUT.
NOT ENOUGH AND SOME PEOPLE.
DON'T LIKE TO GO THE DON'T
EDUCATION THEY WANT TO GO THERE
COMMITTEE CALLS PER SE BUT MAYBE
THEY GO TO THE THOSE LOCAL
LIBRARIAN SO.
I THINK THAT UP MORE.
VARIETY AND MORE OPTIONS IS IS
A BETTER THING IN THIS FRONT
SO I CERTAINLY SUPPORT.
GET OUT THE STATE SPENDING MORE
RESOURCES I I DO THINK THAT YOU
THE LA OR DOES.
I RAISE THEM. SOME GOOD
QUESTIONS THAT MAYBE CAN LOOK AT
THAT.
COST SHARING MODELS AND INTENT
AND TIE IN A MORE.
.
BY UNIFIED STATEWIDE APPROACH
WITH ALL OF OUR.
EFFORTS FOCUSING ON THIS BUT
HAVING THESE PROGRAMS ARE LEFT
LOCAL LIBRARIES.
I KNOW IT'S SOMETHING I SUPPORT
MAKE SENSE OF SEEN HERE LOCALLY
IN OUR IN OUR SACRAMENTO
COMEDIAN OUR OUR LOCAL. LIBRARY
DIRECTORS HERE TESTIFIED PUBLIC
COMMENT AS WELL ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BROTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER CHAVIS.
ARE YOU SURE THAT.
COMMENTS STATED BY THE CHAIR.
OF AND. YOU KNOW WE FORM THE
CONSORTIUM'S TO DO ADULT
LITERATURE ADULT LITERACY ALSO.
IN THOSE ARE WORKING OUT REALLY
WELL BUT WE'RE STILL NOT PROCESS
BUT. NOT EVERYBODY'S GOING TO GO
TO THOSE.
ESPECIALLY START LOOK IN THE
MORE RURAL AREAS IN ROLE
LIBRARIES A PLANE. AND THE
VOLUNTEERS IN INEQUALITY A
COMMUNITY.
SUPPORT YOU GET SO OBVIOUS
SUPPORTIVE ALSO WHICH I THINK.
A BROAD BRUSH TO REACH EVERYONE
IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE.
GREAT DIVERSITY WE'RE BRINGING
WITHIN OUR STATE IS AN IMPORTANT
THING TO CONTINUE TO INVEST AND
SO ON THE SUPPORT OF THANK YOU.
BUT AGAIN I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU ALL TO FIND WAYS WHERE
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT ENTITIES
THAT PARTICIPATE IN LITERACY. DO
A BETTER JOB OF TALKING TO ONE
ANOTHER AND FIGURING OUT HOW WE
CAN.
USE THE BOX THAT WE HAVE TO
BETTER ADVANTAGE I MEAN NO HARM
EVER COMES FROM PEOPLE TALKING
TO ONE ANOTHER I AGREE THAT'S
ONE OF THE DISCUSSION WE HAD
YESTERDAY WITH THE REPUBLICANS
ABOUT. HOW WE CAN?
COMMUNICATE BETTER BUT WELL LIKE
I SAY WHAT WHEN I'M HAPPY SO.
TO WORK ON THAT WITH THE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU THING NO MORE
QUESTIONS. ISSUE NUMBER BEHOLD
THIS ISSUE UP ISSUE NUMBER SIX
WORLD HISTORIES.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. INCLUDES
AN AUGMENTATION OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE ORAL
HISTORY PROGRAM.
THIS FUNDING WOULD ESTABLISH AN
ADVISORY BOARD CHAIRED BY THE
STATE ARCHIVIST
DIGITALLY PRESERVE EXISTING ORAL
HISTORIES. AND.
CREATE NEW ORAL HISTORIES EACH
YEAR.
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU APPEARS
TO BE CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE
LIBRARY'S MISSION OF PRESERVING
CALIFORNIA HISTORY SO WE DON'T
TAKE ISSUE WITH THAT WE
RECOMMEND YOU ADOPT IT. WOULD
YOU SUGGEST ONE A MODIFICATION
THOUGH AND THAT IS THAT YOU
CONSIDER MAKING IT LIMITED TERM
RATHER THAN ON GOING MAKING IT
LIMITED TERM WOULD ALLOW YOU TO
REVISIT THIS PROGRAM IN A FEW
YEARS. REVIEW WHAT WAS WHAT CAME
ABOUT BECAUSE OF THE PROGRAM HOW
MANY ORAL HISTORIES WERE
DEVELOPED REVIEW THE COSTS AND
THEN MAKE A BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS
ACCORDINGLY BASED ON THOSE
FINDINGS.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE LEAVING IT OPEN RIGHT
CHAIR WHAT I'M EXCITED ABOUT
LEAVING IT OPEN.
OKAY.
YEAH THINKS I SHOULD RUB. YET
NOT IT'S HARD TO CONTAIN MYSELF
OKAY I I WILL NOT YEAR THAT.
AND.
THAT YEAH WE DO THIS.
SUPPORT THIS HAPPEN YOU KNOW
ANYWAY WE CAN DOCUMENT.
HISTORY IS THERE'S I THINK
CRITICAL AND AND I THINK YOU
KNOW HERE. SOME OF THE.
SOME ORAL HISTORIES OF A PEOPLE
LIKE OUR CURRENT GOVERNOR FORMER
SPEAKER WILLIE BROWN. AND SOME
OF OUR LEGENDS ARE GONNA BE
AROUND FOREVER. AND SO ON ONE
THING THAT I WANTED TO ADD ON TO
ITS THE WORKLOAD. IS TAKING A
LOOK AT THE LEGISLATURE. AYE WE
HAVE FOR EXAMPLE SOME OF OUR ACT
CAUCUSES SOME OF OUR ETHNIC
CAUCUS IS THE WOMAN'S* IS TO
KNOW THAT.
ROLL CAUCUS WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN
AROUND FOR DECADES AND IT'S
ALWAYS INTRIGUING TO TO DOCUMENT
THAT FOR EXAMPLE WE HAD THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY LAST YEAR.
OF THE CURRENT BLACK OBSERVE
CAUCUS I THINK THAT. THE LATINO
THAT WOULD SAVE CAUCUSES COMING
UP ON A ON A LANDMARK
ANNIVERSARIES WELL. AND SO WE
WANT TO ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER
THAT WHILE WE WILL LIKELY PUT
ADDITIONAL MONEY INTO THIS
PROPOSAL. AND THAT WORK ON A
WORK PLAN TO LOOK AT THOSE
ISSUES AS WELL. WHAT I THINK
THAT'S A TERRIFIC STORY TO TELL?
TRIPLET BUT I'D BE VERY HAPPY TO
HELP WITH THAT. IN ENOUGH I MADE
THE THIS WOULD OFFICE IT WOULD
BE NICE TO LOOK AT.
OF THE DIVERSITY THE* IS IN
A* IS SO WILLING TO LET.
OTHER.
BIPARTISAN PEOPLE BE A PART OF
THE ONE OF MY PERSONAL ISSUES AS
BEING A LATINO HERE FOR SIX
YEARS. NEVER BEING ALLOWED TO BE
PART OF THE LATINO CAUCUS I
THINK WE DO HISTORY WE NEED TO
DO THE FULL SWEEP OF WHAT THE
HISTORY IS OF THESE CAUCUSES.
APPOINT ALL SET.
IF THREE IS NOT ALWAYS PERFECT
AND PRETTY MISTER THAT IS NOT
ENOUGH THROUGH. SO MISTER CHAIR
YEAH MISTER O'DONNELL WE'RE
GONNA SPEND A BUNCH OF MONEY
TELLING PEOPLE HOW GREAT WE ARE.
IS REALLY A WISE USE OF TAXPAYER
MONEY.
I JUST BAFFLES ME AT WHAT WHAT
SPECIFIC ACT ARE YOU REFERENCING
MISTER O'DONNELL.
OR INTERPERSONAL LAWLER AND AND
THE ADULT I GUESS THE HOPE
PROPOSAL AS IT SPEAKS TO THE
LEGISLATURE I JUST THINK.
HI I JUST I'M CURIOUS AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S A WISE
EXPENDITURE.
THERE ENOUGH.
OKAY WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN.
AND WE WILL MOVE ON TO.
ISSUE NUMBER WILL SKIP TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO.
SKIP IS NUMBER ONE. THIS IS A
CROSS CUTTING ISSUE WITH YOU SEE
CSU AND TOO MANY COLLEGES LAST
YEAR WE HAD. A DISCUSSION ABOUT.
.
HUNGER AND THE. PROBLEM WE SEE
AT MANY OF OUR CAMPUSES WITH.
STUDENTS HAVING A TOUGH TIME.
THANK FOR THE BASICS INCLUDING
FOOD AND WE PUTS IN THE BUDGET
SOME RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH
STUDENT HUNGER WHAT TO. HAVE AN
UPDATE ON THAT HOW THAT'S GOING.
TO TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE AS WELL.
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR INVITING US
TO SHARE SOME BRIEF COMMENTS
TODAY.
MY NAME IS TINGLE ARE NO.
AND I'M FROM UC SANTA CRUZ WITH
ME IS REMAIN KANETO FROM UC
BERKELEY. WE CO CHAIR THE YOU
SEE GLOBAL FOOD INITIATIVES FOOD
ACCESS TO BASIC NEEDS EFFORT.
SO IN THIS ROLE FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS WE'VE COORDINATED
EFFORTS ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT AND TEN
CAMPUSES.
ESTABLISHING EFFECTIVE SYSTEM
WIDE IN CAMPUS LEVEL PROGRAMMING
RESEARCH AND EVALUATION.
MEASURES TO ADVANCE
INSTITUTIONALIZING BEST
PRACTICES GOING FORWARD.
THROUGH THE GLOBAL FOOD
INITIATIVE COUPLED WITH THIS
YEAR WITH LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT
THROUGH HUNGER FREE CAMPUS
FUNDING. OUR EFFORTS HAVE
INCLUDED LAUNCHING IN SCALING UP
NUTRITIOUS AND CHOICE BASED FOOD
PANTRIES ON ALL CAMPUSES.
INCREASING ACCESS TO FOOD
PROVISIONING OF PREPARATION
WORKSHOPS AND SERVICES.
SPENDING SWIPE ON HUNGER
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW YOU SEE
STUDENTS TO DONATE EXCESS MEAL
PLAN DOLLARS TO STUDENTS IN NEED
ON ALL CAMPUSES.
IN ESTABLISHING COLLABORATIONS
WITH STATING COUNTY OFFICES TO
REGISTER STUDENTS FOR CAL FRESH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S
NUTRITION ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
AS WORK ON FOOD INSECURITY HAS
PROGRESSED IT BECAME CLEAR THAT
FOOD INSECURITY IS JUST ONE
ELEMENT UNDER A BROADER A
BROTHER. OF BASIC NEEDS THAT
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THE UNIQUE
HARDSHIPS PRESENTED BY THE
OVERALL COST OF ATTENDANCE FOR
STUDENTS INCLUDING FOOD. HOUSING
AND WELLNESS RELATED EXPENSES
AND DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
PUBLISH OUR LARGEST STUDY TO
DATE THAT YOU SEE STUDENT FOOD
HOUSING SECURITY STUDY ARE MAJOR
LESSONS LEARNED FROM OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND UNDERGRADUATE. AND SIX
THOUSAND GRADUATE STUDENT
PARTICIPANTS PERTAIN TO OUR
HUNGER FREE CAMPUS EFFORTS AS
FOLLOWS.
AT PRESENT WE ARE ADDRESSING THE
GENERAL UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
POPULATION FACING FORTY FOUR
PERCENT COMBINED LOW IN VERY LOW
FOOD SECURITY LEVELS. BY
UTILIZING A MULTI FACTOR
ANALYSIS THAT DETERMINES THE
MOST AT RISK GROUPS AND
PRIORITIZING SUPPORT STRATEGIES
FOR THEM.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX PERCENT
OF GRADUATE STUDENTS EXPANDS
FOOD INSECURITY DURING THE
ACADEMIC YEAR WE HAVE DEVELOPED
BETTER GUIDANCE SYSTEMS FOR CAL
FRESH BENEFIT ENROLLMENT
QUALIFICATION FOR GRADUATE
STUDENTS AS WELL AS UTILIZE
MOTIVE. FACTOR ANALYSIS TO
IDENTIFY THE GREATER AT RISK
GROUPS.
ADDRESSING BASIC NEEDS AS A
NOTABLE EFFECT ON ACADEMIC
SUCCESS AND ACHIEVEMENT DATA
FROM ANALYSIS INDICATES THE
MAJORITY OF UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING BOTH FOOD
INSECURITY IN HOMELESSNESS WERE
BELOW THAT THREE POINT OH GPA
WHICH HAS A DIRECT IMPACT ON
THEIR ON AND OFF CAMPUS. STUDENT
EMPLOYABILITY ACCESS TO RESEARCH
PROGRAMS AND POST GRADUATION
OPPORTUNITIES.
ONLY SEVENTY PERCENT OF GRADUATE
STUDENTS WERE EXPERIENCE
FOURTEEN SECURITY AND HOMELESS
THAT'S REPORT BEING ON TRACK TO
COMPLETE THEIR DEGREE ON TIME.
COMPARED TO EIGHTY TWO PERCENT
OF STUDENTS WHO ARE BOTH FOOD
AND HOUSING SECURE. WE CONTINUE
TO MATCH OUR RESEARCH WITH APPLY
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION IN
STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES ARE NOT
PASSIVE BACK TO TIM TO SHARE
ABOUT A HUNGER FOR CAMPUS
IMPACTS AND UPDATES.
SO PUBLIC CONFIRMATION OF THE
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION IN THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET FOR THE UC
SYSTEM EACH CAMPUS WAS AWARDED
THE QUALIFICATIONS OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND.
WE SHARED MEASURE BONE
REPORTABLE OUTCOMES ASSOCIATED
WITH A BEFORE FIFTY THREES
FUNDING FOCUS.
AT EACH CAMPUS FUNDING WAS
DIRECTED AT FOUR SPECIFIC AREAS.
EMERGENCY MEALS CAL FRESH OUT
REACHING ENROLLMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM STAFFING
SUPPORT.
SO THEN EMERGENCY MEALS HUNGER
FREE CAMPUS FUNDING IS SUPPORTED
STUDENTS WITH THE LARGEST
PERSONAL POLICY INSTITUTIONAL
BARRIERS TO SUSTAIN THEIR BASIC
NEEDS.
SUPPORT INCLUDES INVESTING OVER
FORTY THOUSAND DINING MEAL
VOUCHERS ARE SWIPES.
AS WELL AS INCREASED SOURCING OF
FRESH HEALTHY AND DIVERSE FOOD
OFFERINGS FOR PANTRY AND
DISTRIBUTION FOOD SERVICES.
SERVING OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED UNIQUE STUDENTS
OVER THE LAST FOUR MONTHS ALONE
ACROSS ALL TEN CAMPUSES.
STUDENT HEALTH FRESH WORK HAS
INCLUDED WORKING IN CONCERT WITH
CDSS AS CALPERS PROGRAM LEADS AS
WELL AS OUR PARTNERS IN THE CSU
NCCC. TO INCLUDE CAL FRESH
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
STUDENT AWARENESS APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE AND SUCCESSFUL
ENROLLMENT BENEFITS
TO DATE THIS YEAR YOU SEE
CAMPUSES HAVE ENROLLED A RENEWED
OVER EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. DRAWING IN OVER TEN
MILLION AND FEDERAL FUNDS
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE STATE
TOWARD CAMPUS COMMUNITIES.
WITH RESPECT INFRASTRUCTURE
CAMPUSES HAVE INCLUDED SPECIFIC
EQUIPMENT IN ORDER TO IMPROVE
FIND PANTRY FOOD AVAILABILITY.
INVESTMENTS IN CARTS
AS WELL AS FOOD PROVISIONING IN
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES.
ALL TEN CAMPUSES HAVE
ESTABLISHED A FRESH AND HEALTHY
CHOICE BASED PANTRY THAT INCLUDE
SUPPLEMENTAL EVENT SITE BASED
FOOD DISTRIBUTION.
WITH PROGRAM STAFFING SUPPORT
PART TIME SUPPORT IN THE FORM OF
STUFF PETE STUDENT INTERNS AS
WELL AS GRADUATE STUDENT
RESEARCH APPOINTMENTS WERE
INCLUDED TO DIRECTLY SUPPORT
PROGRAM OUTCOMES. OF THE HUNDRED
FREE CAMPUS AB FOR FIFTY THREE
FUNDING. IN ADDITION YOU SEE HAS
PROVIDED I'M GOING SYSTEM I
COORDINATION OF HIS EFFORTS
COUPLED WITH IN PERSON CONVENING
AN ONLINE MONTHLY MEETING
SUPPORT. AND SUPPLEMENTAL CAMPUS
LEVEL STOP TIME DEDICATED TO THE
SUCCESS OF A BEFORE FIFTY THREE
OUTCOMES.
HUNGER FOR CAMPUS FUNDING WAS
ESSENTIAL THE SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN ACADEMIC YEAR.
ALL OF OUR COURT ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES HAVE CONFIRMED THAT THE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
AWARDED BY YOU OUR STATE
LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN ASCENSION
CONTRIBUTING TOWARD PROVIDING
THE GROWING NEED OF SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS.
THE LESSONS LEARNED THAT ON AND
OFF CAMPUS RELATIONSHIP
STRENGTHENED AND THE IMPROVE
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL PROVIDE EVEN
MORE EXPENSIVE STUDENT IMPACT
WITH YOUR CONTINUED FUNDING.
PERVASIVE LEVELS OF FOOD
INSECURITY AND HOMELESS AS AT
CCC UC AND CSU SYSTEMS SPEAKS TO
A STATEWIDE NEED FOR INCREASED
STUDENT SUPPORT FOR BASIC NEEDS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE FUTURE
POSSIBILITY OF LEVERAGING
FURTHER FUNDING THAT IS
ADDITIONAL TO OUR EDUCATION
FUNDING YOUR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
WILL ENSURE THAT EACH CAMPUS
ACCOMPLISHES THE FOR FOLLOWING.
NUMBER ONE HAS A SAFE AN
ATTRITION SPACE THAT WILL KEEP A
STUDENT FROM GOING WITHOUT FOOD.
TO SCALE CAO FRESH EFFORTS TO
EDUCATE AND ROLL THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS PER CAMPUS.
OPERATE FACILITIES WERE STUDENTS
WILL FEEL THEY BELONG AND ARE
BEING SEARCHED PRO ACTIVELY AND
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT MANNER
FURTHERING THE POTENTIAL FOR
ACADEMIC SUCCESS AND RETAIN
STUDENT AND PROFESSIONAL STAFF
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE TO CARRY
OUT THESE COMMITMENTS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO COLLEGE STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS.
OKAY.
IF YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS.
DENISE BADLY AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF STUDENT WELLNESS AND
BASIC NEEDS INITIATIVE FOR THE
CSU AND TO START I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK. ALL OF YOU.
AND YOUR LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUES
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF OUR EFFORTS
TO MEET THE BASIC NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS.
THE TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ALLOCATED.
BY THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO THE CSU HAS BEEN
DISPERSED ALL TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES.
TO HELP THEM BECOME DESIGNATED
AS HUNGER FREE THESE FUNDS WILL
BE CRITICAL IN HELPING ARTS
CAMPUSES DEVELOP IMPLMENT AND
ENHANCE RESOURCES RELATED TO
FOOD INSECURITY. AND ALSO
HOUSING DISPLACEMENT FORA
ALLOCATION WE.
WE DAY ARE IF PEOPLE ASK US FOR
THAT. AYE AND HAD CAMPUSES TO
SUBMIT PROPOSALS FOR FUNDING FOR
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THOUGHTFUL IMPLEMENTATION AND
EVALUATION.
THE SERGEANT DISTRIBUTED THIS
HAND OUT HERE.
AT ALL REFER TO IT THROUGHOUT
MY PRESENT A THROUGHOUT MY
COMMENTS.
SQUEEZING.
SIDE ONE TO PIXAR COMMITMENT TO
THE SEAT TO CSU STUDENTS AND
THEIR ACADEMIC AND FUTURE
SUCCESS.
IT NECESSITATES A COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORTING THEIR BASIC NEEDS
ONCE STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS ARE
NOT ADDRESS IT CAN HAVE AN
IMPACT ON BOTH A PERSONAL AND
ACADEMIC GROWTH IMPEDING THEIR
ABILITY TO ACHIEVE THEIR GOALS
AND EARNED A DEGREE. THIS IS WHY
STUDENT WHILE BEING AS A
PRIORITY IN OUR GRADUATION
TWENTY. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
INITIATIVE THE CS USE PLAN TO
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN GRADUATE IN A TIMELY MANNER.
POSITIVELY IMPACTING THEIR
FUTURE IN PRODUCING ADDITIONAL
GRADUATES TO POWER CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AND INNOVATION.
TURNING TO FLY TO THE CS USE
BASIC NEEDS INITIATIVE THAT THE
SYSTEM WIDE EFFORT TO COORDINATE
SERVICES AROUND CAMPUSES.
SKINNER.
HELPING THEM REACH ALL STUDENTS
IN NEED OF SUPPORT. INITIATIVE
IS STRUCTURED AROUND FIVE KEY
AREAS ADDRESSING THE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS.
GROWING CAMPUS BASS BAIT. CAMPUS
BASED BASIC NEEDS SERVICES SO
THEY CAN REACH ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS
SCALING BEST PRACTICES FROM ONE
CAMPUS TO ANOTHER. WORKING WITH
PARTNERS AND ENSURING LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY OF BASIC NEEDS
SERVICES.
AND FEBRUARY WE RELEASE OUR
FAITH TO COMPREHENSIVE RESEARCH
STUDY OF BASIC NEEDS IN THE CSU.
WE ALSO HAD A SYSTEM WIDE BASIC
NEEDS INITIATIVE CONFERENCE
WHICH BROUGHT TOGETHER CLOSE TO
THREE HUNDRED ATTENDEES TO SHARE
BEST PRACTICES PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEARN FROM
NATIONAL EXPERTS. AND DEVELOP
ACTION PLANS FOR FURTHER PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT TO ADDRESS STUDENT
BASIC MEANS.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WEBER PROVIDE A
POWERFUL INSPIRING WORDS
CHALLENGING US TO CONTINUE
WORKING TOWARDS ERADICATING
STUDENT HOME HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
SEE WHAT CSU CAMPUSES HAVE BEEN
HARD AT WORK MAKING STUDENTS TO
RESOURCES SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
THAT ADDRESS FOOD INSECURITY
HOUSING DISPLACEMENT
HOMELESSNESS AND FINANCIAL
CRISIS.
ON FLIGHT THREE FOR STUDENTS
STRUGGLING WITH FOOD INSECURITY
ALL TWENTY THREE OF OUR CAMPUSES
HAVE A FOOD PANTRY OR FOOD
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM. ALL
CAMPUSES PROVIDE CAL FRESH
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE TO
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS SO THEY MIGHT
HAVE HEALTHY EATING OPTIONS AND
A MAJORITY OF CAMPUSES OFFER
MEALS TO THE MEAL THROUGH EMAIL
SHARING PROGRAM ARE MIL ABOUT
TRICKS PROGRAM.
ON SLIDE FOR YOU'LL SEE THAT CSU
CAMPUSES ALSO PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH SHORT TERM EMERGENCY
HOUSING MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF
OUR CAMPUSES OFFER ON CAMPUS
EMERGENCY HOUSING OR VOUCHERS
FOR OFF CAMPUS HOUSING.
FOR EXAMPLE AT CSU CHICO STOP
PROVIDE STUDENTS FACING.
AND EMERGE I'M FACING.
CRISIS EMERGENCY HOUSING HOTEL
VOUCHERS TO PROVIDE SHORT TERM
RELIEF. AND THE CAMPUS WILL
SERVE AS A CO SIGNER ON LEASE
AGREEMENTS.
TO HELP STUDENTS TRANSITION INTO
LONG TERM HOUSING.
SIMILARLY CSU NORTHRIDGE WILL
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR SECURITY
DEPOSITS TO HELP STUDENTS IN
NEED OF TO PROCURE HOUSING.
AND ON FLIGHT FIVE CSU CAMPUSES
ALSO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS IN NEED
MORE THAN EIGHTY PERCENT OF CSU
STUDENTS RECEIVE SOME FORM OF
NON LOAN AID. BUT BEYOND FEDERAL
STATE AND INSTRUCTIONAL
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS THE
MAJORITY OF OUR CAMPUSES ALSO
OFFER EMERGENCY GRANTS ARE FUNDS
FOR EXAMPLE SAN JOSE STATE
OFFERS EMERGENCY GRANTS FOR
STUDENTS.
I DIED THAT THEY ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO REPAY. SACRAMENTO
STATE ALSO OFFERS EMERGENCY
GRANTS IN HOWTH WHO FINANCIAL
LITERACY WORKSHOPS TO TEACH
STUDENTS ABOUT MONEY MANAGEMENT
AND BUDGETING.
ON THE FINAL SLIDE WE ARE PROUD
OF THE VISION OUR CAMPUSES THAT
TAKEN TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS
HEAD ON AND CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THEIR EFFORTS FROM THE CHANCES
OFFICE. WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE
IS MUCH MORE TO BE DONE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH OUR
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
LEGISLATIVE ALLIES. TO HELP US
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS ARE
ABLE TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE SUCCESSFUL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MCCARTY
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
THE SUPPORT. OF BASIC NEEDS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS MY NAME IS COLLEEN
GANLEY AND I'M A PROGRAM
SPECIALIST WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. MY
WORK FOCUSES ON SUPPORTING THE
BASIC NEEDS OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS INCLUDING FOOD HOUSING
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ARE SYSTEM CURRENTLY
HAS APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT ONE.
TWO POINT ONE MILLION STUDENTS.
WE ARE SO PLEASED TO HAVE JUST
HOSTED OUR FIRST EVER CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BASIC NEEDS
SUMMIT WE HAD CLOSE TO THREE
HUNDRED FACULTY STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATORS ATTEND THE
SUMMIT.
TO LEARN ABOUT STRATEGIES AND
BEST PRACTICES IN SUPPORT OF
THEIR STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS WITH
THE LONG TERM GOAL OF
INSTITUTIONALIZING THESE BEST
PRACTICES. WERE HOPING TO MAKE
THIS AN ANNUAL OR BIANNUAL
EVENTS.
IN PREPARATION FOR IMPLEMENTING
THE HUNGER FREE CAMPUS CAMPAIGN
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CONDUCTED A
SYSTEM WIDE SURVEY REGARDING
FOOD SECURITY RESOURCES.
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS NINETY TWO
PERCENT OF THE COLLEGES HUNDRED
AND FIVE OF OUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES RESPONDED.
SIXTY EIGHT POINT FOUR PERCENT
REPORTED CAMPUS BASED FOOD
PANTRIES ALMOST FORTY EIGHT
PERCENT REPORTED COLLABORATION
WITH THE LOCAL FOOD BANKS TO
ACCESS LOW IN NO COST FOODS.
STOCK THEIR FOOD PANTRIES AND
ALMOST SIXTY TWO PERCENT
REPORTED PROVIDING CAL FRESH
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE TO THEIR
STUDENTS.
USING THE SURVEY DATA WE
DEVELOPED A BEST PRACTICES GUIDE
WHICH IS GOING TO BE DISTRIBUTED
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM THIS WEEK I
PROVIDED A COPY FOR YOU ALL AND
WE CAN ALSO MAKE THAT AVAILABLE
ELECTRONICALLY.
OF THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
UTILIZED EXISTING APPORTIONMENT
PROCESS HE'S TO DISTRIBUTE OUR
HUNGER CREEK HUNGER FREE CAMPUS
FUNDS TO ALL SEVENTY TWO
DISTRICTS.
THAT COVER A HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ACROSS THE
STATE.
THE ALLOCATION ENABLE THE
MULTITUDE OF FOOD SECURITY
RELATED ACTIVITIES ACROSS OUR
SYSTEM INCLUDING PROVIDING CAL
FRESHEN ROMAN INFORMATION AND
ROOM ROLE MEANT SUPPORT SERVICES
TO STUDENTS.
EXPANDING CAMPUS BASED FOOD
PANTRIES AND REGULAR FOOD
DISTRIBUTION ON OUR CAMPUSES
ESTABLISHING HOT MEAL VOUCHER
PROGRAMS DEVELOPING MEAL
DONATION GIFT BACK PROGRAMS
PROVIDING FINANCIAL LITERACY TO
OUR STUDENTS. CREATING FARMER
MARKET DONATION PROGRAMS AND AND
A FEW SITES ESTABLISHING
COMMUNITY GARDEN PROGRAMS.
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT THE COLLEGES
FOR IMPLEMENTING THE HUNGER FREE
CAMPUS CAMPAIGN WE PARTNERED
WITH OUR CSU PARTNERS AND HOSTED
ELEVEN REGIONAL TRAINING.
FOCUSED ON CALPERS ENROLLMENT
PROCESS
THERE WAS EXTENSIVE INTEREST
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM WE HAD EIGHTY
TWO COLLEGES SEND. OVER FIVE
HUNDRED COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY AND STAFF THAT RECEIVED
A DAYLONG TRAINING ABOUT HOW TO
SUPPORT THEIR STUDENTS AND
ROLLING CAO FRESH.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS TO HELP COLLEGES
CREATE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
LOCAL FOOD BANKS. AND WITH THEIR
COUNTY CAL FRESH STAFF AND WE'RE
DOING THIS COLLEGE BY COLLEGE
REGION BY REGION.
IT IS JUST CRITICAL FOR.
.
FOLKS IN OUR SYSTEM TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING EXTERNAL RELATIONSHIPS
WITH FOOD BANKS AND WITH COUNTY
CAL FRESH STAFF.
TO KEEP THIS GOING A MOVING
FORWARD WE HOPE TO EXPAND.
OUTREACH RESOURCE SURFEIT APPS
SORRY OUT REACH RESOURCES FOR
THE COLLEGES INCLUDING
PARTICIPATING IN AND SUPPORTING
THE DEVELOPMENT OF VIRTUAL CAO
FRESHEN ROMAN TRAININGS THAT ARE
BEING DEVELOPED BY THE CSU
SYSTEM. A WE HOPE TO PARTICIPATE
AND ALSO PROVIDE SOME INTERNAL
FUNDING FOR SPONSORSHIP FOR THAT
PROJECT.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS TO
CREATE LONG TERM INFRASTRUCTURE
TO SUPPORT THE FOOD SECURITY
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS THE ONETIME HUNGER FREE
CAMPUS ALLOCATIONS PROVIDED. HAS
ALLOWED THE COLLEGES TO INVEST
IN ITEMS NEEDED TO OFFER FOOD
PANTRY SERVICES RECEIVED HOW
FRESHEN ROMAN TRAINING AND
DEVELOP RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
LOCAL FOOD BANKS AND COUNTY CAL
FRESH STAFF.
WE ARE ENCOURAGING AND
SUPPORTING THE COLLEGES TO BEGIN
INSTITUTIONALIZING THESE
EFFORTS.
THANK YOU AND I'M OPEN TO ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE MONTH THANK
YOU THIS ERA HAS BEEN.
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE HAD A LOT
OF INTEREST IN.
LAST YEAR WE WERE ABLE TO RUN A
BILL AND WE GOT FUNDING FOR THIS
I'M JUST LAST WEEK I WAS AT THE
CSU CHANNEL ISLANDS CAMPUS.
A TALKING TO STUDENTS AND THIS
IS CLEARLY STILL AN ISSUE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WAS
MENTIONED IN THE COMMENTS WAS
THAT THERE WAS.
AND INTEND TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
BEST PRACTICES.
WHAT FROM BOTH A THING FOR ALL
THREE ENTITIES WHAT WHAT CAN WE
EXPECT THAT TO LOOK LIKE IN THE
FUTURE AS IF THIS PROBLEM
CONTINUES TO GROW AS THAT THAT
IS THAT? THE PROBLEM OF BASIC
NEEDS FOR STUDENT CONTINUES TO
GROW WHICH AS YOU'VE ALL STATED
HAS AN IMPACT ON ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES.
WELL I AYE WHICH IS SAY THAT FOR
OUR COLLEGES YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
HUNDRED FOURTEEN COLLEGES AND
TWO POINT ONE MILLION STUDENTS.
I THINK THAT IT IS CRITICAL
THAT WE HELP OUR COLLEGES GET
CONNECTED WITH THEIR LOCAL
RESOURCES BECAUSE THAT IS
SUSTAINABLE AND THAT MEANS
CREATING MO USE WITH THE COUNTY.
FOOD BANKS THAT INCLUDES
ESTABLISHING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE CAL FRESH OUT REACH FOLKS
THERE IN THOSE FOOD BANKS AND AT
THE COUNTIES.
OF OUR SYSTEM IT IS GOVERNED ON
IN PART BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WHICH MEANS DECISIONS HAPPEN
LOCALLY ABOUT WHAT RESOURCES
THEY HAVE ON CAMPUS AND WHAT
RESOURCES. ARE LOCATED IN THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE FULL
JURISDICTION TO. TO MAKE THEM DO
THAT BUT THE COLLEGES HAVE
SHOWN.
EXTREME WILLINGNESS TO PARTNER
WITH THOSE EXTERNAL ENTITIES AND
TO TO CREATE PROCESS HE'S AS
PART OF THEIR FINANCIAL AID
PROCESS AS PART OF THE
ENROLLMENT PROCESS. AND SO FOR
US THAT'S WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
IN TERMS OF INSTITUTIONALIZING
THE WORK. FIGHT I CAN'T SAY THAT
IT WILL HAPPEN AT A HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN COLLEGES BUT WE
CERTAINLY HAVE HEARD FROM MANY
MANY FOLKS.
WHO HAVE EXPRESSED INTEREST IN
THAT AND THEN ALSO LOOKING AT
YOU KNOW THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
HAVE A CAMPUS AND?
PRIORITIZING THE BASIC NEEDS
FOR THEIR STUDENTS.
I THINK I HAVE IF I COULD OFFER
US ON AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
OTHER LEADERSHIP IN THE QUALITY
TIME THAT YOU HAD IN THIS
CONVERSATION.
ARE ON SITES AND AND AND HERE
IN THE CAPITAL.
I THINK ONE OF THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH IS THE
FACT THAT THIS PROBLEM ISN'T
GOING TO GO ANYWHERE AND IT'S
AND ONLY GONNA GET WORSE WITH
THE INCREASED COST OF LIVING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE FACT THAT FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF STUDENTS CANNOT
CONTINUE TO COME INTO EITHER THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM THE CSU
SYSTEM ARE THE UC SYSTEM OR THE
PRIVATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
WITHOUT BEING INTRODUCED AND
TRAINED AND PREPARED FOR THE
BASIC NEEDS EXPERIENCE OF THE
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE.
TOO MANY STUDENTS RIGHT NOW
CALIFORNIA HAVE NEVER SEEN A
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE UNTIL THEY
GET THEIR FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE
WHEN THE GET INTO COLLEGE.
ODD TOO MANY STUDENTS RIGHT NOW
HAVE NEVER HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
THINK THROUGH HOW DO I CREATE MY
BUDGET AS A COLLEGE STUDENT.
IF I GET FINANCIAL AID WHAT IS
THAT LOOK LIKE IF I DON'T GET
FINANCIAL AID WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE AND THEN IN THE
COLLEGES THAT I'M APPLYING FOR
WHICH THE COST OF LIVING IN THAT
AREA AND HOW DO I COME PREPARED.
TO BE IN THAT AREA AND THE WAY
THAT I CAN TAKE CARE OF MY BASIC
NEEDS.
YES CAL FRESH IS A HUGE ONE
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE HISTORICALLY
COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE BEEN BEEN
ACTIVATED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CONVERSATION AND CAL FRESH IS
SOMETHING THAT ALL THREE SYSTEMS
ARE PRIORITIZING. BECAUSE THE
SIZE OF MOST SUSTAINABLE WAY OF
MAKING SURE THAT STUDENTS HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO BUY GROCERIES
TO TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES.
BUT.
PART OF THAT CONVERSATION CAN
HAPPEN. ONCE THEY'RE IN COLLEGE.
ALL OF THESE BASIC NEEDS
STRATEGY SHOULD BE TRAINED IN
SHOULD BE INTRODUCED TO STUDENTS
BEFORE THEY GET HERE. SO IN OUR
PRESENTATION TO THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION WE ALSO
BROUGHT THAT THERE BECAUSE THE
STATE IS FINDING SEVERAL PRE
COLLEGE.
I HAVE PRE COLLEGE PROGRAMS BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PRE COLLEGE
PROGRAMS THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT IS SEE SEE SEE WHAT IS THE
ISSUE WHAT IS YOU SEE WHAT ARE
THEIR REQUIREMENTS. AND THEN HOW
DO YOU MAKE HOW DO YOU SUBMIT A
COMPETITOR APPLICATION.
AND THAT'S FAR AS WE GOT.
BUT WE DON'T TALK ABOUT WHAT ITS
FINANCIAL AID WATER COLLEGE
FINANCES HOW RIGHT TAKE CARE OF
MYSELF ONCE I GET TO COLLEGE
CITING INSTITUTIONALIZING IS
WHAT ARE THE DIRECT SERVICES
THAT WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE
WITHIN THE UNIVERSITY. AND
ADVOCATING FOR BASIC NEEDS TO BE
PRIORITIZED WITHIN THE
UNIVERSITY WITHIN OUR STATE
BUDGET BUT THEN ALSO
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE IS A
PRE COLLEGE COMPONENT TO THAT
THAT IS ESSENTIAL.
BECAUSE WE SHOULDN'T BE HAVING
TO.
GOAL RECRUIT STUDENTS TO TRY TO
COME TO BASIC NEEDS
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE'RE
DESIGNING DATIA COMING KNOWING
THAT A SUCCESSFUL STUDENT.
PRIORITIZE OF THEIR BASIC NEEDS
AND THAT AND THIS IS HOW YOU DO
IT CITING THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED FOR BECAUSE
THAT PRE COLLEGE COMPONENT.
SERVES ALL THREE OF OUR SYSTEMS
A BETTER PREPARED STUDENT GOING
INTO THE CCC CSU YOU SEE TAKES
CARE OF THEIR BASIC NEEDS.
AND I'LLJUST PIGGYBACK OPT OUT
ANOTHER.
.
PEACE THAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO STRESS ARE AROUND
INSTITUTIONALIZING EFFORT THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN SO YOU CAN
HAVE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES BUT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE ON
CAMPUS WHO CAN RUN THOSE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS AND. MANY
TIMES THE FOLKS ON OUR CAMPUSES
ARE WEARING MANY HATS
AND THIS IS THAT ADDITIONAL HAT
SO HOW DO WE START TO THINK
ABOUT WAYS THAT WE CAN HAVE
FOLKS IN. THOSE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT ARE FOCUSED ON
BASIC NEEDS.
AND YOU KNOW WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT STUDENT SUCCESS YOU KNOW
YOU MAY HEAR THE TERM ALL WILL
YOU KNOW EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
ARE NOT SOCIAL SERVICE. AGENCIES
BUT WE ARE STUDENT SUCCESS
AGENCIES WE ARE PROMOTING
STUDENT SUCCESS WERE TRYING TO
GET STUDENTS TO STAY IN SCHOOL
TO GRADUATE AND THEN GOING TO
THE WORKFORCE AND BE PRODUCTIVE.
SO I THINK AS WE START TO THINK
ABOUT THIS WHOLE LISTA COOLEY
AND THINKING ABOUT ALL THE
DIFFERENT VARIABLES THAT PLAY
INTO A STUDENT SUCCESS WE HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT WHILE THAT'S WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HEALTH AND
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT BASIC
NEEDS. AT FOUNDATIONS FOR
LEARNING AND FOUNDATIONS FOR
STUDENT SUCCESS.
IN JUST ONE BRIEF COMMENT TO
BUILDING ON OUR.
INVERTED PYRAMID MODEL AND WILL
SEND THAT THE DIAGRAM OF
INTEGRITY WE WORK WITH ON THIS.
THE THE OUT REACH THAT'S PRE
CALL IS IMPORTANT BUT ALSO THE
TRANSFER THE ADMISSIONS IN THE
MESSAGING AT STUDENTS COME AND
AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE
WORKING ON THE NEXT PHASE THAT
ARE YOU SEE. INSTITUTIONALIZING
EFFORTS IS ENSURING THAT OUR
MISSIONS FOLKS ACTUALLY LOOK AT
BASIC NEEDS PREPARATIONS AS A
NET POSITIVE TO PROMOTE. THAT
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT YOUR
STUDENTS IN THE TIMES OF ALL
FORMS OF CRISIS MENTAL HEALTH
FOOD INSECURITY HOUSING
INSECURITY. THAT WE'RE
DEVELOPING THE SYSTEMS AND TOOLS
TO HELP THEM SUCCEED AND THAT
WILL ONLY BE SUCCESSFUL IF WE
TIED THE PRE COLLEGE WITH THE
PREPARATORY IN THE TRANSITION
SUPPORT THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
FOR FIRST YEAR. AND TRANSFER
STUDENTS AND THEN AS THEY COME
IN WE HAVE CAL FRACTION FOR
STUDENTS THAT DON'T QUALIFY
WHETHER THE DOC UNDOCK A
FORMALLY INCARCERATED YOUTH THAT
WE HAVE PANTRIES AND SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT PROVIDE
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS WHO DON'T QUALIFY. FOR
STATE OR FEDERAL AID PROGRAMS
AND THAT IS THAT BIGGER PACKAGE
OF INSTITUTIONALIZING SUCCESS
THAT WERE ENVISIONING. AND THE
GREAT WORK YOU GET TO DO WITH
THE CCC IN CSU I THINK THE
VILLAGE EFFORT REALLY BILLS THE
STRENGTH OF THE WORK WE'RE
UNDERTAKING. ALSO SOMETHING JUST
REALLY QUICKLY WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NOW. THE I LOVE
THE CONVERSATIONS OF
INSTITUTIONALIZING BECAUSE WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT IS
FOR US TO BUILD RELATIONSHIPS
WITH ACT COUNTIES.
FOR CAL FRESH WORK SOMETHING
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT ALSO IS
LIKE WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
BECAUSE WE'VE CLARIFIED SO MUCH
WITH CAL FRESH WITH REGARDS TO.
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS RIGHT WE DONE SO MUCH
OF THE POLICY WORK MEETING WITH
A CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES I COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICES THERE'S A GREAT PARTNER
CALLED CODE FOR AMERICA THAT
DEBT CREATED TO GET CAL FRESH.
ONLINE TOOL THAT EXPEDITES AND
SIMPLIFIES THE APPLICATION AND
THEY'RE WORKING ON A STAR SEVEN
HOW SIMPLIFICATION WHICH IS
PHENOMENAL.
AND WE STILL ARE WORKING WITH
COUNTIES WHO WORKS GOING TO
START RECEIVING APPLICATIONS IN
THE HUNDREDS AND AND THE
THOUSANDS WITH HOW HOW AT IT
WITH THE PACE OF OUR SUCCESS.
AND ARE WORKING WITH ONE FAX
MACHINE TO PRODUCE ALL OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS.
SO THERE BEEN TIMES WHERE WE
WILL SEND A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
APPLICATIONS AND THREE HOURS BUT
OF THAT FAX MACHINE DIDN'T
RECEIVE ALL THOSE ARE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE APPLICATIONS. THEN
THEY'RE ONLY GOING TO PROCESS AS
MUCH AS THAT ONE FAX MACHINE IN
THAT ONE COUNTY CAN DO SOMETHING
SOMETHING THAT WERE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL IS HOW DO WE TALK ABOUT
THE INSTITUTIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
AND THE PRIORITY OF BASIC NEEDS.
AND HOW DOES THAT IMPACT OUR
PARTNERS
BECAUSE EXCEPT FOR A PARTNERS
HAVE TO BE ALSO ALIGNMENT WITH
OURS WE CAN BE SENDING TWO
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS AND ONLY
ACTUALLY FIVE HUNDRED GET
PRICES.
BECAUSE THEY HAD ONE FAX MACHINE
TO WORK OUT OF SO THE
CONVERSATIONS ARE ALSO HAVING TO
BUILD THE VILLAGE AND SAY HOW DO
WE DO THIS TOGETHER. SO SOME OF
OUR PARTNERS HAVE ASKED DON'T
SEND ME A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE APPLICATIONS IN ONE DAY.
SEND ME TWENTY APPLICATIONS PER
DAY SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A BETTER
PROCESSING SYSTEM AND APPROVAL
RATING BUT HOW DO YOU TELL A
STUDENT YOU CAN APPLY TODAY YOU
COME TOMORROW WHEN ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE SUFFERING FROM FOOD
INSECURITY AND SOME OF THEM
HOMELESSNESS AND FOOD
INSECURITY.
I AM THINK YOU I THINK I THINK
THAT THIS IS A VERY HELPFUL TO
NOW AND I HAVE JUST A QUICK
QUESTION FOR ALL THREE. AND I
NAY IN A COULDN'T UNDERSTAND I
THINK ALL OF YOU TALKED ABOUT
HOW IMPORTANT. IT WAS TO.
EDUCATE OUR STUDENTS MAKE SURE
THEY'RE EQUIPPED WITH THIS
INFORMATION BY IS THE SUGGESTION
THAT THIS HAPPENING QUE TWELVE
AT THE END OF THEIR EACH YEAR OR
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT'S
EMBEDDED IN ORIENTATION FOR YOUR
PARTICULAR INSTITUTION AND I GET
THAT ORIENTATION IS.
OPTIONAL.
FOR SOME OF THESE INSTITUTIONS.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT IT HAPPENED
IN BOTH PLACES IT NEEDS TO BE
STATED AGAIN AND AGAIN THIS IS
NOT FOR A LOT OF THE STUDENTS
IN.
ALL OF OUR SYSTEMS THEY NEED TO
HEAR THIS MANY ARE FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS MANY HAVE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS. THEY NEED TO
HEAR THIS INFORMATION AS OFTEN
AS POSSIBLE TO MAKE IT STICK
BECAUSE IT'S A BIG TRANSITION
OUT OF K. TWELVE AND INTO.
COLLEGE IT'S IN A CULTURE SHOCK
FOR MANY OF THE STUDENTS JUST
FINANCIALLY SO I THINK IT SHOULD
HAPPEN AT THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM
AND A. UPON ORIENTATION INTO IT
ANY ONE OF THE THREE SEGMENTS.
AND THE CONVERSATION THAT I
THINK THAT HE'S WAS BRINGING UP
IS THE FACT THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
PEOPLE ON OUR CAMPUSES THAT CAN
DO THIS WORK.
BECAUSE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN THEN
I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE AT AT OUR
CAMPUS AT BERKELEY. IT WE SAY
LET'S FULLY INTEGRATE BASIC
NEEDS AND TO THE ORIENTATION
MODEL NOW IT'S GONNA BE MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THAT ON TOP
OF MY RESPONSIBILITY
FACILITATING SYSTEM MIGHT
CONVERSATIONS AND BEING HERE
WITH YOU ALL.
SO THEN WHEN THERE'S IN SOME
WHEN THERE'S NO PEOPLE ON THE
CAMPUSES IT'S HAVING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DO WE MAKE THINGS HAPPEN
AND THAT'S WHEN YOU HAVE TO ADD
ANOTHER HAT ON ANOTHER HAD
ANOTHER HOW TO FOLKS. THAT'S
RIGHT YOUR COMMITMENT THIS LAST
YEAR WAS CRUCIAL THIS WAS THE
FIRST TIME THAT WE ACTUALLY HAD
FUNDING TO HAVE PEOPLE AND NOT
JUST SERVICES. BECAUSE WHEN YOU
JUST HAVE SERVICES THAT NO
PEOPLE A YEAR PRIOR GONNA GOING
TO VOLUNTEER MODEL. BE YOU'RE
GOING TO ACTIVATE STUDENTS AND
WHATEVER CAPACITIES THEY HAVE
AND THEN SEE THE QUALITY IN THE
CONSISTENCY OF QUALITY OF
SERVICES AT ALL OF OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. ARE GONNA BE
INCREDIBLY WIDE OF A SPECTRUM
YES SOME CAMPUSES RIGHT NOW THAT
ARE SERVING UPWARDS OF LIKE
EIGHT THOUSAND UNIQUE STUDENTS
YOU HAVE OTHER CAMPUSES WERE
SERVING EIGHT STUDENTS.
AND THE NEED ISN'T THAT
DIFFERENT AND THOSE TWO CAMPUSES
SOMETHING THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING INTO THE CONVERSATION IS
HONORING THE FACT THAT IT HAS TO
HAPPEN ON CAMPUS BUT THEY HAVE
TO COME PREPARED. TO DO THAT
ALREADY AND FOR THOSE OF YOU ALL
THAT READ THE LA TIMES THERE WAS
A REALLY HIGH PROFILE STUDENT
CASE ON THE LA TIMES FRONT
COVER.
PHOTOS VIDEOS ALL OF THAT BEING
THE REASON WHY NEEDS TO BE
HAPPENING ON BOTH IS BECAUSE
THAT STUDENT WAS TOLD MULTIPLE
TIMES TO COME TO THE BASIC
NEEDS.
SPACE ON CAMPUS WAS TOLD
MULTIPLE TIMES TO TALK TO THE
RIGHT PEOPLE THEY JUST FELT
REALLY EMBARRASSED AND THEY FELT
LIKE THEY HAD NO TIME TO DO
THAT.
BECAUSE OUR FAMILY WAS HOMELESS
THEIR TWO SISTERS WERE HOMELESS
AND THEIR BROTHER COULD BARELY
KEEP UP THEIR JOB AND THEY WERE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THAT TOGETHER AS A FAMILY. SO
FOR THEM TO LEAVE THAT DATED A
RHYTHM OF THAT TAKING CARE OF
THE FAMILY TO COME MEET WITH ME
TO HELP THEM FIGURE THINGS OUT
IT ALWAYS FELT LIKE THEY WERE
BETRAYING THEIR FAMILY. BECAUSE
ONE HOUR AWAY FROM THE FAMILY
WASN'T TAKING CARE OF THEM SO I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON RIGHT NOW. HOW
DO WE BUILD A CULTURE WHERE WE
CELEBRATE THE FACT THAT
SUCCESSFUL STUDENTS PRIORITIZE
THEIR BASIC NEEDS BECAUSE IN WE
TOOK CARE OF THAT STUDENT WITHIN
A FIFTEEN MINUTE MEETING?
INDISCRIMINATE MEMBERS TO THAT
YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING A
POPULATION OF ALMOST A MILLION
OF THE STUDENTS WE SERVE IN THE
STATE. SO THE SEVEN HAVE MILLION
DOLLARS ARE HAVE GONE TO THAT
AMPLIFY WHAT WE'RE ALREADY DOING
WE'RE TRYING TO BE AS PROACTIVE
AND PREVENTIVE IN OUR LONG TERM
THINKING AS POSSIBLE. BUT THE
POPULATION SIZE WERE SERVING
ISN'T SMALL IN ANY MATTER SO
JUST WE REALLY WANT TO PRESS
UPON YOU THE APPRECIATION OF THE
SUPPORT THIS LAST YEAR. IN THE
ENORMITY OF WHAT WORK FACING
GOING FORWARD SO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR MAKING TIME FOR US TODAY AND
I JUST WANNA MAKE ONE COMMENT TO
TO PIGGYBACK OFF OF THEIR
ORIENTATION.
ANOTHER IDEA IS ESPECIALLY FOR
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS HAVING
ORIENTATIONS FOR THE PARENTS
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AS WE TALK ABOUT
PREPARING STUDENTS THAT PARENTS
ON BOARD AND THEY UNDERSTAND THE
COMMITMENTS AND.
THUMB THAT SERVICES IN RESOURCE
THAT SOURCES ARE AVAILABLE AND
THAT'S WERE TALKING ABOUT A
HOLISTIC EXPERIENCE ALSO DOING
TRAINING FOR FACULTY AND STAFF
TO TO LET THEM KNOW ABOUT WHAT
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE BECAUSE
MANY TIMES. FOR STUDENTS THEY
MAY FEEL COMFORTABLE GOING TO A
FACULTY OR ONE OF THEIR
PROFESSORS AND THAT PERSON GIVE
THEM THE WRONG. INFORMATION AND
OR TELL THEM TO GO TO THE WRONG
OFF THAT THEY MAY NOT OPEN UP
AND SAY I NEED HELP AGAIN SO
JUST MAKING SURE THAT EVEN ON
CAMPUS OR DON'T WEAR NEST TO
RESOURCES AND SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
THINK IT WELL I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND I THINK THEY THAT
LEAST OF THIS YOU KNOW THIS
HOUSE WAS REALLY INVESTED IN
SEEN SOMETHING MOVE FORWARD. I
THINK.
WITH THE POPULATION OF OVER
MILLION YOU THINK OF SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION THAT WAS INVESTED
OF THAT OF THIS. I'M WHICH IS
YOU KNOW A DOLLAR PLUS I PER
STUDENT OVER FIVE YEARS.
IT'S IT'S NOT MAYBE WHAT WE
NEED BUT I THINK THAT.
IT'S DEFINITELY HISTORIC IN
THAT THIS IS AN INVESTMENT FOR
HIGHER ED AND.
BASIC NEEDS AND WHAT I HOPE WE
CAN LOOK AT IN THE COMING YEARS
IS REALLY WHAT IS NEEDED I'M IN
ORDER TO MEET OF THE. YOU KNOW
VERY VERY IMPORTANT NEEDS FOR
OUR STUDENTS I'M SO HEARING THAT
YOU'RE ALREADY THINKING ABOUT
WHAT INSTITUTIONALIZATION MEANS
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE THE AMMO USE
WITH COUNTIES I MEAN THINGS THAT
I THINK. WE WEREN'T FULLY AWARE
WHAT IT WOULD BE AND I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS PRESENTATION
AGAIN NEXT YEAR TO KNOW WHAT
WHAT STILL MISSING.
WHAT'S WORKED AT SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THE THOUGHT
OF WHAT NEEDS TO GO INTO THIS I
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SOME A MEMBER TING WHICH I FIRED
BUDGET CHAIRPERSON DEXTER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I I DON'T WANT
TO THINK COME.
MYSTERY MOAN INTO SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I DID ONE.
REITERATE I BY PRE SHAPED.
FEEDBACK AND OF BEING THE
FORMER HEAD OF THE NONPROFIT I
UNDERSTAND THAT IS OFTEN VOTE IN
TO FUND THE PEOPLE THAT.
ACTUALLY IT IT TAKES TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE SERVICES SO ON
THE HOUSE.
THIS AREA INVOLVED THAT THEY
WILL BE HELPFUL FOR THIS
COMMITTEE IS TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND. SPECIFICALLY WHAT
ARM.
WHAT ABOUT PEOPLE OR SERVICES OR
SPECIFICS ARE NEEDED AT EACH OF
THE? THE SYSTEMS OFTEN WHAT WE
GET IS WE GET A. YOU KNOW WE
NEED FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
STUDENT HUNGER AND GETS.
DOESN'T SAY IS IT FOR FOOD IS IT
FOR OUR WAREHOUSE IS IT FOR
STAFF AS IT FOR COMPUTER RIGHT.
IN SO IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
EVALUATE AND.
WE CAN SAY WELL WHY NOT ONE
MILLION OR ONE NOT TEN MILLION
RIGHT I MEAN IT'S IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO EVALUATE WHEN YOU
DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND. THE
SPECIFICITY OF IT ARM I DID HAVE
A SPECIFIC QUESTION FOR THE
GENTLEMAN FROM FROM BERKELEY
WHICH COUNTY IS IT THAT ONLY HAS
ONE FAX MACHINE.
.
IT'S NOT JUST ONE COUNT.
YEAH SO SO THIS WAS HAPPENING
RIGHT AFTER THEY HAVE NAMES ARE
THEY DO HAVE NAMED AFTER I GONNA
GET BEAT UP AFTER THIS.
.
THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS ARE
GOING ON RIGHT NOW BUT BUT I
GUESS I MEAN DIVERT THE REASON
TO DOUBT THAT THAT'S A QUESTIONS
LOOK YOU KNOW WE HAVE WE HAVE
COLLEAGUES FROM EVERY PART OF
THE STATE. YEAH IT'S IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT YOU KNOW.
CALTRANS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
STATE FUNDED PROGRAM EVEN THOUGH
THE COUNTY'S ADMINISTER AT THE
MONEY GOES THROUGH THE STATE TO
GO THERE YEAH IF.
THE MONEY'S GETTING BOTTLE NACKT
THEY WERE NOT GETTING THE MONEY
ON THE STREET YEAH.
WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT IT RIGHT
SO IT'S NOT THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
CALPERS GOES THROUGH BIG
ASSERTIVE SUBCOMMITTEE YEAH BUT
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IF.
IT BEGS THE QUESTION AS TO.
YOU KNOW.
WHAT AND WHY IS THAT GOING ON
RIGHT AT YOUR OTHERWISE WE'RE
GOING TO APPROPRIATE MONEY TO
FOR THE SPECIFIC COUNTY TO GO
GET? TECHNOLOGY UPGRADES OR
WHATEVER ORG WOULD BE A TO FAX
MACHINES YEAH I THINK I THINK
THE GREAT OPPORTUNITY AND HOUSE
TOTALLY YOU'RE HUSTLING BACK
THERE IS I AGREE. PAL CAO GRANT
AUTOMATIC CAO FRESH ABSOLUTELY
YEAH YEAH I'VE THAT WHEN YOU'RE
NOT A GREAT IDEA WHEN YOU GROW
UP IN A FAMILY I GREW UP WHEN
YOU'RE HUSTLING HOW YOU CAN LIVE
A LOT OF THE LAST THE QUEST ARMY
EVERY CAN HEAR IT SO. THE
QUESTION IS YOU KNOW WHY CAN'T
WE JUST DO YOU KNOW BASIC
ELIGIBILITY STUFF YOUR. PAL
ELIGIBLE YOU AUTOMATICALLY GET
ELIGIBLE HE OUT FRESH THAT'S
REACTIVE IT'S SO THAT I DON'T
KNOW SO TWO THINGS TO SHAREWITH
YOU ARE ONE IS WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR STATE OUT
SOCIAL SERVICES TEAM. AND
THEY'RE WONDERFUL ARM THE FOLKS
ARE BEING VERY ACTIVATES A SPAN
OF SAYING WE KNOW THIS WE DON'T
KNOW THIS WE'VE TRIED THIS WE
HAVEN'T TRIED THIS. FOR US TO
STRATEGIZE HOW TO BEST MOVE
FORWARD IN THIS CONVERSATION AND
IN TERMS OF AUTOMATIC
ELIGIBILITY IT COMES BACK TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO WHEN YOU DO
AUTOMATIC ENROLLMENT HOW DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE WHEN SOME
COUNTIES ARE OUR TECHNOLOGY
INTEGRATED SOME CAMPUSES ARE
STILL PAPER PAPER TRAIL. SO THEN
DOES PROCESS THESE ARE GONNA BE
DIFFERENT DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU
ARE AND PROCESSING BY STUDENT
COUNT AND EACH ONE OF OUR
SYSTEMS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS PER
COUNTY.
SO I THINK WE CAN START MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION AND WE CAN
CERTAINLY PILOT SOME COUNTIES
LIKE SAN DIEGO ALAMEDA SO ON AND
SO FOR THAT ALREADY HAVE HIGH
NUMBERS THAT ARE ARE. ARE
INTERESTED IN BEING INNOVATORS
AND PUSHING THE ENVELOPE TO SEE
HOW THAT SCALING WORKS BUT IT'S
GONNA BE SOMETHING THAT'S GOING
TO TAKE TIME PEOPLE AND
RESOURCES FOR US TO PILOTS I
LOVE THE INVITATION TO COME BACK
I LOVE THE INVITATION TO BE
TRANSPARENT ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT'S NEEDED I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
COME BACK TO WITH OUR TEAMS
BECAUSE NOW EVERYBODY HEARD IN
THIS ROOM THAT THEY WERE BEING
ASKED THAT. BECAUSE SOMETIMES
WERE TOLD DON'T GIVE YOU
ANYTHING THAT YOU DON'T ASK FOR
SO NOW YOU ASK THOSE GREAT
QUESTIONS THAT WE CAN MOVE IN
THAT DIRECTION. AND I SAY THAT
WITH A LOT OF LOVE FOR THE
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM THAT I
TOTALLY LOST AND YOU'RE NOT EVEN
GIVE ABOVE OR ASK FOR SO THAT'S
NOT.
EH BUT BUT BUT AGAIN I THINK
THAT. THAT'S NOT WE TALK NEXT
YEAR YET MAYBE LISTLESS DO THIS
LIKE TOMORROW YEAH YES BECAUSE
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING
HUNGRY YESTERDAY LAST NIGHT YEAH
IN SO YES.
.
THEY'RE HUNDREDS AKA WE TEND
EXTRA YEAH RIGHT IN SO I THINK
THAT WE WANT TO UNDERSTAND.
WHY?
WERE SOME OF THE PITFALLS ARE
BECAUSE OTHERWISE.
IF MORE SPENDING MONEY AND IT'S
NOT BEING USED CORRECTLY THAT'S
NOT A GOOD USE OUR RESOURCES
RIGHT EITHER. SO WE WE NEED TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW THAT'S
WORKING FROM BEGINNING TO END.
TO THAT
STUDENTS THAT YOU'RE ALL TRYING
TO SERVE CAN GET THE SERVICES
THEY ARE ARE ARE OWED YET IS NOT
WHAT I TALKING ABOUT WHAT THE
DOES ELIGIBILITY DECISION.
THEN GET IN THE SERVICES YEAH
THEY. ALREADY ARE QUALIFY FOR
WHAT'S THE BEST TO THROW BY
SWEAT PRESS TO DO YOU CAN YOU
CAN FOLLOW UP WITH MARK.
OKAY MARX GLASSES PERSON ON THE
DIET FOR HIS HIS HIS PERSONAL
HABITS THAT ARE JGB MINNESOTA'S
FALL FALL UP WITH HIM AND HE CAN
CONNECT YOU SO WE CAN MAKE SURE
WE INTEGRATE THAT WITH ALSO
DAHLE THE VARIOUS. SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT ARE BEING PRIDE
PERFECT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU TO MAKE YOU GET UP AND I
KNOW MR MEDINA HAS SOME
QUESTIONS BUT BUT THIS IS NOT.
YOU KNOW OUR EXPERTISE THAT WE
HAVE A CAL FRESH.
HEARING ON THE OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEE YEAH SO WE WILL BE
OUR BOOK WILL WILL WE WILL
COMMIT TO WORK WITH THEM TO SEE
WHAT BARRIERS WE GET. PERFECT
REDUCE TO IT TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE SELLING HIS ORCHESTRA
MEDINA.
I I THINK THE.
WE ARE JUST BEGINNING TO SEE
THE ENORMITY OF THE OF THE
CHALLENGE
AHEAD OF US AND I THINK TIM YOU
WERE WITH US AT THE HEARING. AT
FRESNO CITY COLLEGE
WE'RE STUDENTS LINED UP FOR
QUITE AWHILE.
TWO OUT PRESENT THAT THE THE
ISSUE AND.
MOST RECENTLY FRIDAY I WAS AT
UC RIVERSIDE AND AGAIN THE
STUDENTS OF UC RIVERSIDE. I
SHARED WITH ME THE SAME CONCERNS
ATTA UC RIVERSIDE SO I I THINK
IT'S STARTING TO SINK IN AND I
PLAYED A PLOT OF THE DIFFERENT
EFFORTS.
BOTH BY THE STUDENTS AND AND
THE LEGISLATURE IN ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE BUT I A QUESTION THAT
I WOULD POSE IS. DO WE HAVE ANY
ANY INFORMATION ON THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN FOOD AND
SECURITY. OF STUDENTS AND THE
RAISING OF TUITION.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION WE DON'T
HAVE ANY DATA AVAILABLE NOW ON
THAT PER SE ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT ELEMENTS TO TEASE OUT
IS THE LITERACY OF THE COSTS OF
COLLEGE AND SO.
FOCUSING ON THEM TUITION HAS
OFTEN.
KIND OF LEFT SOMETHING BEHIND
THE CURTAIN KNOWN AS A COST OF
ATTENDANCE THAT WERE REALLY
FOCUSED ON. THE HOUSING THE FOOD
THE SUPPLEMENTAL COSTS OF
ACTUALLY SUCCEEDING IN BEING
PRESENT IN COLLEGE.
SO I'M EXPLORING THOSE TOGETHER
I THINK COULD BE A MORE.
BENEFICIAL FRUITFUL
CONVERSATION.
SO IT'S REALLY WELL NOTED TO
KIND OF LOOK AT THAT IN IN
CONJUNCTION WITH A LARGER
ENVIRONMENT. I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WHEN YOU ASK THAT
QUESTION I REALLY LIKE YOUR YOUR
GRAY ASKING SOME REALLY GREAT
QUESTIONS.
THERE'S A LOT BEEN THE MAJORITY
MEETINGS HAVE TO BE AND SO.
ONE OF THE THINGS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE THAT WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT ENOUGH IS THE FACT
THAT WE UNDERSTAND COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY THROUGH THE LENS
OF TUITION AND FEES.
WHICH IS AN INCOMPLETE LANDS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
HISTORY OF THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDING A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HISTORICALLY. COST OF LIVING HAS
ALWAYS BEEN MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
TUITION AND FEES.
SO WHEN WE DON'T TALK ABOUT THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE THEN
THAT'S WHY WE'VE HAD GENERATIONS
OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE STRUGGLED
AT DIFFERENT LEVELS AND
OBVIOUSLY TODAY'S STUDENT
STRUGGLING EVEN MORE. JUST
BECAUSE THINGS ARE MORE
EXPENSIVE IN THE COST OF LIVING
IS MORE EXPENSIVE TODAY. THERE'S
A THERE'S BEEN SO MANY FACULTY
THAT I'VE MET WAY IT'S
ADMINISTRATORS THAT I'VE MET
WITH FOLKS IN THE NONPROFIT
WORLD AND THIRD PARTY ENTITIES.
THAT JUST CANDIDLY SHARE WITH ME
YOU KNOW WHAT I DON'T KNOW WHY
THIS GENERATION STRUGGLING SO
MUCH I WORKED MY WAY THROUGH
COLLEGE.
SO WHEN WHEN I HEAR FOLKS SAY
THAT I ASK THEM HOW MUCH DID YOU
PAY FOR RENTS WHEN YOU WERE IN
COLLEGE.
HOW MUCH WHAT YOUR FOOD BUDGET
WHEN YOU WERE IN COLLEGE?
HOW MUCH WISE IN YOUR BANK
ACCOUNT WHEN YOU ARE IN COLLEGE
AND YOU FELT COMFORTABLE?
BECAUSE OF WHAT WAS IN YOUR BANK
ACCOUNT TODAY STUDENTS ARE
PROBABLY PAYING ANYWHERE FROM
THREE TO FIVE TIMES MORE THAN
WHAT YOU PAID FOR RENT.
I'D TODAY STUDENTS ARE PAYING
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE FOR FOOD
SIGNIFICANT MORE FOR BOOKS SO ON
AND SO FORTH.
SO I THINK THAT CONVERSATION TO
SOMETHING THAT WERE VERY
COMMITTED TO AMPLIFYING AND
SAYING TUITION AND FEES IS ONE
THING COST OF LIVING IS ANOTHER.
AND IN THAT THE COST OF LIVING
CONVERSATION DO WE HAVE SPECIFIC
QUALITY OF DATA I DON'T BELIEVE
WE DO OTHER THEN WE KNOW THAT
STICKER SHOCK CONTINUES TO BE
ONE OF THE LARGEST REASONS WHY
WE HAVE UNDER MATCHING
HAPPENING.
BOMB STICKER SHOCK CONTINUES TO
BE ONE OF THE REASONS WHY MANY
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS STUDENTS OF COLOR.
WOMEN AND LGBT PLUS STUDENTS
SEE THE COST OF THAT AND KNOW
THAT THE LIKELIHOOD OF THEM
BEING ABLE TO PAY THAT OFF IS
VERY MINIMAL BECAUSE NOBODY
TAUGHT THEM HOW FINANCIAL AID
WORKS.
NOBODY HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
THEM TO SAY YOUR TUITION AND
FEES BECAUSE YOU QUALIFY FOR THE
PAL GRANT AND THE CAL GRANT ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING CARE OF WHAT
WE NEED TO FOCUS WITH THE U. S.
TO SAY. HOW DOES A LOAN SYSTEM
WORK WHAT ARE YOUR COST OF
LIVING SO THAT YOU KNOW HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THE DATA
DAY IN COLLEGE?
BECAUSE WHEN YOU TALK TO A
FAMILY I LOVE DENISE'S POINT
ABOUT FAMILY PREPARATION BECAUSE
A FAMILY WILL ASK WELL THAT'S
GREAT BUT HOW YOU GONNA PAY FOR
RENT. BECAUSE I CAN'T PAY FOR
YOUR RIGHT HOW YOU GONNA PAY FOR
FOOD BECAUSE I'M NOT GONNA FEE
NOT NO I'M GONNA BREAK IN FOR
SECOND YEAH GO AHEAD BECAUSE.
AS CHAIR OF HIGHER EDUCATION I
VERY WELL UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COST OF ATTENDING COLLEGE.
IS NOT JUST TUITION AND FEES
YEAH ALL THE DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT YOU SAID HOUSING BOOKS
TRANSPORTATION. AND AND WE HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO TRY IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO EXPAND. OF THE
CAL GRANT SYSTEM TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE NEEDS.
BUT WE IN THE LEGISLATURE DON'T
CONTROL. A COST OF HOUSING COSTA
BOOKS WHAT WE DO CONTROL. IS
TUITION AND FEES.
SO I I WOULD ALSO GIVE YOU A ASK
YOU TO COME BACK.
AND TRY TO FLESH THAT OUT OKAY
OKAY BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE TO ME
THAT THERE IS A CORRELATION.
AS FEES OF INCREASED.
AS TUITION AS INCREASE WE HAVE
BEGUN TO HEAR MORE AND MORE.
STUDENTS.
ABOUT THE FOOD INSECURITY AND
HOUSING IN SECURITY SO I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT YEAH AND IF WE
COULD GO BACK YEAH AND EXAMINE
THAT I I THINK THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. AND AGAIN.
AT SOME THINGS WE DON'T CONTROL
BUT TUITION AND FEES WE DO YEAH
AND.
I I THINK WE NEED TO DO BETTER
WOULD YOU LIKE US TO COME BACK
WITH BOTH QUANTITATIVE AND
QUALITATIVE ON THAT. YOU WANNA
KNOW THE EXPONENTIAL DATA.
EVERYTHING YOU CAN PRODUCE A
WHOLE PREDOMINANT CULTURE
BECAUSE WHEN I GO BACK TO OUR
RESEARCH HE WAS GONNA COME FROM
IS GONNA BE GREAT YEAH.
QUESTION.
YEAH YEAH MISTER MARTZ WHICH.
YEAH. THAT'S A TRIP WITH.
MAYBE IT JUST SEEMS LIKE A.
RECURRING THEME IN AND BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING SAID.
MORE MORE WHERE WE'RE HEARING IT
JUST LIKE THE REST OF THE STATE.
YOU KNOW IT'S THE HOUSING CRISIS
I MEAN THE IT.
AND AND AND SO WHILE WE'RE
HAVING DEBATES ABOUT LEGISLATION
TO TO INCENTIVIZE TO. YOU KNOW
OF MORE AND AND HIGHER DENSITY
HOUSING.
I I THINK WE NEED TO JUST NOT
JUST FOCUS ON.
FOOD AND SECURITY BUT I THINK
THE BIGGER PICTURE IS THAT THEY
DID THAT DRIVING COST OF HOUSING
AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO.
YOU NOW HAVE MORE FOCUS ON.
HOW CAN WE YOU KNOW EITHER
THROUGH?
?
A BOND OR OR OR OR MORE OF A
FUNDING FOR OUR UNIVERSITIES TO
BUILD MORE STUDENT HOUSING MORE
HIGH DENSITY STUDENT HOUSING.
IN ORDER MAKE HOUSING MORE
AFFORDABLE I THINK THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF A CONVERSATION
THAT I. HAVEN'T BEEN HEARING
WHO.
COULD I JUST ADD ONE COMMENT ON
YOUR NOTE YOU KNOW IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. WE
DON'T HAVE HOUSING PER SE WE
HAVE ELEVEN OF THE CAMPUSES THAT
OFFER DORMITORIES.
.
BUT WE ARE LOOKING AT A PROGRAM
MODEL THAT'S HAPPENING DOWN IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WITH AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED HOVHANESS.
AND THEY HAVE SOMETHING CALLED
THE COLLEGE SUCCESS INITIATIVE
THEY'RE USING UP COUNTY HOUSING
DOLLARS AND PHILANTHROPIC
DOLLARS. TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THEY'RE WORKING WITH FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES RIGHT NOW.
TO PROVIDE RAPID RE HOUSING
SERVICES TO PROVIDE HOUSING
NAVIGATION SERVICES AND TO
PROVIDE SUBSIDIES RENTAL
SUBSIDIES FOR STUDENTS AND SO I.
I THINK IT'S WORTH LOOKING AT I
THINK IT'S UP BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK THAT THERE'S ENOUGH MONEY
IN EDUCATION TO SOLVE THE
HOUSING CRISIS MAYBE THERE IS I
DON'T KNOW BUT.
BUT THIS IS A MODEL WHERE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY LEVERAGING
DOLLARS THAT ARE DESIGNATED FOR
HOUSING EACH CLOCK COUNTY HAS A
COORDINATED ENTRY PROGRAM. THAT
SERVES HOMELESS PEOPLE IN
GENERAL NOT EXCLUSIVE TO COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
BUT HOW DO WE GET CONNECTED WITH
THOSE COORDINATED ENTRY FOLKS
LOCALLY TO TO EXPAND THE WORK TO
SUPPORT HOMELESS PEOPLE TO
INCLUDE HOMELESS COLLEGE
STUDENTS. AND WE SEE IT
HAPPENING CONTRA COSTA WE SEE IT
HAPPENING IN LOS ANGELES I THINK
IT'S WORTH LOOKING AT THAT
PROGRAM MODEL. AND AND TRYING TO
FURTHER THAT EXPAND THAT SCALE
THAT BECAUSE THOSE ARE HOUSING
DOLLARS DESIGNATED FOR HOUSING
SERVICES.
SO IT'S JUST SOMETHING FOR
CONSIDERATION IS ALSO A BILL ON
NINE EIGHTEEN THAT WOULD CREATE
ALSO HOUSING BILL THAT WOULD
CREATE A SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM FOR TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
I I THINK THAT IS ALSO
SOMETHING THAT AND THOSE WHO I
THINK WOULD BE USING PROP SIXTY
FOUR DOLLARS THOUGH PLEASE DON'T
QUOTE ME ON THAT.
BUT IT'S THOSE TYPES OF
INITIATIVES THAT ARE GROUNDED IN
THE HOUSING WORK SPACE
THAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE.
ESPECIALLY FOR A SYSTEM OF OUR
SIZE AND WITH THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT WE HAVE AND SO I
THOSE ARE THINGS I THINK WE
SHOULD LOOK AT. AND TRY TO
EXPLORE AND TRY TO EXPAND UPON.
OKAY FAIR ENOUGH I KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HUNGER HERE.
TIMELY BUT IT'S IT'S A BIG ISSUE
BUT I DO END UP JUST A FEW
THINGS.
AT FOR A PURPORTED MOVE ON ONE
IS.
.
AS OUR OUR BUDGET SERIOUSLY TO
WHO WE DON'T CONTROL FEES AGAIN
IT'S UP TO THE SEGMENTS GRANTED.
THEY SAY IF WE FIND THE
SYSTEMATIC QUICKLY THERE'S NOT
THE PRESSURE TO INCREASE SPEED
THE FIRST PLACE SO SO I GET THAT
BUT.
YOU KNOW IN LARGE PART THAT THAT
BUILT THE NEEDIEST STUDENTS
EITHER TELL GRANT RECIPIENTS OR
CAL GRANT SO THAT SO THE
TUITION.
IS SOMEWHAT OFF THE TABLES KEEP
ON THE MIDDLE THEY GET THE
SQUEEZE PEOPLE THEIR FIFTH YEAR
THEY DON'T GET THE COVER
ANYMORE.
BUT IT REALLY ARE THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT REALLY COMPOUND THIS
AND SO ACOSTA LIVING WE TALKED
ABOUT.
LAST YEAR.
INCREASING OUR OUR CAL GRANT
UMBER RACE HE RESTRUCTURING THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM SO IT COVERS
NOT JUST THAT THE TUITION COSTS
BECAUSE REALLY IT'S THE COST OF
INSTRUCTION AS WE AS WE NOTED
SO.
THAT'S YOU KNOW LARGER
DISCUSSION THAT WE TALK ABOUT A
FEW WEEKS AGO THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD CONTINUE BUT. BUT ON THIS.
WE KNOW THAT OUR WORK IS NOT
DONE AND AND I THINK THERE'S
SOME THINGS THAT WILL TAKE A
LOOK AT WHERE THIS YEAR AND.
IN THE FUTURE AS WELL SO.
SING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS ON
ISSUE NUMBER ONE ALSO A CROSS
CUTTING ISSUE.
THE LAST FEW YEARS RELATES TO
YOU SEE CSU OR COMMITTEE
COLLEGES RELATES TO.
OUR FACULTY AND FACULTY DIVERSE
CITY WE HAVE A PANEL FROM THE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA AND.
CSU CANCERS OFFICE.
AS WELL AS OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
OKAY.
SO WE'LL START WITH THAT YOU
SUSAN TALKED CARLSON CORRECT
OKAY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I I'M SUSAN
CARLSON I'M THE VICE PROVOST FOR
ACADEMIC PERSONNEL AND PROGRAMS
AT THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
I'M PLEASED TO REPORT YOU
BRIEFLY ON THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S USES OF THE
FUNDING.
ALLOCATED TO SUPPORT FACULTY
ADVERSITY FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
WE'VE NAMED OUR PROGRAM
ADVANCING FACULTY DIVERSITY.
A COVERING THE HIRING THAT HAS
RESULTED THE BEST PRACTICES THAT
ARE EMERGING AND THE WAYS IN
WHICH THIS PILOT PROGRAM HAS
PROVIDED INCENTIVES FOR NEW
PROCESSES.
SO TO RECAP BRIEFLY LET ME NOTE
THAT WE FELT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
AWARD THESE PRECIOUS FUNDS
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE PROCESS.
AND TO ENSURE THAT WE COULD
MEASURE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
EXPENDITURES. SO THAT WE WOULD
KNOW HOW ADDITIONAL EXPENDITURES
COULD ADD VALUE IN OUR EFFORTS
TO DIVERSIFY THE FACT FACULTY.
SO I'D LIKE TO SPEAK YOU BRIEFLY
ABOUT OUR EFFORTS IN THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEENSEVENTEEN YEAR
AND THEN IN THE CURRENT YEAR AS
WELL.
WE'RE PLEASED WITH THE RESULTS
OF OUR THREE PILOTS FOR TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN.
EARLY ON WE DETERMINED THAT THE
BEST USE OF THE FUNDS WHICH TO
SUPPORT A FEW COLLEGES AND US
SCHOOLS SELECTED THROUGH A
COMPETITIVE SYSTEM WIDE PROCESS.
THESE WERE UNITS READY TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL STEPS TO DIVERSIFY
THEIR FACULTY AND TO CREATE AN
INCLUSIVE ENVIRONMENT.
NEARLY ALL OF THE FUNDING WENT
TO THREE UNITS UNDERTAKING
IMPORTANT HIRING DURING THE
YEAR.
SO THAT WAS THE BOREN'S A
COLLEGE OF ENGINEERING AT UC
RIVERSIDE THE JACOBS SCHOOL OF
ENGINEERING AT UC SAN DIEGO. AND
THE COLLEGE OF AGRICULTURAL AND
NATURAL RESOURCES AT UC DAVIS.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE FOCUS
INFUSION OF FUNDS MADE A
DIFFERENCE IN FACULTY DIVERSITY
RELATIVE TO THESE UNITS PAST
PERFORMANCE.
AND TO THE COMPARED TO UNITS WE
USE TO MEASURE THEIR SUCCESS.
ALL THREE UNITS SAW SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE IN PRACTICE AND IN
CONVERSATIONS AS WELL AS AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF NEW
FACULTY WHO HAVE MADE VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO DIVERSITY AND
TO IMPROVING THE ACADEMIC
CLIMATE. FOR ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES AND
WOMEN.
CANDIDATES WHO MADE IT TO THE
FINALIST INTERVIEWS WERE
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE DIVERSE BY
GENDER AND RACE ETHNICITY AND
ALL THREE UNITS.
AND THE DIVERSITY OF HIRING WAS
IMPROVED SIT HERE SOME
SPECIFICS.
IN THE PROVOST DIVERSITY AND
ENGINEERING FELLOWS PROGRAM AT
RIVERSIDE THREE OF THE THREE
PLANNED HIRES WERE FEMALE.
TO WERE UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITIES AND THE THIRD WAS A
PERSON OF COLOR.
THIS IS A REMARKABLE ACHIEVEMENT
IN ENGINEERING.
AND THE UC SAN DIEGO ENGINEERING
PILOT THERE WERE EIGHT FEMALES
AMONG THE TWENTY TWO HIRES OR
THIRTY SIX PERCENT. AND FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES
AMONG TWENTY TWO HIRES OR
ROUGHLY EIGHTEEN PERCENT.
AGAIN THIS HIRING IS A THREE
FOLD INCREASE ON THE DIP UP
CURRENT FACULTY DIVERSITY
DEMOGRAPHICS.
THESE NEW UC SAN DIEGO HIRES ARE
ALREADY WORKING WITH K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS AND UNDER. UCSD STUDENTS
IN SPECIAL COURSES AND PROGRAMS
THEY'VE DESIGNED IN THEIR FIRST
YEAR.
IN THE PROGRAM AT UC DAVIS THE
COLLEGE HIRED FOR FEMALES AND
ONE UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
FACULTY. OUT OF TOTAL HIRES OF
THIRTEEN.
AND YOU KNOW IN THE CONTEXT OF
PROPOSITION TWO ARE NINE THESE
UNITS DID NOT HIRE BASED ON RACE
OR GENDER. BUT FOCUSED ON THE
RECRUITMENT STRATEGIES AND THE
DEPARTMENT PRIORITIES THAT WOULD
ATTRACT DIVERSE CANDIDATES READY
TO DO THEIR RESEARCH AND
TEACHING. ANY UNIVERSITY
COMMITTED TO DIVERSE STUDENTS
AND COMMUNITIES.
FOR EXAMPLE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
DIVERSITY STATEMENTS FIGURED
PROMINENTLY AND ALL THREE
PILOTS.
AND NOTABLY ALL THREE PILOTS
WERE IN STEM DISCIPLINES WHERE
THE DIVERSITY OF NEW P. H. D.'S
AND THIS IS THE NATIONAL
AVAILABILITY IS NOT AS DIVERSE
AS WE WOULD WANT.
AND OUR FINAL REPORT WHICH WE
FILED WITH THE LAST NOVEMBER WE
FOCUS ON THE PERCENTAGE OF HIRES
THAT WERE FEMALE ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES AND
NOT ON THESE HEAD COUNTS.
AND THAT WAS SO THAT THE RESULTS
COULD BE MEASURED AGAINST PAST
YEARS AGAINST COMPARATOR GROUPS.
AND UNDERSTOOD IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE AVAILABLE POOL OF
CANDIDATES.
IN THE SECOND YEAR WHICH IS
STILL COURSE ONGOING WE'VE HAD
AGAIN A COMPETITIVE PROCESS TO
DETERMINE WHICH UNIT SHOULD
RECEIVE FUNDING. AND WE DECIDED
TO SPREAD THEIR WORDS OVER FOR
PILOTS THIS YEAR.
THAT INCLUDES THE UC BERKELEY
COLLEGE OF ENGINEERING. UC
IRVINE'S SCHOOLS OF BIOLOGICAL
SCIENCES ENGINEERING INFORMATION
IN COMPUTER SCIENCES AND
PHYSICAL SCIENCES.
YOU SEE SAN FRANCISCO SCHOOLS OF
DENTISTRY MEDICINE NURSING AND
PHARMACY.
AND UC SANTA BARBARA'S
DEPARTMENT OF ECONOMICS.
SO IN ADDITION TO ONE COLLEGE
WHICH WAS ENGINEERING AT
BERKELEY WE INCLUDED ONE
DEPARTMENT ECONOMICS AT SANTA
BARBARA AND TWO CLUSTERS OF
SCHOOLS AT IRVINE AND IT SAN
FRANCISCO.
WITH THIS RANGE OF KINDS AND
SIZES OF UNITS WE CAN TEST THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE. AND OF INTERVENTIONS
AND STRATEGIES AT DIFFERENT
SCALES.
WE'RE CONTINUING SOME OF THE
PRACTICES THAT PROVED EFFECTIVE
IN YEAR ONE INCLUDING ENHANCED
OUTREACH THE USE OF A POST
DOCTORAL FELLOWSHIP YEAR TO
RECRUIT.
TAPPING INTO THE PROVEN TALENT
OF THE DIVERSE FELLOWS IN THE
PRESIDENT'S POSTDOCTORAL
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S POSTDOCTORAL
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAMS.
INTERVENING AND TRADITIONAL
EVALUATION PRACTICES AND
TARGETED USE OF START UP FUNDS.
OTHER NOTABLE INTERVENTIONS IN
THE SECOND YEAR INCLUDE MORE
INCLUSION OF STUDENTS IN THE
HIRING PROCESS. MAKING USE OF
CAMPUS EQUITY ADVISORS.
CREATING PEER MENTORING COHORTS
OF NEW FACULTY. AND HIRING AT
THE SENIOR LEVEL THROUGH ENDOWED
CHAIRS.
I'M PLEASED TO REPORT THAT IN
THIS YEAR'S FOR PILOTS OF THE
ADVANCING FACULTY DIVERSITY
PROGRAM HAS PROVEN TO BE AN
INCENTIVE FOR SIGNIFICANT CAMPUS
INVESTMENT.
INCLUDING THE ALLOCATION OF
ADDITIONAL FACULTY FD.
AND THE COMPETITION FOR THE
SECOND YEAR OF AWARDS WE DID NOT
REQUIRE THAT THE CAMPUS IS
PROVIDE ANY KIND OF MATCHING
FUNDS BUT MOST OF THEM DID.
THIS SUGGESTS I BELIEVE HOW
POWERFUL THE SPECIFIC ALLOCATION
TO SUPPORT FACULTY DIVERSITY HAS
BEEN.
WE'RE CONTINUING WITH MANY OTHER
EFFORTS IN RECRUITMENT AND WOOD
BUILDING INCLUSIVE DEPARTMENTAL
CLIMATES ACROSS THAT.
CAMPUSES FOR EXAMPLE IT'S NOW
STANDARD PRACTICE ON MOST OF OUR
CAMPUSES TO REQUIRE CANDIDATES
FOR A FACULTY POSITIONS. TO
SUBMIT A CONTRIBUTIONS TO
DIVERSITY STATEMENT IN WHICH
THEY DETAIL PAST EFFORTS IN
THEIR TEACHING OUTREACH OR
RESEARCH. AND TO TELL US HOW
THEY WILL CONTINUE SUCH EFFORTS
ONCE THEY JOIN THE UC FACULTY.
OUR PILOT UNITS ARE MAKING THIS
STATEMENT A CENTRAL PART OF THE
EVALUATION PROCESS.
AND FINALLY BOTH THE CAMPUSES
AND THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
ARE SUPPORTING RESEARCH THAT
WILL HELP US UNDERSTAND WHICH
RECRUITMENT. EFFORTS ACTUALLY
WORK IN OUR EFFORTS TO BUILD THE
DIVERSE FACULTY OF THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
CSU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MELISSA
BARD AND I SERVICE THE VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR HUMAN RESOURCES
AT THE CSU OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR.
THIS ISSUE HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
STRIDES IN RECRUITING A DIVERSE
AND REPRESENTATIVE COHORT OF
PRESIDENTIAL LEADERSHIP.
IN FACT WE RECENTLY CELEBRATED A
MILESTONE OF THE MAJORITY OF
TWELVE WOMEN AMONG OUR TWENTY
THREE PRESIDENTS.
IT IS CLEAR FROM THE RESPONSE TO
THAT SUCCESS HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
FOR OUR STUDENTS TO HAVE ROLE
MODELS WHO SHARE SOME OF THEIR
EXPERIENCES.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE WORKING SO
DILIGENTLY TO REPLICATE THAT
SUCCESS AT THE FACULTY LEVEL.
THESE ARE NEW CONVERSATIONS AT
THE CSU AND WE HAVE BEEN MAKING
STEADY PROGRESS FOR A LONG TIME.
IF THE FIRST FIGURE AND TABLE IN
YOUR HANDOUT SHOWS THESE CHANGES
OVER TIME.
THE PERCENTAGE OF FACULTY WHO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AS WHITE WAS
EIGHTY ONE PERCENT TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO.
SIXTY NINE PERCENT TEN YEARS
AGO.
AND IS ABOUT SIXTY ONE PERCENT
AS A FALL TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
THE GENDER GAP IS ALSO CLOSING.
TEN YEARS AGO ONLY FORTY ONE
PERCENT OF FACULTY WERE FEMALE
COMPARED TO FORTY SEVEN PERCENT
AS A FALL TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
AS A ARE A MAJORITY OF NEW
FACULTY HIRES.
ONE OF OUR SIGNATURE PROGRAMS
THE CHANCELLOR'S DOCTORAL
INCENTIVE PROGRAM IS CELEBRATING
ITS THIRTIETH ANNIVERSARY THIS
YEAR.
SINCE ITS INCEPTION THE PROGRAM
HAS HAS THAT APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ALUMNI IN TO
SEE IT YOU FACULTY POSITIONS.
FORTY THREE PERCENT OF THOSE
FACULTY MEMBERS. ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY GROUPS
COMPARED TO ONLY ABOUT FIFTEEN
PERCENT OF THE CURRENT FACULTY.
HOWEVER WE KNOW WE CAN DO MORE.
THE LEGISLATURE'S FINANCIAL
SUPPORT OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS
COINCIDES WITH AN UPTICK IN
TENURE TRACK HIRING AS CAMPUSES
REPLACE FACULTY POSITIONS. LOST
DURING THE RECESSION AND ADD
ADDITIONAL FIVE WOULD BE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
THAT HAS PROVIDED US WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE REAL
PROGRESS FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE THE RECESSION.
TABLE TO IN YOUR HANDOUT SHOWS
OUTCOMES FOR RECRUITMENT FOR
FACULTY WHO JOIN THE CSU AND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN. AS WELL AS PRELIMINARY
OUTCOMES FOR SEARCHES FOR
FACULTY WHO WILL BE JOINING THE
CSU AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
IN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN JUST OVER
FIFTY PERCENT OF NEW FACULTY
IDENTIFIED THEMSELVES AS WHITE.
WELL BELOW THE SIXTY FOUR
PERCENT IN THE GENERAL FACULTY
POPULATION.
RESULTS APPEAR TO BE SIMILAR FOR
THE FACULTY BEING RECRUITED FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
ALTHOUGH MANY OF THE SEARCHES
ARE STILL IN PROGRESS.
AT THIS POINT IN THE YEAR WE
ALWAYS HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS FOR HIM RACE OR
ETHNICITY IS STILL UNKNOWN BUT
THOSE NUMBERS WILL SUBSTANTIALLY
LOWER BY THE TIME THE NEW
FACULTY COME ON BOARD AND FALL.
BASED ON THESE PRELIMINARY DATA
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT THE CLASS OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WILL BE
ANOTHER VERY DIVERSE GROUP.
MOVING NOW TO SPECIFIC USES OF
THE FUNDING THE LAST TWO YEARS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN.
RECOGNISING THE CHALLENGE OF
CREATING SUSTAINING MOMENTUM AND
A LARGE AND COMPLEX SYSTEM FUNDS
FROM SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN HAVE BEEN
USED IN WAYS INTENDED TO BOTH TO
HAVE IMMEDIATE IMPACT. AND
SUPPORT LONG TERM CHANGE.
WE'VE USED THE FUNDS TO RAISE
THE VILLAINS VISIBILITY OF THE
CS YOU AS AN EMPLOYER OF CHOICE
THAT MAJOR HIGHER EDUCATION
DIVERSITY CONFERENCES AND
ORGANIZATIONS. SUCH AS THE
SOCIETY FOR THE ADVANCEMENT OF
CHICANOS AND NATIVE AMERICANS IN
SCIENCE.
A PHD PROJECT AND OTHERS.
WE'VE PROVIDED INCENTIVES TO
CAMPUSES THE RECRUIT GRADUATES
OF THE CHANCELLOR'S DOCTORAL
INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
THIS YEAR THE FUND SUPPORTED
START UP COSTS FOR FIFTEEN NEW
FACULTY OF HIM TEN WHERE MEMBERS
OF MINORITY GROUPS AND ELEVEN
WERE WOMEN'S.
WE'VE PROVIDED CAMPUSES WITH
SEED MONEY TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTING BEST PRACTICES FOR
RECRUITING AND RETAINING DIVERSE
FACULTY.
THE FUNDS FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND EIGHTEEN REVIEWS
DIFFERENTLY.
WE FUNDED ELEVEN CAMPUS PROJECTS
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE REQUEST
FOR PROPOSAL.
ALL PROPOSALS HAD TO ADDRESS HOW
THE WORK WOULD BE SUSTAINED LONG
TERM AND HOW SUCCESSFUL
ACTIVITIES COULD BE ADOPTED BY
OTHER CSU CAMPUSES.
THESE AWARDS WERE MADE IN LATE
DECEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AFTER MUCH RECRUITING FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WAS ALREADY
COMPLETE.
SO MOST PROJECTS INCLUDE
ACTIVITIES THAT WILL IMPACT NEXT
YEAR'S RECRUITING CYCLE AS WELL
AS THIS YEAR'S.
ONE EXAMPLE IS CSU FRESNO.
THEY'RE FOCUSING ON BUILDING A
PIPELINE OF STRONG STEM
CANDIDATES STARTING WITH THEIR
OWN ALUMNI AND INCLUDING
REGIONAL AND NATIONAL PARTNERS.
THE CAMPUS WILL BRING SENIOR
GRAD STUDENTS AND POSTDOCS TO
CAMPUS TO GIVE SEMINARS AND MEET
FACULTY AND STUDENTS AND OFFER A
WEEKLONG BICU CAMP THIS SUMMER.
FOCUSED ON ACADEMIC CAREERS AND
COMPREHENSIVE UNIVERSITIES.
THEIR GOAL IS TO DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY FACULTY HIRED IN THE
SCIENCES COMPARED TO CURRENT
LEVELS.
THE FUNDING BY THE LEGISLATURE
TODAY AS HAVING IMPORTANT IMPACT
IN SEVERAL WAYS.
FIRST NEW FACULTY HIRING IS
CHANGING THE SHAPE OF THE
FACULTY OVERALL.
FOR EXAMPLE AS A FALL TWENTY
SEVENTEEN MORE THAN TWENTY
PERCENT OF ALL CURRENTLY ACTIVE
AFRICAN AMERICAN FACULTY HAD
BEEN HIRED IN EITHER TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN OR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN CITY. FORTY
ONE PERCENT OF NEW
HIRES IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WHERE MEMBERS OF
MINORITY GROUPS. COMPARED TO
ONLY ABOUT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT A
RECENT DOCTORAL RECIPIENTS
NATIONWIDE.
SECOND CAMPUSES HAVE
INCREASINGLY EMBRACE BEST
PRACTICES INCLUDING THIS PAST
YEAR.
CAMPUS ADMINISTRATORS STARTING
WITH PRESIDENT AND PROVOST HAD
MADE IT CLEAR THAT A DIVERSE
FACULTY IS CRUCIAL TO STUDENT
SUCCESS AND THESE PRIORITIES ARE
INCREASING INCREASINGLY EMBEDDED
IN THEIR SEARCH PROCESSES.
CAMPUSES ARE ALSO FOCUSING ON
RETAINING FACULTY OF COLOR
THROUGH SUPPORT ON THE PATH TO
TENURE AND MAKING SURE NEW
RECRUITS FILL PART OF THE
UNIVERSITY COMMUNITY.
FINALLY THE FUNDING CREATES
AWARENESS AND SENDS THE MESSAGE
THAT THESE ACTIVITIES ARE
IMPORTANT TO THE CSU AND TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
GIVEN CAMPUSES LIMITED BUDGET
FOR RECRUITING A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. EVEN MODEST
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT CAN HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
INNOVATIONS FUNDED THIS YEAR
CONTINUED AND EXPANDED.
OUR BEST EFFORTS TO BRING IN NEW
TENURE LINE FACULTY WILL BE
POSSIBLE WHEN THE CSU BUDGET
REQUEST IS FULLY FUNDED.
IF THE CSU BUDGET REQUEST IS NOT
FULLY FUNDED NOT ONLY IS IT
LIKELY THAT BUDGETS THAT SUPPORT
RECRUITING WILL BE STRAINED BUT
IT'S VERY LIKELY THE NUMBER OF
CAMPUSES WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
SCALE BACK TENURE TRACK
RECRUITING IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THAT COULD ADVERSELY IMPACT OUR
GOAL FOR A MORE DIVERSE FACULTY
AND THAT'S WHY OUR TOP PRIORITY
IS FOR FUNDING FOR THE CSU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JACOB
NAP I'M A REPRESENTING THAT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE JUST
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
THE COMMUNICABLE DO BUDGET
INCLUDES CATEGORICAL PROGRAM
DEDICATED TO EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT AVERAGES
ABOUT TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ALLOCATES.
RESOURCES FROM THE E. O. FUN TO
OUR SEVENTY TWO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS FOR THE LOCAL
PROMOTION. OF E. O. PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES EACH DISTRICTS WE
BELIEVE IS IN THE BEST POSITION
TO UNDERSTAND LOCAL NEEDS AND
UTILIZE LIMITED E. RESOURCES.
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ALSO
USES A PORTION OF THE OEO FUND
EACH YEAR OUGHT TO PAY FOR AND
RUN A SYSTEM WIDE EYED JOBS
BOARD IN DATABASE. AT THE
PROMOTES.
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN
THE COMMUNICATIVE STEM AND
LINKS.
APPLICANTS WITH LOCAL DISTRICTS.
SO A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND WE
RECENTLY CHANGED.
ARE FUNDING ALLOCATION MODEL
WITH IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICORP SYSTEM HISTORICALLY.
WE DISTRIBUTE FUNDS FROM THE
EEO FUND BASED ON THE F. T. S.
OF EACH DISTRICT.
BUT TWO YEARS AGO WE ARE WE MADE
A SWITCH AND.
OR STATEWIDE E. OWN DIVERSITY.
ADVISORY GROUP IDENTIFIED NINE
BEST PRACTICE AREAS IN PROMOTING
EEO AND THOSE ARE ON PAGE SEVEN
OF YOUR AGENDA.
.
AND WHAT WE REQUIRE NO BRING
ORDER FOR DISTRICT TO RECEIVE.
OF A PORTION OF THE STATEWIDE
EEL FUND IS THEY'VE TO CERTIFY
TO THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
THAT THEY MEET.
MULTIPLE METHOD NUMBER ONE OF
WHICH IS HAVING A AND E. DEAL
PLAN FOR THE DISTRICTS IN E. O.
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
AND THAT THEY REPORT ANNUALLY
ON THE WAY THAT THEY SPENT THEIR
FUNDING.
THEY NEED TO MEET THAT MULTIPLE
METHOD NUMBER ONE AND SIX OF THE
REMAINING MULTIPLE METHODS THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE
STATEWIDE GROUP.
THAT CERTIFICATION HAS TO BE
SIGNED BY THE CHAIR OF THE LOCAL
BOARD OF TRUSTEES OF THE CEO.
OF THE DISTRICT.
IN THE CHIEF HR OFFICER.
THE IDEA WAS TO.
TO HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
USE OF THESE FUNDS AND ALSO TO.
TO RAISE AWARENESS.
IN DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE STATE
ABOUT THE REALLY GOOD WORK THAT
IS GOING ON. AND SOME OF THESE
LOCAL. EEL PROGRAMS.
JUST TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE
FLAVOR OF THE NINE MULTIPLE
METHOD AREAS ARE BROKEN INTO PRE
HIRING.
HIRING AND POST HIRING IN THE
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE.
YOU ARE USING FOCUSED OUR
REGION PUBLICATIONS ARE YOU
OFFERING INCENTIVES FOR HARD TO
HIGHER AREAS OR DISCIPLINES.
DO YOU HAVE ANY.
GROW YOUR OWN PROGRAMS AT YOUR
LOCAL DISTRICT AND ARE YOU
PROVIDING CONSISTENT AND ONGOING
TRAINING. FOR YOUR HIRING
COMMITTEES.
SO EACH DISTRICTS EEL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR.
ENSURING THAT THE DISTRICTS E.
O. PLAN IS IMPLEMENTED AN
UPDATED REGULARLY.
BY TETHERING THE RECEIPT OF EEL
FUNDS TO SUBMISSIONS OF THESE
MULTIPLE METHODS CERTIFICATIONS.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAS
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED A
DISTRICT COMPLIANCE WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF FOR ONE THE
DISTRICT SUBMIT E. O. PLANS
EVERY THREE YEARS TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN DECEMBER TWENTY FIFTEEN
JUST OVER FIFTY PERCENT OF OUR
DISTRICTS WERE.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THAT
REQUIREMENT.
AND ONCE FUNDING WAS TETHERED
TO HAVING THOSE.
THOSE THINGS IN PLACE THAT YOUR
PLAN THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
WERE AT ALMOST ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT COMPLIANCE WITH HAVING
THOSE.
IMPORTANT STRUCTURES AT ALL OF
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS.
SO TOTALING FUNDS TO.
TO HAVING A ROBUST E. O. PLANS
LOCALLY.
WE'VE SEEN THAT IT'S HAD A AN
ACTUAL IMPACT IT'S PROPORTIONAL
TO THE FUNDING.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WAS ABLE TO
ALLOCATE FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO EACH LOCAL DISTRICT. AGAIN
WERE SPLITTING THIS SEVENTY TWO
WAYS SO WE'RE ABLE TO ALLOCATE
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH
LOCAL DISTRICT.
THAT CERTIFY COMPLIANCE WITH
THE MULTIPLE METHODS.
CERTIFICATION PROCESS.
.
THROUGH THE SUBMISSION OF THE
MULTIPLE METHODS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE REQUIRES IS THAT THE
DISTRICT PROVIDE A NARRATIVE OF
WHAT THE DISTRICT IS DOING.
TO.
TO PROMOTE IO IN EACH OF THOSE
NINE AREAS AND.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THEN
COLLECTS THIS INFORMATION AND I
IN THROUGH STATEWIDE COMMITTEE.
TWO YEARS AGO WE PRODUCED A.
IN E. OWN DIVERSITY BEST
PRACTICES MANUAL THAT HIGHLIGHTS
OF SOME OF THE BEST IDEAS THAT
WE SAW IN DIFFERENT LOCAL
DISTRICTS WHICH ARE REALLY LIKE.
LABORATORIES FOR.
FOR TRYING NEW AND INNOVATIVE
EEO PROGRAM SO WE WE REALLY ARE
TRYING TO CONNECT OUR DISTRICTS
WITH ONE ANOTHER A TO SEE WHAT'S
WORKING AND WHAT'S NOT WORKING
OBVIOUSLY IT WILL IT WILL.
DIFFER IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
STATE.
OF SO THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THE LOCAL FUNDS OUT FROM
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
PERSPECTIVE.
WE ARE FOCUSING THIS YEAR ON.
PROMOTING.
ATTENTION IMPORTANCE TO THE USE
OF DATA IN LOCAL E. O. PROGRAMS
AT THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
INITIATE A PROGRAM AT TO ASSIST
OUR LOCAL DISTRICTS WITH THE
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS.
OF LOCAL DISTRICT DEMOGRAPHIC
APPLICANTS IN EMPLOYMENT DATA.
ARE DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED IN THE.
THE REGULATIONS OF THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS AYE IN TITLE FIVE TWO
COLLECT AND ANALYZE OF LOCAL.
APPLICANT DATA FROM DISABLED SO
YOU HAVE A.
A FACULTY FULL TIME FACULTY
POSITION
WHO WAS IN THE INITIAL APPLICANT
POOL WHO WAS STILL IN THE POOL
ONCE YOU RUN THE MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS. WHO RECEIVED AN
INTERVIEW?
WHO WAS HIRED WHO IS PROMOTED
ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE SPECTRUM
OF EMPLOYMENT?
IN THERE ARE VARIOUS
STATISTICAL ANALYSES THAT THAT
YOU CAN IMPLEMENT TO SEE.
IF THERE ARE ANY.
PLACES ALONG THE SPECTRUM OF
EMPLOYMENT WHERE THERE MAY BE A
DISPARATE IMPACT.
TO CERTAIN MONITOR GROUPS SO WE
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO THREE WEEKS
AGO.
PRODUCED THE.
EEL LONGITUDINAL A DATA GUIDE.
THAT YOU RECEIVED A COPY OF
IT'S ON OUR WEBSITE AND WE ARE.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WILL BE
PROVIDING STATEWIDE TRAININGS OF
THIS FALL NINE FIVE DIFFERENT
AREAS OF THE STATE FOR OUR LOCAL
HR OFFICERS AND INTERESTED
FACULTY.
AND AND STAFF.
SO THAT OUR SYSTEM IN OUR LOCAL
DISTRICTS WILL HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE THE POWER
OF.
DATA.
IN THE EEL CONTEXT.
AND THE THE VERY.
GOOD RESULTS THAT WE CAN SEE OUT
FROM USING THE DATA
APPROPRIATELY.
NOT HAPPEN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
START WITH THAT.
GETTING RID.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. ARM JUST
TO FALL BUT THAT.
CAN YOU COLLEGES COULD YOU ON.
DE GIVE A LITTLE MORE
SPECIFICITY AROUND HOW YOUR
EFFORTS IMPACTED RECRUITING
IMPACT POLL. ON THERE WASN'T
ANY.
SPECIFIC DATA ABOUT HOW THE
ACTIONS WERE.
CREATING AN IMPACT SURE ARE ON
PAGE SEVEN OF YOUR AGENDA WE
HAVE SOME SOME DATA ABOUT THE
DEMOGRAPHIC COMPOSITION. OF OUR.
TENURE TENURE TRACK FULL TIME
FACULTY.
SYSTEM WIDE.
I WILL SAY AB SO TWO THINGS ONE
ALL OF THE DATA THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS COLLECTED
FROM OUR LOCAL DISTRICTS GOING
BACK MORE THAN TEN YEARS. IS UP
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE IN YOU WE ACTUALLY JUST
ADAPTED A NEW TOOL THAT YOU CAN
RUN VARIOUS ANALYSES TO SEE THE
WAY THE TRENDS OF CHANGED OVER
TIME. I WILL SAY THAT OUR
STUDENT POPULATION SO BE NO
SURPRISE.
IS.
OVER FIFTY FIVE PERCENT UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITIES.
OUR FULL TIME TENURE TENURE
TRACK FACULTY.
IS.
IS NOT NEARLY.
THAT DIVERSE.
I DO BELIEVE THAT WE ARE AT
ABOUT TWENTY TWO PERCENT
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY.
AND THE FAMILY ASPECT WHICH
AGAINST YOU CAN ANSWER IT SHORT
ARM.
WHAT IMPACTS HAVE TO ROB
ACTUALLY YOU'VE OUTLINED?
HOUSE
ON YOUR ABILITY TO RECRUIT AND
HIRE MORE DIVERSE FACULTY.
THE DATA THAT WE'VE RECEIVED
ANSWERED THAT QUESTION
CERTIFICATE THAT THE GREAT THE
DATA THAT WE'VE RECEIVED IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS OF FROM OUR LOCAL
DISTRICTS RELATED TO FIRST TIME
HIRES. HAS SHOWN THAT THE.
PERCENTAGE OF UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITIES HAS INCREASED FROM
TWENTY PERCENT IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN.
TO THIRTY PERCENT.
JUST LAST YEARS WE'VE SEEN A
FIFTY PERCENT INCREASE IN WHAT'S
BEEN REPORTED AS
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY HIRES
FIRST TIME BUYERS FROM A LOCAL
DISTRICT THAT'S GREAT AND WHAT
THE LOCAL DISTRICT TRIBUTE THAT
TO.
AND I'M SURE IT'S DIFFERENT FOR
DIFFERENT AREAS BUT IN. MAYBE
YOU CAN GIVE ME SOME EXAMPLES
FOR YOU KNOW.
IT IS DIFFERENT FROM DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS AND YOU KNOW WE WE
RECEIVE MORE INFORMATIONS FROM
SOME DISTRICTS THAN OTHERS. BUT
I I I DO KNOW THAT.
MANY DISTRICTS HAVE REPORTED
THAT THE.
THE INFLUX IN FULL TIME HIRING
DOLLARS ONE TIME TWO YEARS AGO.
IT ENABLED.
MORE HIRING TO TAKE PLACE THAT
PARTICULAR YEAR WHICH REMEMBER
INCOMMUNICADO SYSTEM WITH OVER
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FULL TIME
FACULTY.
EVERY YEAR WERE HIRING OF ITS.
PEBBLES INTO A POND IMPORTANT
COUPLES.
BUT DOWN I KNOW WAS REPORTED IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
THESE EEO DOLLARS AND NOT ONLY
SOME OF THE PROGRAM'S LOCALLY
THAT HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED BUT.
THE.
.
EMPHASIS THAT'S BEEN PLACED ON.
BEST PRACTICES THROUGHOUT THE
SYSTEM WE'VE HAD MANY DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE SO THAT THAT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL AND.
HAS ALLOWED THEM TO ADOPT
PROGRAMS THAT BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
OTHER PLACES WHAT IT WILL BE
HELPFUL WAS P. JUST TO GET A.
GREATER UNDERSTANDING OF
SPECIFICALLY WHAT PROGRAMS AND
WHAT COLLEGES ARE DISTRICTS ARE.
BEING SUCCESSFUL FOR OUR AND
WHAT'S WORKING OBVIOUSLY
UNDERSTAND THAT DIFFERENT.
.
COLLEGES MAY DO DIFFERENT THINGS
AND THAT'S TOTALLY
UNDERSTANDABLE. BUT IT'S UNDER
IT WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
WHAT'S WORKING ABSOLUTELY I.
I CAN PULL TOGETHER MORE
INFORMATION AND WE ALREADY HAVE
THE PUBLICATION THAT WE PUT
TOGETHER LAST YEAR ON THE BEST
PRACTICES UNIVERSITY BEST
PRACTICES MANUAL. THAT.
I DID NOT PROVIDE YOU A COPY
WITH TODAY IT'S ON OUR WEBSITE
KNOW MAKE SURE THAT YOU GET A
COPY.
BUT IT ACTUALLY IT'S FOR OUR
STATEWIDE EEO COMMITTEE SELECTED
THE THREE BEST PROGRAMS THAT
FRIEND IN THEIR OPINION FROM
EACH OF OUR SEVENTY TWO
DISTRICTS IN THE NINE BEST
PRACTICE AREAS. GREAT IT BE
GREAT TO GET A BREAKDOWN OF THAT
TENURE DATACOM BACK IN TERMS OF
THE.
CHANGED ON MY PRE* THAT THE
CHART THAT ARM.
DISBARRED PROVIDED US FROM CSU
TO KIND OF GIVE US A LITTLE OF
BIT OF HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE.
AND AND TO MISS BARD I'M.
KICKING YOU WALK US THROUGH A
LITTLE BIT HOW THE LOW POINT
NINE MILLION WAS SPENT.
ARE.
WHAT THE VARIETY CAMPUSES I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE WERE?
SPENT A SIMILAR WAYS ARE ALL
DIFFERENT WAYS.
SURE WE HAVE.
OBVIOUSLY TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES
AND NINETEEN CAMPUSES SUBMITTED
A PROPOSAL AND WE FUNDED ELEVEN
OF THOSE.
TRUMP I HAVE A BREAKDOWN THAT'S
NOT IN YOUR IN YOUR MATERIALS
BUT I BEACH I'M HAPPY THIS TO
SHARE WITH YOU AND THEY HAD A
LOT OF DIFFERENT IDEAS.
ONE OF THE COMMON THREADS THAT
WE SAW IN ALMOST EVERY PROPOSAL
WAS A NEED FOR MORE.
SEARCH COMMITTEE TRAININGS
PARTICULARLY AROUND UNCONSCIOUS
BIAS AND SIMILAR THINGS AND SO
THAT THAT SEND A MESSAGE TO
MYSELF AND MY STAFF THAT THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT WE PUT WE NEEDED
TO WORK ONE ABOVE AND BEYOND
THIS.
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL BUT
DEVELOPMENT AND AND SHARE THAT
SYSTEMICALLY SO THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE WORKING ON AND THEN THE
THE INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES. PALM
FRESNO ART CAO POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO SAN BERNADINE NO AND THE
OTHER EIGHT.
ALL HAVE A VARIETY OF THINGS
SOME OF THEM ON ASKS FOR FUNDING
TO HELP US START UP COSTS.
I'M AND HELP SOME OTHER ADJUNCT
AND THEIR TEMPORARY FACULTY BE
SUPPORTED FOR RESEARCH
OPPORTUNITIES ON BECAUSE.
THERE'S A CERTAINLY AGREE A
LARGE POOL WITH OF TEMPORARY
FACULTY THAT COULD.
BECOME TENURE TRACK IN THE
SEARCH PROCESS AND SOME OF THAT
SUPPORT THAT THEY DON'T HAVE.
FACULTY WERE INTERESTED IN MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WHETHER THAT BE
CONFERENCES OR NETWORKS THERE
WERE ALSO A LOT OF PROPOSALS
AROUND INCLUSION.
BECAUSE I THINK ALL OF US
RECOGNIZE THAT RECRUITING AND
HIRING A DIVERSE PERSON IS IS
NOT THE AND THAT'S ONLY THE
BEGINNING. AND SO THERE'S A A
LARGE FOCUS ON THE COMMUNITIES
ON THE CAMPUSES OF INCLUSION
EFFORT ON CAMPUS AND NETWORKS
AND AND AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY FEEL WELCOMED AND AND.
THEIR TALENTS ARE YOU GUYS ON
THE CAMPUSES OUT AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO SHARE I HAVE COPIES OF
THE DOCUMENT OF ALL OF THE
CAMPUS PROGRAMS IF YOU WOULD
LIKE THAT I CAN PROVIDE THAT TO
YOU AS WELL YEAH YES PLACE.
EITHER ONE OF THE.
PROMISES OF THE HOME INITIAL
FUNDING WAS.
TO INSURE THAT THERE WAS
ADEQUATE RECRUITMENT AND IN POOL
WE CONSTANTLY HAVE TO HEAR. THAT
DE UM THERE'S LIKE A PIPELINE
THERE IS LACK OF APPLICANTS.
SO HOME I I'D ACTUALLY AGREE
WITH I'M HAVING A SEARCH
COMMITTEE TO HAVING THE SEARCH
COMMITTEE TRAINED BY. THE SEARCH
COMMITTEE DOES NEED TO BE
TRAINED IF
YOU DON'T HAVE DIVERSE POOL TO
INTERVIEW FROM SO. I THINK THAT
WAS VERY VERY FIRST THING THAT
HOME WE WERE VERY FOCUSED ON SO
I WOULD BE INTERESTED IN.
HEARING ABOUT HOW THOSE
CAMPUSES.
HANDLED THOSE EFFORTS
SIGN IF YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION
SUMA SIMILAR TO WHAT MISS CALLS
HIM I THINK PROVIDED FREE FOR
YOU SEE I THINK YOU COULD SEE
THAT YOU SEE OBVIOUSLY THERE.
DEAF YOUR CAMPUSES FEWER
DEPARTMENTS BUT. THEY THEY
CHOOSE LITERALLY ONLY FOR
DEPARTMENTS THEY GAVE EACH A
DECENT.
CHUNK OF MONEY BY THINK YOU
COULD YOU COULD SEE THE RESULTS
SORT.
SHORT NOT CERTAINLY AND A COUPLE
OF THE CAMPUS IS REALLY FOCUSED
ON STEM DISCIPLINES AND.
SAID THERE WERE CERTAINLY SOME
FOCUS CAMPUS SPECIFIC BUT THERE
WAS A LOT OF INTERESTING GETTING
AND INVOLVED WITH THE.
.
OUR POSTDOCS
AND OUR GRAD STUDENTS AND GOING
OUT TO SOME OF THOSE NETWORKS I
ONLY MENTIONED A FEW OF THE
CONFERENCES FOR EXAMPLE OF A
DIVERSITY COMMENTS IS THAT WE'VE
ATTENDED. BUT THERE WAS.
A LOT OF EFFORT AROUND HELP WE
CAN WE REACH AND CREATE MORE
DIVERSE POOLS AND. CERTAINLY AND
WE CAN PULL SOME MORE
INFORMATION FOR YOU ARE NOT
SPECIFICALLY DEFINED A HELPFUL
THAT THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
AND I JUST WONDERED JUST FAT
FAKE COME.
HISPIDUS CARLSON.
FOR THE.
I THINK FOR THE PRESENTATION WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE.
SPECIFICITY IT REGARDING THE
DEPARTMENTS AND.
I THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
HAVE A LITTLE MORE.
UNDERSTANDING AT THE DEPARTMENT
LEVEL WHAT SOME OF THE FUNDS
WERE SPENT FOR I MEAN WE BECAME
A LOT OF DISCRETION. AND.
I DON'T I THINK WHAT WE'RE JUST
LOOK REFORMERS FEEDBACK AS TO
WHAT WAS EFFECTIVE IN THEIR
MIND.
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
OUR OWN PART I HAVE MY OWN
BELIEFS OF WHAT MIGHT BE
EFFECTIVE BUT I THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY GET.
SPECIFIC FEEDBACK FROM THE
FACULTY MEMBERS WHO WERE IN
CHARGE OF. THOSE AYE RECRUITMENT
AND SEARCH PROCESSES OF WHAT
WHAT WORKED WHAT DIDN'T WORK.
AND WHERE WHERE WE CAN AMPLIFY
YOUR YOUR EFFORTS AT OTHER
CAMPUSES AS WELL AS AT CSU AND
ACT. ON COMMUNICORP IS OBVIOUSLY
KNOWING THAT EACH OF THE.
SEGMENT IS DIFFERENT BUT YET.
THAT YOU'RE THERE PROBABLY THAT
THE THE PLACES WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO CONFERENCES ARE FINITE
THE PHD PROGRAMS ARE FINITE PHD
GRADUATES ARE. ARE FINE I DIDN'T
IN ESSENCE.
BICU ARE GOING AFTER.
.
GET OF SOMEWHAT SIMILAR. SIMILAR
POOLS OF PEOPLE.
AND.
I I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT BOTH YEARS OR THE
CURRENT YEAR.
I THINK BOTH BOTH FIGHTERS WOULD
BE AND WOULD BE HELPFUL I I
DON'T THINK WERE LOOKING FOR A
LINE LIKE I'M.
YOU KNOW LIKE I TWENTY TWENTY
YOU HAVE BUDGETS FOR YOU ALLEN
NIGHT I JUST THINK JUST JUST TO
GET SOME FEEDBACK AS TO WHAT
WHAT WAS WHAT WAS WORKING. AND
WOULD BE GREAT IN TERMS OF ON.
IRAQ DOT ARE DESERTING YOU
MENTIONED THAT SOME OF THE MONEY
WENT TO FELLOWSHIPS WHICH
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN SOMETHING
THAT WOULD HAVE NECESSARILY OUR
CURRENT ME BAD. OBVIOUSLY SEEMS
LIKE A MIX LAW SENSE BECAUSE WHY
NOT GIVE THEM A FELLOWSHIP SO
THEN YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO. ITEMS
LIKE THE WAY WE APPROACH OUR
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM HERE AT THE
CAPITOL BECAUSE YOU GET. TENDS
TO SEE PEOPLE THAT YOU WOULD GET
TO WORK WITH THEM FOR A YEAR SO
THEN YOU REALLY SEE. BUT THEY'RE
LIKE FIRST AS A IN A TWO HOUR
INTERVIEW SO THAT I THINK THAT
MAYES COSTS A LOT OF SENSE COME
AND AND I THOUGHT THAT WAS VERY
INTERESTING. APPROACH AND SO I
CAN GIVE YOU A COUPLE EXAMPLES
BUT BUT AT A HIGHER LEVEL FOR
THESE UNITS TO GET A. LARGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
WAS IT AN AMAZING INCENTIVE WAS
JUST LIKE.
OKAY.
WE DON'T NORMALLY GET THIS MUCH
MONEY IN A SINGLE YEAR TO HELP
US WITH HIRING AND THERE'S. VERY
LITTLE THAT FACULTY CARE ABOUT
MORE THAN HIRING RIGHT FINDING
THE RIGHT COLLEAGUES.
.
TO JOIN THEM SO THAT IN ITSELF
MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE AND AS A
MOTIVATOR.
BUT THE FELLOWSHIPS.
IN THE FIRST YEAR RIVERSIDE.
.
PART OF THE AMAZING SUCCESS THEY
HAD IN ENGINEERING OF RECRUITING
THIS DIVERSE GROUP WAS.
UP THROUGH THE OFFER OF THAT
EIGHTY FIVE FUNDED A FULLY
FUNDED YEAR AS A POSTDOCTORAL.
SCHOLAR IN ADDITION TO WHATEVER
OTHER POST DOCTORAL WORK THEY
HAD DONE AND ALLOW IT LETTUCE
DID GET INTO THE POOL A LITTLE
BIT EARLIER WHEN IT'S.
A LITTLE BIT MORE DIVERSE AND
CONVINCE THEM THAT THIS WAS THE
PLACE FOR THEM.
IT'S ALSO BEING BEEN USED
EFFECTIVELY THIS YEAR YET.
SANTA BARBARA AND ECONOMICS.
.
I THINK IT'S A AYE. A MECHANISM
IT'S EXPENSIVE BUT IT'S A
MECHANISM THAT I THINK TOM WOULD
WORK A LOT OF DISCIPLINES.
AND I THINK THAT'S GREAT I THINK
THAT'S GREAT FEEDBACK WHAT I
UNDERSTAND IT IS.
EXPENSIVE BUT IT'S.
THESE ARE POSITIONS THAT YOU
HAVE A PERSON FOR POTENTIALLY
THIRTY AFTER THIRTY YEARS SINCE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT OVER THIRTY
YEARS IT'S NOT VERY EXPENSIVE AT
ALL.
SO I THINK THANK YOU FOR THE.
MR MEDINA. AS WE TALK ABOUT THE
EXPENSE.
NOT I'M LOOKING HERE IT SAYS
THAT ESTIMATED. A FUNDING FOR
THIS YEAR IS ONE POINT THREE
MILLION AS OPPOSED TO TWO POINT
THREE MILLION. FROM THE PREVIOUS
YEAR.
.
WHAT I'M READING HERE IN FRONT
OF ME?
THAT IS IS THAT.
CORRECT.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
WE PUT ONE TIME MONEY IN THE
BUDGET LATIMES TO YEAR'S THAT
THERE'S THERE'S NO MONEY IN THIS
YEAR'S GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET WE COULD CONSIDER AGAIN
WHEN WE CLOSE OUT OUR BUDGET. OF
ANY EIGHTEEN BUT I JUST HEARD
THE IMPORTANCE OF OF FUNDING AND
HOW EXPENSIVE THIS IS.
AND IT'S CERTAINLY IMPORTANT.
.
ONE THING THAT I THINK IS
MISSING IN THE DATA HERE IN
FRONT OF US. IS THE COMPARISON
BETWEEN FACULTY AND THE STUDENT
BODY A WE HEARD FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT THE
STUDENT BODY IS. FIFTY PERCENT.
MINORITY FIFTY PERCENT. OF
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
A SIX PERCENT UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITIES RIGHT.
FIFTY SIX PERCENT UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
CRACKED AND STILL AND FACULTY OF
COLOR MAKE UP.
WHAT PERCENT OF I BELIEVE IT IS
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY TWO TO
TWENTY THREE PERCENT
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY FULL
TIME FACULTY
FACULTY?
AND IT.
YOU KNOW I I THINK THIS IS A.
LOU TO DETAIL HERE FROM UC AND
CSU BUT IF I WERE TO ASK YOU.
.
SAY FOR EXAMPLE.
FOR A. LET'S LET'S GO TO LATINO
STUDENTS WITHIN CSU.
CAN YOU GIVE ME WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF OUR STUDENTS IN CSU OR LATINO
STUDENTS.
I DO NOT HAVE THE EXACT NUMBER
BUT I WILL GET THEM FOR YOU BUT
I I WOULD SUGGEST THAT IT'S
PROBABLY CLOSE TO FIFTY PERCENT
I WOULD SAY YOU'RE RIGHT YEAH I
THINK.
BUT STILL OF FACULTY ARE ONLY
FOUR POINT FIVE PERCENT LATINO.
WHIP WHERE STUDENT BODY IS A.
ABOUT FIFTY PERCENT WITHIN CSU.
AND FOUR POINT FIVE.
I LIKE DINO FACULTY.
ASKED THE SAME QUESTION TO YOU
SEE.
AND IF YOU COULD TELL ME WHAT
PERCENT OF OF THE STUDENTS AT UC
ARE LATINO.
AND I ALSO BECAUSE I DON'T WORK
INSTANCE I DON'T DOUBTS WHEN IT
COME MONTHS A AND WILL KNOW THE
NUMBER.
SAY EVER CAN ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
SICK GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS FOR
UC OUT YOU SEE IS ABOUT THIRTY
TWO PERCENT YOU ARE AND STUDENTS
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY THIRTY
PERCENT. THIRTY PERCENT AND IF
COULD YOU BREAK IT DOWN A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
FOR ME.
HOW MANY A OF THAT THIRTY
PERCENT MIGHT BE LATINO STUDENTS
BUT SOMEBODY ELSE COMING UP?
I'M HELPING MY SEIZE YOUR
COLLEAGUE.
WHEN THERE'S.
I I'M SORRY I DON'T HAVE THE THE
SPECIFIC DATA RIGHT IN FRONT OF
ME OF THIS PUMP ALTHOUGH THE
LARGEST PORTION IS THE LATINO SO
MAYBE THIRTY PERCENT. MIGHT BE.
WE WE KNOW THAT IN THE LAST
GENERAL.
ADMISSIONS
PERIOD THAT LATINO STUDENTS WERE
ALMOST FORTY PERCENT OF THOSE
WHO OF THE ADMITTED STUDENT
YEAH.
FORTY PERCENT OF ADMITTED
STUDENTS NEW STUDENTS COMING AT.
OF THE APPLICATIONS CYCLE OF AYE
HAPLOTYPE DON'T KNOW THE
EMOTIONS NUMBER FOR THAT AGAIN.
BUT DO YOU KNOW FACULTY ONLY
MAKE UP FOUR POINT FIVE PERCENT.
OF TENURED FACULTY.
AND ANOTHER THING WE DON'T HAVE
HERE IN FRONT OF THIS IS THE
LONGITUDINAL. FOR THE HISTORIC
GROWTH.
OR I WOULD SAY.
PERHAPS LACK OF GROWTH.
UP OF FACULTY UP.
OVERALL RIGHT OVERALL BECAUSE I
HAVE SEEN THE DATA WE WITH THE
DATA WAS GIVEN TO US A IN THE
LATINO CAUCUS IN THE BLACK
CAUCUS.
OF FOR THE PAST FORTY YEARS.
SO I I I WOULD.
COMMAND.
BOTH UC AND CSU. OF FOR FOR.
MOVING THE NEEDLE A LITTLE BIT.
BUT I WOULD POINT OUT THE STUDY
THAT WAS DONE OR THE.
NEWS STORIES THAT RECENTLY CAME
OUT SHOWING THAT DISPARITY THE
DISPARITY BETWEEN FACULTY. AND.
AND STUDENTS.
.
WE WE WE HEARD EARLIER THIS
MORNING ABOUT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
PROPOSED UP FROM THE GOVERNOR.
TO.
DO ONLINE.
.
RIGHT TO IT INCREASE ONLINE
EDUCATION WITH THE PURPOSE OF
INCREASING A STAND.
AND NOW.
THE GRADUATES
RIGHT IN UC AND CSU.
I AYE MY PROPOSAL THAT TEN
MILLION DOLLARS COULD BE BETTER
SPENT.
ON HIRING MORE MINORITY FACULTY
IN UC AND CSU.
.
QUESTION TO.
CSU.
SPECIFICALLY AT THAT THE SAN
LUIS OBISPO.
CAMPUS.
A LACK OF THAT DIVERSITY AMONG
STUDENTS
AND AND I THINK LACK OF
DIVERSITY FACULTY A CAMPUS THAT
PRODUCES PROBABLY OF MAYBE THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF ENGINEERS. A
IN THE CSU SYSTEM HA HOW COULD
SEE AS YOU DO BETTER. AT THE.
SAN LUIS OBISPO CAMPUS.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND I
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT SAN LUIS
OBISPO HAS THE FULL SUPPORT OF
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THEY
HAVE AN INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE
PRESIDENT. WHO'S VERY INTERESTED
IN THIS ISSUE CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS THIS ISSUE AND IS DOING A
NUMBER OF. THINGS ON CAMPUS TO
TRY TO WIDEN AND AND BECOME MORE
DIVERSE ON IT'S NOT ADMITTEDLY
MOVING AS QUICKLY AS I THINK WE
WOULD ALL LIKE BUT THERE ARE A
LOT OF INITIATIVES THERE AND.
YOU KNOW I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
HAVE A SOMETHING PUT TOGETHER
THAT WOULD GIVE YOU A FULL
PICTURE OF WHAT'S BEING DONE
THERE.
AND AND AND I DO WANNA COMMEND
BOTH CSU AND UC FOR FOR THEIR
EFFORTS AND YOU MENTIONED.
YOU SEE MENTIONED UC RIVERSIDE.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU SEE
RIVERSIDE IS.
THE MOST DIVERSE CAMPUSES
STUDENT BODY.
AND THAT WE'RE MAKING.
ADVANCES IN THE FACULTY.
.
COULD YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT CLUSTER HIRING THAT UC
RIVERSIDE. A HAS USED.
A CLUSTER HIRING A I DON'T KNOW
A LOT ABOUT THE SPECIFICS AT
RIVERSIDE BUT I IT'S.
.
SEEN AS A BEST PRACTICE BECAUSE
IT ALLOWS YOU TO.
.
BRING IN LARGER COHORTS OF
APPLICANTS A AND EVEN TO SEE TO
FIND.
AFFINITIES AMONG APPLICANTS WHO
MIGHT MAKE UP OF GOOD COHORT TO
BRING TO THE UNIVERSITY.
IT'S.
THAT. THE RESEARCH IS ON EVEN.
ON WHETHER COHORTS ARE THE BEST
WAY TO DIVERSIFY THE FACULTY PA
IT IT DEPENDS ON MANAGING IT
WELL WHICH IS HARD BECAUSE
YOU'RE BRINGING. WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IS YOU'RE INTERVENING INTO
THE STANDARD? DEPARTMENT
DECISION MAKING ABOUT WHO.
THEY WANT TO CHOOSE AS THEIR
NEXT COLLEAGUE AND ACTUALLY IT'S
PROBABLY AND IN MANY CASES A
GOOD IDEA TO.
TO GET PEOPLE TO THINK BEYOND
THEIR STANDARD DISCIPLINARY WAYS
OF HIRING COLLEAGUES AND TO
THINK ACROSS DISCIPLINES WHICH
IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY COSTS
ARE HIGHER IS OFTEN DO SUCCEED.
IS GOOD IS CLUSTER HIRING OF.
LIMITED TO DEPARTMENT OR WOULD
IT BE IT WOULD USUALLY BE A
COULD BE IN A DEPARTMENT.
WAR OF THE SANTA BARBARA PAT.
PILOT THIS YEAR IN ECONOMICS
HAD THEIR THINKING OF IT AS A
CLUSTER HIGHER TO BRING IN
PEOPLE WITH CERTAIN KINDS OF.
EXPERTISE AND ECONOMICS BUT IT
USUALLY.
AMONG DEPARTMENTS AND ACROSS
DEPARTMENTS AND AGAIN BECAUSE SO
MANY OF THAT THE ISSUES.
.
FACULTY.
ARE RESEARCHING GO BEYOND A
SINGLE DISCIPLINE WHEN WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND SOLUTIONS SO IF
WE HIRE FACULTY WHO ARE INCLINED
TO WORK OUTSIDE A SINGLE
DISCIPLINE.
WERE MORE LIKELY TO TO MAKE
ADVANCES IN THE NOSE SOLVING THE
WORLD'S PROBLEMS.
I KNOW THAT UC RIVERSIDE
RECENTLY.
HIRED I THINK.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FIVE OR SEVEN
AT NATIVE AMERICANS OF
PROFESSORS AND I THINK THAT WAS
IN A MONUMENTAL.
A CERTAIN THAT WE WE HADN'T SEEN
A ANYWHERE WOULD PROBABLY DON'T
SEE IT AT ANY OTHER INSTITUTION.
I ALSO READ HERE ARE THE THE.
PRACTICE OF ASKING APPLICANTS
TO WRITE ABOUT.
TALK ABOUT A THEIR EXPERTISE AND
IN TEACHING. I BELIEVE YES A THE
THE POPULATION THAT THEY ARE
TEACHING CAN YOU TALK MORE ABOUT
THAT.
SURE.
NOW ALMOST ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES
REQUIRE A ALL FACULTY APPLICANTS
TO SUBMIT WHAT WE CALL A
CONTRIBUTIONS TO DIVERSITY
STATEMENT.
AND IT.
ENABLES THAT THOSE WHO HAVE
DONE WORK IN THEIR TEACHING IN
THEIR PRIOR RESEARCH OR EVEN
OUTREACH.
I TO TO DIVERSE COMMUNITIES TO
TALK ABOUT THAT.
THE.
BUT MANY OF THE PILOTS HAVE MADE
A CHANGE IN HOW THEY USE THOSE
STATEMENTS WHICH I THINK HAS
BEEN EFFECTIVE AND THEY'VE.
FACTORED THEIR EVALUATION OF
THOSE STATEMENTS ARE EARLY INTO
THE PROCESS EARLIER IT RIVERSIDE
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE ENGINEERING
PILOT LAST YEAR.
THAT THE FIRST CUT OF
APPLICANTS.
FOCUSED ARE MAINLY ON RESEARCH
POTENTIAL IN RESEARCH
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND ON
CONTRIBUTIONS TO DIVERSITY. AND
THAT IS IN LARGE PART WHAT HELP
THEM TO TRACK SUCH A.
A DIVERSE FINALIST POOL AND
THEN A DIVERSE POOL OF HIRES BUT
THEY DID SOMETHING SIMILAR AT
SAN DIEGO ALSO IN ENGINEERING
LAST YEAR WHERE THEY.
THAT THE FACULTY WERE TRAINED
IN HOW TO READ THESE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO DIVERSITY
STATEMENTS AND MANY DISCIPLINES
THIS IS A NEW. ISSUE.
BUT IN A DISPLAY LIKE
ENGINEERING IT THAT OFTEN THE
FOCUS IS ON TEACHING BECAUSE
THAT'S OF A COMPETENCY ALL
FACULTY NEED NOW AT THE ABILITY
TO TEACH A DIVERSE SET OF
STUDENTS.
.
WE NOT TOO FAR BACK HAD A
HEARING AT SAN JOSE STATE ON.
DIVERSITY OF FACULTY A ACROSS
THE THREE SYSTEMS.
AND AND I WOULD.
AND I REMEMBER.
OF
ASTRONOMER.
OF FROM UC BERKELEY AND HE MADE
THE STRONG STATEMENT THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE MORE DIVERSITY.
AND HIGHER EDUCATION AND HIS
STATEMENT WAS BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT TO.
SO I I THINK THE WILL AND IT
NEEDS TO BE THERE.
AND THE PRIORITY NEEDS TO BE
GIVEN TO IT.
.
AND AND AGAIN.
WE ARE MAKING VERY SLOW
PROGRESS.
TOWARDS THAT IF WE LOOK FORTY
YEARS BACK
THE THE THE PERCENTAGES OF.
.
TENURED FACULTY OF COLOR HASN'T
CHANGED MUCH AT ALL.
AND.
IT IS VERY SLOW PROGRESS AND.
AGAIN I I WOULD ENCOURAGE UP
ALL THREE SYSTEMS TO CONTINUE.
TO.
TO WORK AT IT.
BECAUSE I THINK IT DOES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE A TO THE SUCCESS OF
OF THE STUDENTS THAT WE'RE WE'RE
TEACHING.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER DFI ME
CIRCLE BACK FOR A MOMENT ONE.
EXCELLO WHICH YOU ASKED ABOUT.
THE DOCUMENT THAT ILLUSTRATES
ALL OF THE SUMMARIES OF THE
FUNDED PROPOSALS FOR THIS PAST
YEAR INCLUDES A FIVE PARAGRAPH
ONE SL LOW. AND THEY ARE
PROPOSING LAUNCHING A CLUSTER
HIGHER FOR TEN DEPARTMENTS TEN
FACULTY MEMBER ACROSS
DEPARTMENTS AND I ALSO HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WHICH
TALKS ABOUT CLUSTER HIRES THAT
WAS THAT THEY HAVE ALREADY DONE.
IN THE COLLEGE OF LIBERAL ARTS
AND ALSO IN MATH AND SCIENCE ON
THIS DOCUMENT CONTAINS OTHER
INFORMATION THOUGH SO I CAN PEEL
OUT THE SPECIFIC INFORMATION TO
PROVIDE TO YOU. THANK YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME AND AND I KNOW WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS ON
ON THE STOP.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MARTZ ITCHY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I.
THIS A SUBJECT TO.
REMINDS ME OF HOW WHEN I WAS A
STUDENT AT UCLA LAW SCHOOL WE
WOULD BE.
ADVOCATING FOR MORE FACULTY
DIVERSITY AND.
AND WE WOULD HAVE.
DEMONSTRATIONS IN PETITIONS.
AND THEN WE WILL GET SOMEONE.
AND THEN THE RELIEF.
SO.
THE RETENTION IS THERE
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ALSO. ESPECIALLY
WHERE.
IT SEEMS LIKE BECAUSE THE POOL
IS SO SMALL THAT.
THEY THEY. THE THAT THE
TALENTED.
.
FACULTY OF COLOR ARE HIGHLY
SOUGHT AFTER ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
SO OF FOR ALL THREE SEGMENTS IN
THE WATER WHAT ARE THE THEY THAT
THEY'RE. THE MOST.
SUCCESSFUL OR COMPELLING
ARGUMENTS AS TO WHY TO COME AND
TO STAY. AT UC CSU ARE ARE ARE
CALIFORNIA CAN BE COLLEGES.
ORDER AND I WOULD IMAGINE THERE
BE WIDE VARIATION A DEPENDING ON
THE CAMPUS AND DEPARTMENT AND
AND DISCIPLINE IN.
IN OUR GREAT RESEARCH
FACILITIES.
BUTTA ARE IS OUR TH ONE BIG
ROTH FLOOR AT DIVERSE FACULTY IS
OUR DIVERSE STUDENT BODY OF
FACULTY WANT TO WORK WITH OUR
STUDENTS AND DAY THEY FIND IT
QUITE COMPELLING.
TO
TO TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WHICH WE WORK WITH SUCH A
DIVERSE STUDENT BODY SO I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY BUT. THE ONE OF
THE TOP WAYS WE CAN RECRUIT.
AND IT'S.
.
BUT INDEED A GREAT AUNT TOOL
THAT WE HAVE.
AT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
ALSO FOUND HELPS ONCE WEEK
WRITTEN.
RECRUIT THOSE FACULTY RETAIN
THEM.
IS TO BE SURE THEY'RE FINDING
THE RIGHT COMMUNITY NOT JUST
AMONG THEIR STUDENTS BUT AMONG
THEIR PEERS.
AND I MENTIONED EARLIER THE
PRESIDENT'S POSTDOCTORAL FELLOWS
PROGRAM.
SIMILAR TO THAT PROGRAM AT CSU
WHICH WE'VE HAD FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS AND IT.
BRINGS IN A COHORT OF NEW
POSTDOCTORAL FELLOWS IN ALL
DISCIPLINES.
WHEN THAT WE NOW BRING IN ABOUT.
OVER THIRTY YEARS WE HAVE
ROUGHLY SAY THAT IT'S A TO YOUR
PROBLEMS SEVENTY OF THOSE
FELLOWS EVERY YEAR AND OVER
THIRTY YEARS WE'VE BUILT A
COMMUNITY. ACROSS THE SYSTEM AND
OUR PRIMARY GOAL FOR RUNNING
THAT PROGRAM IS TO RECRUIT THOSE
AMAZINGLY TALENTED OF FELLOWS
INTO THE FACULTY BUT ONCE THEY
GET INTO THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE
A READY MADE. NETWORK ACROSS THE
SYSTEM.
DEAD.
ENABLES THEM TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT'S NOT GOING SO WELL
CRITICALLY WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT AND I'M IN THE POSITION TO
EVALUATE THEM. AND THEN WE JUST
STARTED.
THREE YEARS AGO. A.
EXIT AND RETENTION SURVEY OF OUR
FACULTY
SO THAT WE WOULD HAVE BETTER
DATA ON.
WHY FACULTY DO LEAVE AND WHY
THEY STAY?
AND IT'S.
.
OTHER FINDINGS ARE NOT.
SO SURPRISING BUT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE DATA FOR THE FIRST TIME
THAT CONFIRMS.
WHAT WE THOUGHT WE KNEW ABOUT
WHY FACULTY LEAVING MY THE STATE
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE YET BECAUSE
THE NUMBERS ARE SMALLER?
?
IT IS THE ABILITY TO.
DISAGGREGATED THOSE FINDINGS
ACROSS THAT WE CAN DO IT BY
GENDER BUT WE CAN'T YET DO IT BY
RACE AND ETHNICITY.
SO YOU THEIR DATA IS
INSUFFICIENT TO.
TRY TO.
TO DRAW IT TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW
WHY WHY DO ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN
FACULTY LEAVE OR STAY ONE WHAT'S
COMPELLING OR WHY DO AT LATINO
FACT BELIEVERS TODAY. UP BUT I
CAN TELL YOU ONE ONE OF THE
FINDINGS FOR ALL FACULTY AND IS
THAT.
.
SALARY MATTERS YOU KNOW THEIR
ABILITY TO.
LIVE IN IN OUR STATE.
IS A BIG ISSUE FOR. THE FACULTY
BUT THE QUALITY OF THEIR
STUDENTS AND COLLEAGUES IS RIGHT
THERE AS WELL.
AND I WOULD ALMOST ECHO
EVERYTHING THAT MY COLLEAGUE
SHARED AS WELL ON TO MY EARLIER
COMMENT ABOUT HIRING SOMEONE IS
JUST THE FIRST STEP IN AND
PAYING A LOT MORE ATTENTION
FOCUSED ON INCLUSION AND WHY
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING. ON OUR
CAMPUSES ARE DOING A BETTER JOB
I'M A GREAT JOB ON MOST OF THE
BUILDING COMMUNITIES OF SUPPORT
NOT ONLY FOR THE FACULTY MEMBER
BUT ALSO FOR THE FAMILY AND AND
FILLED. HER THE TROOP COMMUNITY
IN THAT AREA THEY LIVE IN A BUT
WE CERTAINLY HAVE CHALLENGES
WITH SALARIES.
AND THE COST OF LIVING.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE AND SO THAT'S THAT'S A
LARGE PIECE OF COMING OF OUR
PRELIMINARY DATA AS WELL. PA BUT
THERE AND AT BUT CERTAINLY THE
MISSION AND THE THE STE THE
STUDENT POPULATION I THINK IS IS
PROBABLY THE NUMBER ONE REASON
THE MOST TO DO STAY INTERESTED.
AGAIN IT WOULD BE FOR THE
COMMUNICATIVE SYSTEM CERTAINLY
THE MISSION OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AND THE INCREDIBLY DIVERSE
STUDENT BODY THAT WE SERVE SO I
WOULD I WOULD POINT OUT AS FAR
AS THE IMPORTANCE OF OF
RETENTION AND IT'S IT'S A
CENTRAL BECAUSE AS YOU POINTED
OUT THERE'S.
GETTING SOMEONE THE DOORS ONE
THING BUT IF YOU CAN'T KEEP
THEM.
THEN YOU HAVEN'T YOU HAVEN'T
GOTTEN ANYWHERE SO THREE OF THE
NINE MULTIPLE METHODS THAT WE
USE THAT THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
FOR ALLOCATING <c.green>O. FUNDING</c>
RELATE TO. A POST HIRING AND
RETENTION.
IN THE INCLUDE.
WHETHER OUR DISTRICTS HAVE A
PROFESSIONAL DO WELL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS ARE FOCUSED ON
DIVERSITY.
WHETHER A DIVERSITY IS
INCORPORATED INTO CRITERIA FOR
EMPLOYEE EVALUATION AND TENURE
REVIEW WHICH I THINK IS ACTUALLY
A VERY INTERESTING ONE. AT THE
HAS TO BE NEGOTIATED LOCAL WE.
WITH.
WITH UNIONS.
AND THEN.
GROW YOUR OWN PROGRAMS WE'VE.
WE'VE HAD A A FLOWERING OF.
MENTORSHIP PROGRAMS ARE FOCUSED
ON DIVERSITY THAT ARE.
AIMS TO DO JUST THAT IS TO
RETAIN UR OUR DIVERSE FACULTY.
ALRIGHT AND.
ONE LAST QUESTION I I. I KNOW
THAT.
.
ASIANS.
CAN SOMETIMES BE INCLUDED AND
AND THESE DIVERSITY PROGRAMS AND
SOMETIMES ARE NOT.
SEVERAL MENTIONED AT DIFFERENT
TIMES UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITY.
DO YEAR DIVERSE CITY.
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS TARGET
ASIANS.
AND THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION SO SO
WHEN WE USE UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY AT YOU SEE WE DO MEAN.
DE.
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO AND
NATIVE AMERICAN.
BUT WE OFTEN ALSO TALK ABOUT.
FACULTY OF COLOR AND AND IT
REALLY VARIES BY DISCIPLINE.
HOW REPRESENTED ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED SHUTTLE OTHER
FACULTY OF COLOR ARE INCLUDING
ASIAN?
I KNOW DAVIS ONE OF THEIR
CONCERNS HAS BEEN.
EVEN SUBPOPULATIONS OF GOODNESS
A LOT OF THINGS THAT YOU KNOW I
GET FOLDED INTO ASIAN SUB SUB
AGE PERCEPTIBLY LESIONS OF.
ASIAN.
.
FACULTY ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO
THEM AGAIN BECAUSE THEY STUDENTS
ARE.
CONCERNED THAT THEY'RE NOT
SEEING A ASIAN FACULTY ON
TEACHING THEIR COURSE ISN'T IN
CERTAIN DISCIPLINES.
SO.
.
IF IT HASN'T BEEN A FOCUS OF
THIS PROGRAM BUT IT'S SOMETHING
WE CERTAINLY TRACK.
EFFECT WE TRACK.
.
IT'S AVAILABLE IN OUR.
INFORMATION CENTER ONLINE.
FACULTY.
WE HAVE YOU KNOW OUT. A WHITE
FACULTY ASIAN FACULTY AND DIE
UNDER REPRESENTED CATEGORIES OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO AND
NATIVE AMERICAN BUT WE ALSO TO
SEGREGATE BY. US CITIZENSHIP
STATUS.
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S IT'S ANOTHER
WAY OF THINKING ABOUT WHO ARE
FACULTY ARE AT YOU SEE NEARLY A
QUARTER OF THE FACULTY ARE.
NOT CITIZENS OF THIS COUNTRY SO.
WE HAD IT TELLS YOU SOMETHING
ABOUT THE BACH COMMUNITY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF CONNECTING ARTS
HUMANITIES AT THE UNIVERSITY TO
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE WORLD.
YES WE DO INCLUDE ASIAN AND.
THOUGH THE PIE CHART ON THE
HAND OUT.
ACTUALLY ILLUSTRATES A I'M.
A FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT CHANGE ON
IT WE WENT FROM TWENTY THREE
POINT SIX PERCENT AND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND HAVE A DROPPED A
TWENTY TWO AND A HALF PERCENT
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. BUT THE FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN MORE SEEING
TWENTY SEVEN POINT TWO SO
THIRSTY THIRST ON SOME
IMPROVEMENT IN THAT AREA. THAT
SHOW I THINK WE'RE QUITE A QUITE
OUR INITIATIVES HAVING AN
IMPACT.
AND FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. SIMILAR TO THE UC OUR
OUR CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
DEFINITION OF UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY INCLUDES UP BLACK
HISPANIC. AND NATIVE AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER.
BUT AS FAR AS THE USE OF THE
FUNDING TO OUR LOCAL DISTRICTS.
OF THAT THE FUNDING ABSOLUTELY
THAT CAN BE USED FOR THAT THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF OF
OF ASIAN FACULTY FOR CLASSIFIED
STUFF.
IT REALLY DOES VERY REGION TO
REGION WITHIN THE STATE AND WITH
THE NEEDS.
AND THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF OUR
VARIOUS LOCAL DISTRICTS ARE.
YEAH THANK YOU I I WOULD JUST
CLOSE BY THAT YOU KNOW.
REITERATING.
A POINT THAT I THINK SOMEONE
MADE EARLIER THAT THAT. THERE
ARE DEPARTMENTS
WHERE ASIANS.
MAY BE UNDERREPRESENTED WHERE
MAYBE DIFFICULT TO.
.
HAVE.
ASIAN LAW PROFESSORS.
.
WORD THEY MAY BE OVER
REPRESENTED RELATIVE THE STUDENT
POPULATION AND COLLEGES OF
ENGINEERING AND SO.
LIKE.
NAM WHICH IS ASK OF DATA.
ASIANS NOT BE CATEGORICALLY
EXCLUDED.
.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
THIS WAS THE INFORMATION ON THIS
HELPED INFORM INFORM US ABOUT
THAT.
DECISIONS WE MADE THE PAST TWO
YEARS AND THAT ONE TO HAVE
FOLLOW UP DISCUSSION OF COURSE
AND AND AS WELL WILL CONSIDER.
OF THESE ISSUES FOR POTENTIAL
INCLUSION IN THE TWENTY.
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
THIS IS NO ACTION ITEM ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL NOW PROCEED
WITH PUBLIC COMMENTS.
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
PLEASE LINE UP IN THE MIDDLE.
THE MICROPHONE.
IT'S COMING AROUND HIM AGAIN
PLEASE AS USUAL KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE OR LESS
SIXTY SECONDS OR LESS.
MORNING WITH A BASKET RESEARCH
RESEARCH ANALYST ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL CONTEXT ON
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DIVERSITY
WITHIN THE CSU. THE ANALYSIS
PROVIDED BY THE CSU IN FACT WE
HAVE A MAJORITY OF CSU FACULTY
WHICH INCLUDE LECTURES MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELORS LIBRARIANS
COACHES ALL WHO SERVE STUDENTS
ON A DAILY BASIS. LECTURES WHO
MAKE UP OVER HALF OF THE
INSTRUCTIONAL FACULTY WITHIN THE
CSU ART BACK LEST RACIAL AND
ETHNIC WE DIVERSE BAND TENURE
LINE FACULTY.
OVER THE LAST THIRTY YEARS
NUMBER TENURE LINE FACULTY HAVE
IN FACT REMAINED ESSENTIALLY
FLAT.
ID SPEAKING TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA'S POINT IN THE CSU SYSTEM
FOR EVERYONE LATINO LATINA
FACULTY MEMBER THERE NINETY
SEVEN LATINO LATINA STUDENTS IN
CONTRAST FOR EVERYONE WHITE
FACULTY MEMBER THERE ARE NINE
WHITE STUDENTS.
OF THE MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND STUDENTS IN
THE CSU SYSTEM THREE OF OUT OF
FOR IDENTIFIES STUDENTS OF
COLOR.
AND FOR THE FACULTY OF COLOR WHO
SUPPORT THEM WHO WERE UNDER
REPRESENTED ON OUR CAMPUSES.
THE EXPECTATIONS TO SERVE THEM
WEARING AN INCREASED BURDEN ON
THEIR DAY TO DAY WORKLOAD BECOME
ONLY REFER TO THIS AS CULTURAL
TAXATION AND THEY DO THIS WORK
EVERY DAY. THIS ISSUE CAN CANNOT
EXPLAINS CANNOT ADDRESS THE
UNDER REPRESENTATION OF FACULTY
OF COLOR ON OUR CAMPUSES WITHOUT
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM OF TENURE
DENSITY.
THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
DEDICATED FUNDING FOR TENURE
LINE HIRING THAT CFA IS
ADVOCATING FOR WOULD DEVOTE MUCH
NEEDED RESOURCES TO THIS ISSUE
WOULD ALLOW THE CSU TO BEGIN
MAKING REAL CHANGES TO ENSURE
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO TENURED
FACULTY. AND INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF TENURE LINE FACULTY OF
COLOR THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR DENISE
DAWKINS.
WHAT I NOTICED HERE WAS THE
PEOPLE SITTING HERE WERE NOT
DIVERSE IN IT WOULD REALLY HELP
IF THEY WERE I AM A TENURE TRACK
FACULTY AT CALIFORNIA STATE
BAKERSFIELD I'M IN THE NURSING
DEPARTMENT? AND NOBODY TALKS
ABOUT NURSING AND WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST.
.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT FEMALES
PLEASE DON'T THROW WITHIN WITH
PEOPLE OF UNDER REPRESENTED
COLOR BECAUSE THE NURSING THAT'S
NOT THE ISSUE. I HAVE WORKED MY
CAMPUS IS PROBABLY FORTY
PROBABLY FIFTY SIX FIFTY PERCENT
OR MORE HISPANIC WE HAVE NO
HISPANIC FACULTY. ON THE ONLY
BLACK BACK FULL TIME BLACK
FACULTY
SO I WANT YOU TO KEEP THAT I AM
PART OF THE I WAS ONE OF THE ON
DOCTOR CANDIDATES FROM THE AYE
CHANCELLORS ON PROGRAM THAT
HELPED. AND I'M REALLY PROUD TO
SAY THAT BUT THE RETENTION SUCKS
SORRY AND I THINK THAT YOU NEED
TO HEAR FROM FACULTY OF COLOR OF
HOW TO RECRUIT FACULTY. AND ON
HOW TO ON RETAIN FACULTY AND.
MR MEDINA I'M IN LOVE WITH YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WHAT YOU SAID
DON'T TELL YOUR WIFE.
YOU.
I.
.
AT SYNDICATE STILL BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE'VE LONG
ADVOCATED FOR A DIVERSE FACULTY
POPULATION THAT REPRESENTS THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE WE
BELIEVE THIS IS CRITICAL AND
SHOULD BE A SYSTEM PRIORITY
HOWEVER. IN ORDER TO ALLOW AN
INFLUX OF DIVERSE CANDIDATES
THERE MUST BE ATTRACTIVE
POSITIONS AVAILABLE.
WHEN THE ENTRY POINT INTO OUR
SYSTEM IS A PART TIME ASSIGNMENT
WITH LITTLE JOB SECURITY AND
LITTLE PAY WILL FAIL TO RECRUIT.
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS FROM
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS.
WE MUST PAY SERIOUS ATTENTION TO
THIS ONE US ANY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
FULL TIME TO PART TIME FACULTY
RATIO. AND OUR CURRENT OVER
RELIANCE ON PART TIME FACULTY.
SACKING URGES THE MULTI YEAR
COMMITMENT TO DEDICATED FUNDING
FOR FULL TIME FACULTY HIRING AND
A DEGREE PIPELINE THROUGH THE
CSU THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS TO RETURN TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO TEACH.
LASTLY WE'RE IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THE HUNGER FREE CAMPUS PROGRAM
ENCOURAGE TENSION TO THESE VITAL
PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DINNER COMEY AT
PRESENT LUSTROUS FEDERATION
TEACHERS AND VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE. CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
THE THAT THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CAN BE COLLEGES.
JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW
WHEN A CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
SIXTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD. BUT OUR STATE HAS THE
GREATEST DEGREE OF POVERTY OF
ANY STATE IN THE NATION THEY
TELL YOU THAT THIS KIND OF
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
WITH FOOD INSECURITY.
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
ALSO A HOMELESSNESS AND MANY
OTHER SOCIAL ISSUES THAT
CONFRONT OUR STUDENTS IS GOING
TO REMAIN AND WE'RE BARELY
SCRATCHING THE SURFACE HERE.
THIS IS A GIGANTIC BARRIER TO
SINCE SUCCESS WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THIS VERY VERY SERIOUSLY HAVE
BEEN ADVOCATING THIS FOR MANY
MANY YEARS.
THE OTHER THING I LIKE TO SAY
ABOUT THE IN TERMS OF RETENTION
OF.
OF OUR OF OUR.
.
A THE BY MINORITY FACULTY A WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT YOU GET OF IT
NEXT MONTH AFTER MEMBER INTO OUR
SYSTEM.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT ALL THE
SUN IS ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE
TRYING TO GET TENURE WHEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO BECOME
SUCCESSFUL A TEACHERS. A IN TO
ME COLLEGES WHERE I TEACH.
THERE ON EVERY THEIR AT THEIR
OF MINORITY REPRESENTED ON EVERY
COMMITTEE POSSIBLE THAT THEY CAN
PLACE THEM ON THE OVER BURDEN
THEM TREMENDOUSLY. AND THAT
DOESN'T GIVE THEM OUT YOU KNOW A
FAIR CHANCE OF BECOMING THE KIND
OF FELT THE MEMBER THAT THAT
THEY WANT TO BE ALSO. THE WONDER
THEY'RE GONNA LOOK SOMEPLACE
ELSE SOMEPLACE BETTER WITHOUT
ARE NOT ON EVERY COMMITTEE
ACROSS THE CAMPUS EVERYDAY THANK
YOU.
HELLO AMY MINUTES WITH THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES
AND USE OF UNIVERSITIES OR
SUPPORTING YOU AND CONTINUED
FUNDS TO ALL OF THE SEGMENTS FOR
INCREASED FACULTY DIVERSITY. AND
HUNGER FREE CAMPUS EFFORTS THANK
YOU.
JEFF THOMAS RETURN MEMBERS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL THE BLIND.
WE ARE HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS THE
NEEDS OF THE BRAILLE AND TALKING
BOOK LIBRARY AND THE PEARL
INSTITUTE LIBRARY WHICH IS THE
PRIMARY. METHOD FOR PROVIDING
READING MATERIALS FOR MORE THAN
FORTY THOUSAND BLIND AND LOW
VISION INDIVIDUALS.
ESPECIALLY THOUSANDS OF SENIORS
SUFFERING REASON VISION LOSS.
ON ALL OF THESE INDIVIDUALS.
THE STATE HAS.
PROVIDES NO FUNDING FOR THE
BRAILLE INSTITUTE LIBRARY AND
ALTHOUGH IT USED TO PROVIDE A
HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE FUNDS FOR
THE BRAILLE AND TALKING BOOK
LAVERY TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO. IT
PROVIDES ALMOST NO FUNDING FOR
THE.
BRAYLON TALKING BOOK LIBRARY
TODAY.
MOREOVER IN THE LAST TWO TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION BUDGETS HAVE
ZEROED OUT THESE OF FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT ARE CURRENTLY USED TO
FUND THESE LIBRARIES. HOWEVER
UNFORTUNATELY THE FUNDING HAS
BEEN RETAINED. NONETHELESS NO
MATTER WHAT.
POLITICAL PARTY MIGHT BE IN
POWER THERE WILL BE CONTINUED
MOMENTUM TO ELIMINATE THESE
FUNDS.
IN THE YEARS TO COME WE NEED TO
BEGIN TO REINVEST IN OUR BRAYLON
TALKING BOOK LIBRARY IN OUR
ROOMS TO TO LIBRARY THAT SERVE.
THE ESTATES LINE BLIND AND LOW
VISION POPULATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD NEARLY AFTERNOON CHINA
MCCARTNEY MCCARTY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALTHEA
HEARTACHE I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
HISTORICAL SOCIETY. AND I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE STATE LIBRARY.
STATE LIBRARY IF IT'S LEADERSHIP
WITH PUBLIC LIBRARIES AROUND THE
STATE ARE KEY TO CREATING A MORE
JUST AND INFORM FUTURE. THUS WE
SUPPORT THE STATE LIBRARY'S
RESOURCE SHARING PROPOSAL
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY PROPOSAL
LIBRARY LITERACY SERVICES
AUGMENTATION AND THE EXPANSION
OF THE CURRENT ORAL HISTORY
PROGRAM.
AS YOUR STATE'S OFFICIAL
HISTORICAL SOCIETY AND NONPROFIT
PARTNER WITH THE STATE LIBRARY
WE ALSO HOPE TO COME BACK TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WITH THE
COLLABORATIVE REQUEST FOR
FUNDING. AND ARE WORKING WITH
MISTER TAME MISTER MARTIN MISTER
LUCAS AS WELL AS WITH DOCTOR
ADAMS AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND
WE'RE DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
PAST TWO YEARS OF FUNDING WE
RECEIVED. AS ALWAYS WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY. AND ITS RICH AND
COMPLICATED IMPORTANT HERITAGE
COULD CARE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JEAN
HEARST OP REPRESENTING THAT
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARIES. IN
PARTICULAR THE INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY PROPOSALS AND THE
LOTTERIES LITERACY SERVICES
AUGMENTATION THAT ARE VERY
CRITICAL TO OUR COMMUNITIES WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF THOSE
ITEMS.
HOWEVER ONE HELLO CHAIR MEDINA
MY NAME SHOULD GET TERRACE AND I
SERVE AS THE PRESIDENT TO THE
BY THINKING THE MANY MEMBERS I
HAVE SIGNED ONTO THE LETTER.
BEING CIRCULATED BY CHAIR MEDINA
TO SUPPORT THE FOOL YOU SEE YES
YES YOU FUNDING REQUESTS.
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR ARE
STRUGGLING TO STAY IN AN
INCREASINGLY EXPENSIVE SYSTEM
OFTEN SACRIFICING THEIR BASIC
NEEDS FOR THE SAKE OF A FOURTEEN
SCHOOL.
STATE MANDATED GROWTH IS MOVING
QUICKLY AND CAMPUS CLIMATE IS
WORSENING WHILE INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION SIMULTANEOUSLY
LACK FACULTY THAT LOOK LIKE THE
DEMOGRAPHICS. OF STUDENTS TODAY.
TODAY YOU'LL BE HEARING FROM
STUDENTS WERE EXPERIENCING
FIRSTHAND THE HARDSHIPS THAT
COME WITH THE HIGH COST OF
ATTENDANCE.
I ASK THAT YOU TAKE THEIR
EXPERIENCES INTO CONSIDERATION
WHEN MAKING YOUR DECISION.
THINKING.
THANK YOU.
BUT OFTEN RESPECT
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I I'M A FIRST
YEAR STUDENT FROM UC SANTA CRUZ
AND THAT MY NAME IS BIG NASH
HIGHER ON THE. LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FIRST INNING ASSEMBLY
AS WELL AS A BOARD MEMBER ON THE
SEASON ASSOCIATION.
I'M TIRED WE S. STUDENTS ARE
TIRED BECAUSE YOU KNOW THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING A LONG LIST
OF OTHER COMMITTEE HEARINGS
OTHER MEETINGS WITH YOU ALL THE
LEGISLATORS. OR THE UC
ADMINISTRATION HAPPENS ONE SMALL
PORTION OF THE SLEW OF
COMMITMENTS AS STUDENTS.
I I STUDENTS ABOUT TO MAKE IN
ORDER FOR SOMEONE.
TO HEAR US TO ALL THIS TROUBLE
THE ENERGY THE TIME PHYSICAL
EMOTIONAL LABOR WE PUT IN CO
EFFORT AND INITIATIVE ON OURS ON
OUR PART. BUT ALSO ARE DEEPLY
REFLECTIVE OF OUR STATE AYE
STUDENTS WITHIN A RIDICULOUSLY
UNDERFUNDED PUBLIC HIGHER AT
CYST.
SO I'M SURE ALL OF YOU HEARD
ABOUT THE STATISTICALLY
REPRESENTED TODAY I AM THE FORTY
FOUR PERCENT OF YOU SEE STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING LOW OR VERY LOW
FOOD SECURITY PUT SECURITY AT
SOME POINT OF TIME.
AT THE YOU SEE THAT THE ABYSMAL
LEVELS OF FACULTY DIVERSITY IN
OUR CAMPUSES BUT THE STATISTICS
ARE NATURALLY TIED AND ARE A
DIRECT MANIFESTATION OF STUDENTS
LIVED EXPERIENCES AND YOU'VE
HEARD THAT BOTH IN TODAY'S
HEARING.
AS WAS MENTIONED BY SOME
REMEMBER MEDINA AND IN EVERY
OTHER HEARING FROM US SO AGAIN
WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER MIDI
MEDINA SAID A SORT TO QUICKLY
TODAY.
DO CONTROL THE TUITION YOU
CONTROL THE FEES SO FUND US
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KELLY
MURDOCH AND I'M A SOPHOMORE AT
UC BERKELEY I'M SURE YOU'VE
HEARD A MILLION TIMES WHAT DO
YOU SEE BUDGETS ASK AS WE ARE
ASKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL ONE
FORTY MILLION. TO BUY OUT
TUITION INCREASES ADDRESSING
ROAMING GROWTH AND PAY FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
HE'S A VERY BROAD CATEGORY SO I
WANTED TO TELL YOU ALL WHAT THIS
MONEY WILL GO TOWARDS AYE YOU
SEE BERKELEY. WHILE FUNDING FOR
THE UC IS DECREASED OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS ENROLLMENT HAS
INCREASED MAKING IT HARDER FOR
STUDENTS TO GET THE CLASSES THEY
NEED TO GRADUATE ON TIME.
FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION WILL GO
TOWARDS EXPANDING COURSE
OFFERINGS FOR STUDENTS THREE
MILLION WILL GO TOWARDS BETTER
FUNDING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND ACADEMIC ADVISING SERVICES.
MANY STUDENTS HAVE TO WAIT WEEKS
TO MEET WITH A MENTAL HEALTH OR
ACADEMIC COUNSELOR AND
OFTENTIMES STUDENTS NEED THESE
APPOINTMENTS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
ONE MILLION WILL GO TOWARDS
FUNDING THE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION OF STUDENTS OF COLOR.
THE UC PRIDES ITSELF ON DIVERSE
CITY YET RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION CENTERS ARE STUDENT
RUN AND STUDENT FUNDED. THIS
PAST YEAR STUDENTS VOTED TO
INCREASE OUR OWN STUDENT FEES IN
ORDER TO PROPERLY FUND THE
CENTERS THIS IS THE JOB OF THE
UC NOT THE STUDENTS.
IF YOU DECIDE NOT TO INCREASE
INCREASED.
THIS WILL MAKE THE UC EVEN LESS
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE THAN
IT IS NOW SUPPORT STUDENTS
SUPPORT PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SUPPORT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. FUND THE UC THANK
YOU.
AND HAVE YOU IN MY NAMES IT IN
IS AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF ACT
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE DEMOCRATS AND
THAT STUDENTS WHO HAVE TO WORK
TWO JOBS THAT I STILL HAVE TO
THE CURRENT. SITES GET MALES.
SO RECENTLY CCD AT DROPPED THE
LETTER ASKING VERY PROMINENT
DEMOCRATS AND PRETTY MUCH
ANYBODY ELSE THAT'S GOING TO
SIGN ON TO SIGN ON AND SUPPORT
FUNDING THESE CIENCIAS YOU.
I WE HAD PEOPLE SUCH AS MULTIPLE
REGIONAL DIRECTORS AND.
AREA AND THAT THERE ARE SO WHO
IS THE VICE CHAIR THE DNC WHO
SIGNED ON. AND THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY RECENTLY ADDED LINGUISTS
ARE PLATFORM SAYING THAT WE
SHOULD BE INVESTING IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND I HOPE WE SEE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT HAPPEN THINK
IT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY
NAME IS AMIR RIGHT I'M A SECOND
YEAR STUDENT UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY.
FIRST I WANT START UP BY
THANKING THOSE OF YOU THAT
SIGNED THE LETTER IN SUPPORT OF
OUR FUNDING REQUEST. AND HERE TO
SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT FUNDING THE
UC.
LET ME START OFF BY SAYING I
DON'T ACTUALLY PAY TUITION I
RECEIVE THE MAXIMUM OUT OF
FINANCIALLY FOR THE GOVERNMENT.
SO THIS ISN'T FOR ME THIS IS
FROM MY PEERS
HERE'S THAT ATTEND UNIVERSITY
WHERE ONE OF EVERY FORTY
STUDENTS IS BLACK.
AND FOUR PERCENT OF STUDENTS
SYSTEM WHY ARE BLACK.
I CAN UNIVERSITY WHERE THREE
PERCENT OF FACULTY SYSTEM MIGHT
A BLACK YEAH EDUCATE.
FOR ME THIS BUDGET ASKING ME THE
FUNDING OF A NEW AND DIVERSE
POOL FACULTY.
THIS CAN MEAN THE FUNDING OF
RECRUITMENT RETENTION CENTERS
SYSTEMS THAT LOOK LIKE ME CAN
FEEL SUPPORTED WHEN THEY COME TO
YOU SEE.
THIS COULD MEAN THE FUNDING OF
BASING THE SECURITY PROGRAMS.
ALMOST HALF OF STUDENTS IN THE
YOU SEE HERE ARE FOOD INSECURE.
I WANT.
I GET CAL FRESH
BUT WHAT ABOUT THOSE THAT KNOW.
FOR THOSE FOR WHOM IT IS ENOUGH.
IN CLOSING LET ME SAY THE FILE.
I STUDY POLITICAL SCIENCE
I WANNA BE LIKE YOU ONE DAY.
BUT I CAN'T DO THAT IF I CAN
GRADUATE.
I CAN'T DO THAT IF I DROP OUT OF
SCHOOL BECAUSE I CAN'T PAY FOR.
I CAN'T DO THAT IF I CAN'T
SUCCEED BECAUSE OF FACULTY
WOULDN'T SUPPORT ME.
I CAN'T DO THAT IF MY GRADES
FELL BECAUSE I GO HUNGRY.
FINALLY.
ASK THE SUBCOMMITTEE REMEMBER
THAT BUDGETS ARE STATEMENTS OF
VALUES.
HOW MUCH DO YOU VALUE HIRED
HIGHER EDUCATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU CAN ASK YOU
IF YOU QUESTION YES FIRST OF ALL
WHAT YOU SEE DO YOU TO GO TO UC
BERKELEY OKAY? AND COULD I ASK
YOU QUESTIONS IS GOOD WE TALKED
US REALLY MEAN YOU CAN HELP
EDUCATED SO. YOU YOU SHOULD YOU
HAVE A CAO FRESH CARD YES YES
AND THEN CAN YOU WALK THROUGH.
HOW HOW DIFFICULT WAS IT TAKES
TWO TO GET THAT AND HAPPY
UTILIZED THAT YOU CAN?
SO FOR ME PERSONALLY WAS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO GET HOW
FRESH BECAUSE.
IT'S ITS A HEARTS ISN'T ACCESS
ESPECIALLY FOR STUDENTS ME SPENT
ALL DAY TRYING TO PLAY PHONE TAG
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND TRYING
TO GET YOUR POINT IN TRYING TO
GET THE CASE WORKER TO CALL YOU.
US THAT'S A COUPLE MONTHS IT WAS
ITS OWN IT CAMPUS OF HELP YOU OR
YOU GO TO THE COUNTY.
DEPARTMENT IT DEALS WITH HOW
FRESH SOMEONE CAMPUS RECOMMENDED
ME TO THE DEPARTMENT SO THERE'S
A THERE'S A SEPARATE SITE THAT
YOU CAN USE A SEPARATE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT WEBSITE.
THAT'LL HELP YOU THROUGH THE
PROCESS OKAY SO USE THAT I AND
MANY USING IT AND WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE ON CAMPUS FOR ME THERE'S
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE.
THE MARKETS ON CAMPUS THAT YOU
CAN USE THE COVERAGE CARD THAT I
AND I USED TO GET GROCERIES
EVERY MONTH.
SO DEATHLY HELPS WITH MY
BUT CAN YOU ACTUALLY YOU UTILIZE
IT AT THE.
.
AT THAT THE HOLFORD THAT THE
CAFETERIA NOT BUT IT WOULD HAVE
YOU KNOW WHAT I PROFIT NOT. NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INFORMATION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY MY NAME'S
HERSELF UNA AND I'M A FIRST YEAR
AT UC BERKELEY.
PERSONALLY EARNING ACCEPTANCE
AT UC BERKELEY I THOUGHT THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE WOULD BE THE
ACADEMIC RIGOR.
BUT INSTEAD TO MY SURPRISE IT'S
FIGHTING TO STAY IN THIS
INCREASINGLY EXPENSIVE SYSTEM BY
SACRIFICING BASIC NEEDS FOR LIKE
FOOD AND HOUSING SECURITY JUST
TO PAY FOR MY SCHOOL.
IT'S CHOOSING BETWEEN ADEQUATE
NUTRITION AND THE SEMESTERS
COURSE READERS IT'S STRUGGLING
TO BE ACTIVELY PRESENT ON AN
EMPTY STOMACH IT'S TRYING TO BE
ACADEMICALLY COMPETITIVE EVEN
WHEN. MY BODY IS STRUGGLING TO
KEEP UP WITH MY MIND.
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS WERE
ALREADY SUPPORTING OUR BUDGET
* AND HAVE PUBLICLY AFFIRMED
THE NEED FOR MORE INVESTMENT.
BUT WE ARE LOOKING TO THE REST
OF YOU OUR STATE LEGISLATORS TO
MAKE HIGHER EDUCATION TO PROVIDE
A PRIORITY IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
CYCLE AND SUPPORT OUR ONE
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET ASK. THINK.
HELLO I'M MY NAME IS ANNA
WHITNEY FROM OUT OF STATE
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY WHO WAS
RECENTLY ELECTED TO REPRESENT.
OUR STUDENT BODY IN OUR STUDENTS
SENATE.
I'M HERE TO URGE YOU TO FILL THE
UNIVERSITY. OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENT ASSOCIATIONS BUDGET
ASKS.
BY TWENTY TWENTY EMPLOYMENT
EXPERTS PREDICT THAT SIXTY FIVE
PERCENT OF JOBS WILL REQUIRE
POST HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION.
RIGHT NOW UNEMPLOYMENT IS TWICE
AS HIGH FOR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES THAN IT IS FOR PEOPLE
WITH COLLEGE DEGREES.
THE EARNING DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN
COLLEGE AND HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES HAS DOUBLED SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY.
IT IS CLEAR THAT A COLLEGE
DEGREE IS IN DEMAND IN OUR
ECONOMY AND AS A TOOL FOR
ECONOMIC COMPARTMENT.
SO WHO IS MOSTLY BENEFITING FROM
THESE DECREES EXPENSIVE DEGREES
PEOPLE WHO CAN PAY FOR THEM
PEOPLE WHO ARE TO COME FROM
WEALTH.
OUR HIGH TUITION HIRED SYSTEM
DOESN'T DO ENOUGH TO SERVE
MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES WHO DON'T
QUALIFY FOR AID. PEOPLE WHOSE
AID DOES NOT COVER THEIR LIVING
COSTS AND PEOPLE WHO DON'T
ENROLL TO BEGIN WITH BECAUSE
THEY'RE INTENDED BY THE PRICE.
WITH EACH TUITION HIKE OUR
SCHOOLS BECOME LESS DIVERSE LESS
EXCELLENT AND MUST JUST.
THERE'S NO SUBSTITUTION TO
REDUCING THE NET COST OF A
DEGREE OVERALL.
EVERY YEAR WERE CHOOSING TO
ENROLL MORE AND MORE PEOPLE.
BUT WE'RE NOT CHOOSING TO
INCREASE INVESTMENT AT THE RATE
AT WHICH WE ARE INCREASING
ENROLLMENT.
IF WE WANT EVERYONE TO BE READY
FOR TODAY'S ECONOMY AND FOR
TOMORROW'S ECONOMY WE CANNOT
CONTINUE WITH THIS
DISINVESTMENT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR TIME MY NAME IS TIMOTHY
EITHER I'M A FRESHMAN AT UC
BERKELEY. FOR A LOT OF FRESHMEN
LIKE ME TODAY IS PHASE ONE OF
CLASS REGISTRATION. BUT FRANKLY
CLASS REGISTRATION IS IN THE
MOST PRESSING HER IMPORTANT
THING. A LOT OF STUDENTS MINDS.
AS MY PEERS BEFORE ME HAVE
ATTESTED TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
ANDTHE OVERWHELMING BUDGET OF
TUITION OWED BURDEN OF TUITION
REQUIRE STUDENTS TO SACRIFICE
BASIC NEEDS.
TO KEEP ATTENDING SCHOOL
STUDENTS ARE WORRYING ABOUT HALF
TO FIND SOMETHING TO EAT OR A
PLACE TO SAY.
I DOUBT THEY'RE FOCUSING ON
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO FIT THAT MATH CLASSOF THE
NEED TO TAKE TO GRADUATE INTO
THEIR SCHEDULE FOR NEXT
SEMESTER.
IT'S DISHEARTENING THAT DURING
MY TIME AT THE FLAGSHIP
UNIVERSITY OF THE YOU SEE I'VE
SEEN SO MANY STUDENTS STRUGGLING
TO STAY AFLOAT AND THE
OVERWHELMING BURDEN OF TUITION
CERTAINLY. DOESN'T MAKE THOSE
WATERS CALMER.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE
TODAY-WHILE CLASS REGISTRATION
IS
OCCURRING AND WHILE FINALS ARE
APPROACHING WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS.
WOULD AGAIN LIKE TO THANK ALL
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S TO THE BILL
OF THE LEGISLATORS WHO HAVE.
SUPPORTED I ASK FOR ONE HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS BUT. TO
THOSE WHO HAVEN'T
YOU'VE HEARD THE STATISTICS
OU'RE CONTINUING TO HEAR OUR
STORIES WE NEED SUFFICIENT
FUNDING FOR THE UC SYSTEM THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ON MEN COME FROM.
I SAID IN A UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SANTA CRUZ AND. OUT
ALONG BELABORED POINT.
Y'ALL HEARD A STATISTIC YA
HEARD AUG TESTIMONY FROM ALL
STUDENT. I THINK IS COMMON SENSE
THAT THE MORE RESOURCE YOU GUYS
PUT INTO SCHOOL ENSURING DUSTIN
ON HUNGRY DETAILING. STARTING IN
A GOOD ENVIRONMENT NATURALLY
WILL GIVE GIVE THAT RESULT.
AND I'M IMPLORE ALICE LATER TO
DO THE RIGHT THING AND TO HAVE
PROBABLY FUND.
YOU SEE AND NOT PUT A FINANCIAL
BURDEN.
THAT COST BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ON JUST THAT THANK YOU.
HELLO JARED KELLER ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR INFRASTRUCTURE THE
SACRAMENTO PUBLIC LIBRARY AND
TODAY I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF CONTINUED FUNDING FOR
A CALIFORNIA PUBLIC LIBRARIES TO
AYE REMAIN CONNECTED TO SCENIC.
SCENIC HAS BEEN A GAME CHANGER
FOR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC LIBRARIES
AND ESPECIALLY THE SACRAMENTO
PUBLIC LIBRARY. PARTY CONNECTED
TO SCENIC WE LABOR TO PRY
CONNECTIVITY TAR TWENTY EIGHT
LOCATION.
AS A RESULT OF CONNECTING TO
SCENIC WE'RE NOW ABLE WHEAT AS
OF TODAY WE PROVIDE GIGABIT
CONNECTIVITY TO TWENTY TWO OUT
OF TWENTY LOCATIONS WILL BE
CONNECTING THE REMAINING SIX.
NEXT FISCAL YEAR WITH THIS IS
DONE FOR US IS IT'S BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE US UNLIMITED ACCESS. IN
COMMUNITIES WHERE IT'S
DEFINITELY NEEDED IT'S ALSO
GIVEN US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RETHINK PROGRAMMING. AND THINK
ABOUT PROGRAM IN TERMS OF TO BE
STRAINED SO NOW WE ARE ABLE TO
HELP BRIDGE DISTANCE AND BRIDGE
GAPS BY CREATING DYNAMIC
PROGRAMMING TO HELP ON KIDS
PROGRAM. HOW TO LEARN TO THREE
D. MODEL ANTI THIS BASICALLY
ANYWHERE THAT THEY CAN HAVE AN
ACTIVITY IN ONE OF OUR BRANCHES
SO THIS IS ABOUT TRANSFORM
LIBRARY SERVICES? AND PROVIDED
MUCH NEEDED CONNECTIVITY IN MANY
OF OUR COMMUNITY IS THAT DEAN
AND NOT HAVE IT BECAUSE OUR
LIBRARY IS THE ONLY LOCATION
WHERE THEY EXIST.
SO I ENCOURAGE YOU TO PLEASE
CONTINUE FUNDING FOR A VARIABLE
VALUABLE PROJECT THANK YOU.
HELLO.
THANK YOU I'M REFC ASSASSIN THE
DIRECTOR OF THE SACRAMENTO
PUBLIC LIBRARY AND I'M HERE TO.
BOTH SUPPORT THE.
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR THE STATE
LIBRARY AS WELL AS TO ECHO
JARRETT'S THOUGHTS ON WHAT
SCENIC HAS MEANT FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AS YOU KNOW WE ARE.
AN URBAN RURAL AND SUBURBAN
LIBRARY SYSTEM.
SCENIC HAS MADE A TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE.
CHIU EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO DO FOR OUR COMMUNITY. THE
OTHER PIECE OF THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE ABLE TO DO THROUGH OUR
ADULT LITERACY PROGRAM.
EXPANDED SUPPORT FOR LITERACY
PROGRAMS
TO THE STATE LIBRARY WILL IMPACT
OUR ABILITY TO REACH THE VERY
YOUNGEST OF OUR RESIDENTS
THROUGH OUR EARLY LITERACY
EFFORTS.
AS WELL AS THE ADULTS THAT WE
SERVE THROUGH OUR BASIC LITERACY
GED PREP ESL PROGRAMS AND CAREER
ONLINE HIGH SCHOOL.
ABOUT NINETY PERCENT OF OUR
CAREER ONLINE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES GO ON TO HIGHER
EDUCATION IT'S A WONDERFUL
SAFETY NET THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
EXPERIENCE THROUGH THEIR LOCAL
LIBRARY. WHICH HAS.
WHICH IS A LITTLE LESS ATTEMPT
INTIMIDATING THEN THROUGH MORE
TRADITIONAL MEANS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR OAK
AFTERNOON WENT CHAIR MCCARTY AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS A. MY NAME IS
AMY HEINZ SHAIKEN I AM THE
HIGHER EDUCATION DIRECTOR FOR
THE RE CLAIMS CA HIGHER
EDUCATION COALITION. A REGARDING
THE SUBJECT OF FACULTY
DIVERSITY.
WE STRONGLY ECHO THE.
SENTIMENTS OF FACT IN
MAINTAINING AT NOTATION ON THE
SEVENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE FULL
TIME TO PART TIME RATIO. AND
ALSO CONSIDERING HIRING THE NON
TENURED FACULTY INTO TENDERED
POSITIONS THE NON TENURED
FACULTY TENDS TO BE MORE DIVERSE
AND IT WOULD BE A VERY IMPORTANT
MOVEMENT IF WE COULD FIND SOME
PATHWAYS TO MOVE THE NON TENURED
FACULTY INTO LETTER RATE FACULTY
POSITIONS.
ALSO THE REKLAME CA HIGHER
EDUCATION COALITION HAS A POLICY
POSITION PAPER THAT MOST OF YOU
HAVE SEEN.
ITS TITLE THE SIXTY SIX DOLLARS
PICKS UP RENAMED AFTER THE FORTY
EIGHT HOUR FIX ALSO INCLUDED THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEES
AND.
IN THIS PAPER SHOULD WE CHOOSE
TO USE THIS FUNDING MECHANISM TO
DEFRAY TUITION AND FEES ALSO IT
ALLOWS US TO FREEZE THAT STUDENT
AID COMMISSIONS BUDGET THEREBY
ADDING TWO BILLION DOLLARS
APPROXIMATELY FOR THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION. TO NOT HAVE TO
DEFRAY TUITION AND FEES AND
INSTEAD TO GO TOWARD SURVIVAL
COSTS THINK YOU.
CAN LUIS REPRESENTING SCENIC
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE ENTIRE
LIBRARY PROJECT PACKAGE BEFORE
YOU AND I THINK PART IN A
FINANCE IN THE STATE LABOR FOR
WORKING WITH US THIS FALL IN THE
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION. TO PUT
TOGETHER THE WHOLE THING THAT'S
IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY TO REALLY
CONTINUE THE WORK OF BRINGING
TWENTY LIBRARIES AND TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. TODAY WE ARE ON
TRACK TOHAVE A HUNDRED FORTY
FUTURE STICTION THAT OF THE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE. AND
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
BRANCHES OUT OF THE ONE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE BRANCHES
TO BE CONNECTED ON PROCESS OF
CONNECTING. TO SEEN ACT AND IT'S
BEEN REALLY TRANSFORMATIVE AS
TESTIFIED FROM THE SEGMENT A
PUBLIC LIBRARY EARLIER TODAY AND
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS PACKAGE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANGIE
CHEN AND I'M A SECOND YEAR
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY I'M HERE
TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE EASY
BUDGET ASK OF A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION ADDITIONAL FUNDING. AYE
THOSE YOU GET THE UC BERKELEY
FOOD PANTRY LAST SEMESTER AND I
GOT TO INTERACT WITH THE FORTY
TWO PERCENT OF STUDENTS WHO IT
SO WE EXPERIENCE WITH
INSECURITY.
THE STUDENTS ARE TRANSFER
STUDENTS THEY ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR THEY ARE FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND THEIR
STUDENT PARENTS THESE OTHER
PEOPLE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY BASIC NEEDS AND
SECURITY. WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
THEM PARTS OF CAMPUS DIVERSITY
BUT WHAT'S REALLY CRUCIAL IS
ACTUALLY FUNDING ADVERSITY AND
THIS INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
INITIATIVES SUCH AS THE HUNGER
FREAKS CAMPUS PROGRAM SO THAT
STUDENTS FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS
CAN FOCUS ON GETTING THE DEGREE.
RATHER THAN WORRYING ABOUT
WHETHER GOING TO GET THEIR NEXT
MEAL FROM.
FOOD SECURITY IN EFFORTS MUST BE
EXPANDED AND KOREANS WITH IT
WILL INCREASES.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
EDUCATES NINE THOUSAND MORE
STUDENTS THAN IT DID IN THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND THE STATE FUNDING
HAS REMAINED THE SAME. AND THIS
DOESN'T JUSTIFY STUDENTS BASIC
NEEDS INSUFFICIENT FUNDS ALSO
IMPACT COURSE AVAILABILITY
BECAUSE AVAILABILITY STUDENT TO
FACULTY RATIO ON THE QUALITY OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
SO IF STATE INVESTMENT HIGHER
EDUCATION IS INADEQUATE THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN FALLS ON
STUDENTS AND WE CAN'T AFFORD
THAT PLEASE WORK WITH US TO
FULLY FUND THE UC THINKING.
HELLO EVERYONE THAT YOU SO MUCH
FOR STAYING TO HEAR ALL THE
PUBLIC COMMENTARY MILLION IS A
LOT THAT YOU ALL MAY TIME TO
HEAR US. NOMINEE MUST GUY ALLEN
AND A GRADUATING SENIOR AT
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE.
I WANT TO TALK TODAY A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE DISPARITY BETWEEN
THE STUDENT AND FACULTY IN TERMS
OF DIVERSITY. SO USE YOUR PAGES
ALL THE TIME FOR BEING THE MOST
DIVERSE YOU SEE AND WE ARE IN
TERMS OF STUDENTS. NEARLY NINETY
PERCENT OF STUDENTS AT OUR
SCHOOL ARE NOT DO NOT IDENTIFY
AS WHITE BUT NEARLY EIGHTY
PERCENT OF THE FACULTY TO YOU.
SO THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITY IN GRANTED THE FACULTY
MEMBERS COME FROM. THE TWENTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOURTEEN SCHOOL
YEAR I KNOW THERE'S BEEN PUSHES
TO HAVE MORE DIVERSITY. BUT THAT
THAT THE US IS THE DISPARITY
THAT GREAT DOES NOT GO AWAY
WITHIN FOUR YEARS. I'VE BEEN IN
ADDITION TO PROFESSORS I WANT
ALSO CALL ATTENTION TO THE OTHER
FACULTY ON CAMPUS THAT COULD
IMPACT SO IN TERMS OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
IF TACKLE IF PROFESSORS DON'T
EVEN REPRESENT THE STUDENT HOW
CAN I MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
REFLECT THOSE STUDENTS AND IF
THOSE SERVICES DON'T REFLECT THE
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF A
COMFORTABLE COMING UP TO THINK
THAT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING. SOME
YOU HAVE THINGS THAT THIS OF YOU
HAVE SITUATIONS OF THAT GREAT OF
A DISPARITY YOU HAVE THINGS FOR
STUDENTS ARE FEELING TOKEN DOWN
THERE SOME OTHER SUPPOSED FILM
POWER YOU HAVE THINGS WHERE.
STUDENTS ARE FEELING LIKE THEY
HAVE THIS IMPOSTOR SYNDROME
BECAUSE THEY FEEL LIKE THE THE
FIRST TO BE EMPOWERED IN THIS
PLACE TO GET A HIGHER EDUCATION
TO. TO PURSUE BETTER THINGS FOR
THEMSELVES AND FOR THEIR FUTURE
BUT THEY DON'T FEEL SUPPORTED BY
THIS THE SYSTEM THAT'S POSTED
EMPOWERING THEM. SO I REALLY
HOPE THAT WE CAN THINK ABOUT
THESE THINGS IN THE GRAND SCHEME
OF THINGS BECAUSE YOU KNOW LIKE
ISN'T UP FOR SCHOOL AND VICE
VERSA. SO I STUDENTS ARE GOING
THROUGH SCHOOL UNDER DEALING
WITH THE THINGS LIKE FOOD
INSECURITY LIKE AND ACCESSIBLE
HOUSING LIKE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THERE ALSO DEALING WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. AND ALL OF THESE
THINGS ON TOP OF EACH OTHER IN
ADDITION TO HOW EXPENSIVE
COLLEGES NOT HAVING THE SUPPORT.
OF FACULTY BY THE PROFESSORS OR
COUNSELORS OR OTHER THINGS LIKE
THAT THAT REFLECT THEM I CAN
EMPATHIZE THEM TO THE UNDERSTAND
THE LINGUISTIC BARRIERS AND THE
CULTURAL BARRIERS AND ETHNICITY
THINGS. ALL OF THOSE THINGS
MATTER AND ALL THOSE THINGS
SHOULD HAVE A PART IN THIS
CONVERSATIONS OF THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND THANK YOU
FOR STAYING IN THE COUNTRY.
SORRY ARM. MY NAME IS TOUGH CON
I'M A SOPHOMORE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF.
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY.
FROM AN EARLY AGE WE ARE TAUGHT
THAT LIKE. WE NEED TO PURSUE A
COLLEGE DEGREE IN SCHOOL. BUT
ONCE WE GET HERE OF WE PUMMELED
BY HUGE DEBTS AND.
I LIKE HIGH TUITION FEES.
I PERSON WILL COME OUT WITH
ALMOST. THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN LOANS.
I THAT IN STATE STUDENT AT THE
END OF MY TIME AT THAT BERKELEY.
IT'LL BE COULD BE MORE END OF
DEPENDING ON THE CUTS.
.
BOB IN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
LIKE RUBIN SAID TODAY OUR
STUDENTS HAVE TO WORK HARDER AND
GO OUT STRUGGLE MORE.
TO GET THROUGH A.
THEIR TIME AT SCHOOL.
ARE THE LACK OF AFFORDABILITY OF
OBTAINING A COLLEGE DEGREE AND
THEN INEFFICIENT.
RESOURCES AT THESE.
CONTUSIONS.
BOB ALONGSIDE WITH HUGE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
MAKES IT MAKES IT.
HARDER FOR STUDENTS TO GET
THROUGH COLLEGE
I URGE YOU TO MAKE HIRED AT A.
PRIORITY IN THIS BUDGET CYCLE
AND SUPPORT OUR. ONE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS BUT BUDGET
ASK THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
IF YOU.
HI EVERYONE MY NAME IS A DAVID
LYNCH FILM WITH THEIR YOUR UC
RIVERSIDE.
WITH THE CONTINUE DISINVESTMENT
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
WITH THE CCC CSU AND YOU SEE
MORE AND MORE OF THE BURDEN COST
OF EDUCATIONAL FONG STUDENTS
SOME CREAMER FINANCIAL HARDSHIP.
AS IT STANDS FOOD INSECURITY IS
ARAMBULA YOU SEE US CAMPUS IS
WELL AS OTHER UC CAMPUSES.
I MUST OFFERED HAVE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE.
OF NOT EXPERIENCE X.
EXPERIENCING EXTREME FOOD
INSECURITY. BUT I'M HERE BECAUSE
I WILL NOT STAY SILENT WHILE
OTHER MY PEERS BACK IN RIVERSIDE
ANOTHER UC CAMPUSES. A GO
HUNGRY.
ON THE TOPIC OF FACULTY MINORITY
REPRESENTATION I HAVE PERSONALLY
HAD POSITIVE EXPERIENCES WITH
THE LATINO LATINA.
FACULTY ARE YOU SEE ARE WHO HAVE
HELPED ME LEARN NEW SKILLS AND
GROW THE STUDENT.
MANY OF MY PEERS FROM OTHER
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS THE BLACK
COMMUNITY BY MIDDLE EASTERN ASIA
PACIFIC ISLAND HAVE ALSO.
EXPRESSED HOW BIG OF A
DIFFERENCE HAVING THIS FACULTY
THE REPRESENT YOURSELF AS MEAD
IN THEIR EDUCATION.
A I THINK THOSE ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT SUPPORTER
WONDERED IF FORTY MILLION BUDGET
OUTSIDE AUTHORITY BEEN.
BROKEN DOWN MANY TIMES.
.
AND I'M ASKING THOSE WHO DO NOT
SUPPORT ALREADY TO RECONSIDER
THIS FUNDING WILL ENSURE THAT
FOOD INSECURITY FOR PRESENTATION
OF FACULTY AND MANY MORE ISSUES
WILL BE ADDRESSED AT THE UC.
I ALSO HOPE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT OR THE SUPER
FUNDING THE YOU SEE IT BUT ALSO
THE CCC NCSU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GREATER.
TIME A NAME IS EMILY AYE
MISTAKING AYE YOU SEE ARE EMPIRE
PRICE CALIFORNIA. I TEND WITH
THEM WHEN I TO ONE OF THE MOST
DIVERSE UC'S GET OUR FACULTY
FACULTY DESERVE LIKE THAT WAS IT
IS WALKING CAMPUS DAYS SHOULD BE
SURROUNDED BY FACULTY TO
UNDERSTAND THE EXPERIENCE OF
STUDENTS OF COLOR. MOVING
FORWARD I ALSO WANT TO TALK
ABOUT PUTTING SECURITY MOST
CAMPUSES HAVE FOOD PANTRIES AND
THAT'S GREAT BUT WE NEED TO DO
MORE. I PERSONALLY KNOW STUDENTS
WHO HAVE TO DECIDE BETWEEN
TEXTBOOKS OR FOOD EVER IN A
COURT OF SYSTEM IS SUCKS BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO MAKE THAT CHOICE
THREE TIMES. USUALLY THE FIRST
TWO WEEKS OF EACH CORNER ARE THE
WORST.
MY FIRST YEAR AT THE SUCH
STRUGGLE EITHER I. GOOD MONEY
FOR GROCERIES OR I GOT MY BOOKS.
I USUALLY NEVER BOUGHT THE BOOKS
WHICH OF COURSE AFFECTED MY
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE BECAUSE NOT
EVERY PROFESSOR PUT THE BOOK ON
RESERVE.
AND.
I JUST I YOU KNOW IF IT IS
SECURITY AFFECTS STUDENTS DAILY
LIVES TO MIX GRADUATION SEEM
IMPOSSIBLE.
SOME BECAUSE OF THIS AND BECAUSE
THE STORIES OF EVERY OTHER
STUDENT I HOPE THAT. YOU SUPPORT
UC'S BUDGET REQUEST THINK YOU.
BOB.
THANK YOU OUR MONEY WAS JONATHAN
THE FROM BUT MADERA GIVE
STUDENTS ARE YOU SEE WEBSITE
CURLY SERVING AS THE
UNDERGRADUATES DO REPRESENTATIVE
AT THE UC BOARD OF MISSIONS AND
RELATIONS WITH SCHOOLS.
A MANY CAMPUSES ARE OVER ROLLING
I DO YOU SEE THAT WITH THE DOES
AND YOU KNOW. WITHOUT WHILE MANY
OF THE SPECIAL STUDENT SERVICES
OFFICE JUST FOOD PANTRY AND
HOUSING SERVICES ARE IMPACTED
AND ASSIST AND UNSUSTAINABLE.
DUE TO LACK OF FUNDING.
AND IN ADDITION WE HAVE COSTS
AND THE ARE TO TEARING AT
ALARMING RATES I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW FOOD OFTEN SECURITY AND
THAT'S HOW IT'S ALSO. A BIG
TOPIC BY THE ONE YOU WANT TO
COVER SOME OF THE TOPICS THAT
MAY NOT BE COVERED YOU KNOW
SUGGESTED HEARING COSTUMES. YOU
KNOW UP RIVERSIDE PERHAPS EVEN
OTHER CAPS AS WELL YOU KNOW
HAVE SEEN STUDENTS FORCED TO SIT
ON THE FLOOR. ARE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW CHAIRS AND THAT'S ARE
BROKEN THERE'S NOT ENOUGH AND
SOME OF THE SEATS IF POSSIBLY
YOU KNOW MR MEDINA PUBLISHED ON
THE BEFORE AND THESE ARE
DECEASED OUT YOU KNOW STILL
THERE.
NOW I DO WANT TO POINT OUT IS
CHIU BECAUSE THIS IS THE CHARITY
AND NOTHING'S BEING FAKES.
IT'S PAST PRACTICALLY FABRICS
AND WHAT TOGETHER AT THIS POINT.
AND YOU KNOW FOR ONE I WAS ONE
OF THE STUDENTS OUTSIDE ON THE
FLOOR FOR AN HOUR AND A HALF
TRYING TO LEARN ABOUT PAY
TUITION WITHOUT SUPPOSED TO
GIVE.
SUPPOSED TO BE A PROPERTY IN
THE CAR THINKING.
THANK YOU.
AND JUST TO REMIND WE'RE KIND OF
RUNNING ON TIME SO PLEASE
REMEMBER SIXTY SECONDS THINGS
ICE YEAH CONDUCTING AND IT IS
THE AW AYE ROGER ROBINSON A
GRADUATING SENIOR AT UC
BERKELEY.
ALL GOES WELL NEXT WEEK DURING
FINALS WILL HAVE A DIPLOMA ON
THE TWELVE SOME NOT HEAR FROM ME
BUT I AM HERE FOR MY FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO WANT TO APPLY FOR
THE UC AND FOR THE KIDS OF
BERKELEY WHO LIVE IN THE SHADOW
OF YOUR.
IT'S THE THAT THEY FEAR THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO AFFORD BEING A
FOURTH YEAR HERE MEANS I'VE BEEN
AROUND FOR A LITTLE WHILE AND
I'VE SEEN HOW THIS ACT GOES
THOSE THERE AND AROUND MY
FRESHMAN YEAR. WHEN THE UC
REGENTS VOTED TO INCREASE
TUITION THEN WAITED FOR THE
STATE TO BUY IT OUT NOSE AROUND
LAST YEAR WHEN THE UC REGENTS
VOTED TO INCREASE TUITION AGAIN
BUT THIS YEAR I AM CONVINCED
THAT THINGS ARE DIFFERENT I WAS
THERE IN JANUARY WHEN FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN. LIVING MEMORY THE
REGION'S DECIDE NOT TO EVEN PUT
IT ON THE TABLE AND PUT ALL
THEIR EGGS IN YOUR BASKET TO
COME TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
DEMAND MORE FUNDING TO REVERSE
TRENDS AND DISINVESTMENT.
AND IT HAPPENED FOR THE SECOND
TIME IN RECENT MEMORY JUST A
WEEK OR TWO AGO WHEN THE
REGION'S AND ANNOUNCED AGAIN
THAT THEY'LL BE TAKING THE VOTE.
OFF THE TABLE AND MAY BECAUSE WE
HAVE FAITH IN YOU THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. TO DO THE RIGHT
THING TO REVERSE THESE TRENDS OF
DISINVESTMENT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING AND IF
THIS IS THE YEAR TO CHANGE THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING DIFFICULT
CHALLENGING BUT PRODUCTIVE
MEETINGS WITH PEOPLE LIKE MARK.
JACK HER FRIENDS FROM DEAL OUT
OF TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GOING
ABOUT THIS THE RIGHT WAY WE KNOW
THE IMPLICATIONS AND I AM MORE
CONFIDENCE NOW THAN I HAVE BEEN
AT ANY POINT IN THIS PROCESS
THERE BUDGET ASKS.
ARE NECESSARY AND YOU WILL PULL
THROUGH ON THEM THERE'S A REASON
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY LEADERSHIP
HAS STOOD BEHIND THESE I ASKED
SO FIRMLY SO I ASK YOU DO THE
SAME. THANK YOU.
WOULDN'T.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AN
INQUIRY AND I'M CURRENTLY A
FIRST YEAR UC RIVERSIDE BEFORE I
BEGIN SPEAKING ABOUT YOU SEE
SYSTEMATIC ISSUES A LARGE. I
WANT TO DIVE DEEPER INTO MY
EXPERIENCE OF NAVIGATING THROUGH
TO KEEP KID THROW QUE TO TWELVE
SYSTEM ARM AS A FIRST GENERATION
LOW INCOME STUDENT WHERE ELECT
TO EDUCATE ME ON UNIVERSITY
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS. FINANCIAL
BUDGET MANAGEMENT EXETER UP ALL
TOO OFTEN THE UNIVERSITY LET'S
TOKENIZED YOU KNOW DIVERSITY AND
IT BEING YOU KNOW LARGELY. GONE
STOOD OF COLOR BASED BUT YET IF
THOSE TWO ON FINANCIALLY PROVIDE
THE RESOURCES FOR US TO PROSPER
ALL TOO OFTEN THE SYSTEMS LONG
SPECIFICALLY THE UC SYSTEM.
LIKES TO.
.
USE OUR USER NECESSITIES AND
TURN THEM INTO LUXURIES ARM AND
ALL I ASK IS THAT YOU MAKE A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION BUDGET AS
A PRIORITY FOR THE SAKE OF
STUDENT PROSPERITY ACROSS THE
SYSTEM THING YOU.
Q. FIRST AND YOU'RE LISTENING TO
PUBLIC COMMENT OUT MY NAME IS
FARIS I MEAN YOU SEE BERKELEY
JUNIOR.
STUDYING POLITICAL SCIENCE
I'M HERE TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCE
AT UC BERKELEY AND I HAVE A FEW
NUMBERS THAT I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU. UP FORTY TWO PERCENT
OF UC BERKELEY CA YOU SEE
STUDENTS ARE FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS I'M ONE OF THEM THIRTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF STUDENTS
QUALIFY FOR PROGRAMS I'M ONE OF
THEM. TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT
TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT OF YOU SEE
TRENDS YOU SEE STUDENT
TRANSCRIPT COMMUNITY I'M PROUD
TO SAY THAT I'M ONE OF THEM SO
WHEN WE SAY THAT UC'S OUR DRIVER
OF SOCIAL MOOD. MOBILITY IN
CALIFORNIA WE TRULY MEAN THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY MISTER FELTING
WAS NOT HERE BUT I HOPE HE IS
AWARE THAT THE SAN FRANCISCO
DEMOCRAT DEMOCRATIC PARTY PASSED
A RESOLUTE A RESOLUTION.
SUPPORTING FULLY FUNDING AT THE
U. SEASONS YES USE.
AND I. I WAS THERE ADVOCATING.
FOR THIS I RESOLUTION.
AND I'M GLAD THAT I DID BUT I
REALLY HOPE THAT YOU.
WE FULLY FUND YOU GUYS FULLY
FUND THE YOU SEE SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY GO FOCUS ON ACADEMICS
THANK YOU.
AND.
HI MY NAME IS NEIL MCCLINTIC
IMAGING YOUR TRANSIT FROM UC
BERKELEY I CAME FROM DE ANZA
COLLEGE ON SO I'VE BEEN HERE A
FEW TIMES I KNOW. EVIL KIND OF
LISTEN TO THE SAME SORT OF
NARRATIVES AND YOU'VE HEARD ALL
OF OUR TALKING POINTS
I AND SO I DID WANT TO COME TO
BRING UP SOMETHING THAT HASN'T
BEEN BROUGHT UP YET. WHICH IS
THE FACT THAT WE CONSTANTLY HEAR
THAT THE UC SHOULDN'T SHOULDN'T
BE ADEQUATELY FUNDED BECAUSE
THERE IS ADMINISTRATIVE WASTE
BECAUSE YOU CO P. ISN'T USING
FINDS THE WAY IT SHOULD.
THERE'S NO DOUBT BEEN A
CONCERNING WAYS TO FUNDS COMING
OUT OF YOU CO PI THINK WE SAW
THAT FROM THE AUDIT.
HOWEVER THE REALITY IS THAT IT'S
TIME TO STOP PLAYING HOT POTATO
WHILE CAMPUS IS LIKE UC BERKELEY
ARE LITERALLY FALLING APART.
THE RECENT CHANGE IN THE UC
REGENTS MENTALITY OF NOT EVEN
CONSIDERING TUITION HIKES THIS
COMING MAY IS IMPAIRED IF I IT'S
A POINT OF CAPITALIZATION.
IT SHOULD BE SEEN AS A HISTORIC
MOMENT IT'S WHERE FOLKS WILL BE
ABLE TO LOOK BACK AND SEE THE
UNPRECEDENTED EFFORTS OF
STUDENTS TO GIVE BACK TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
BUT IT WILL ONLY TRULY BE WORTH
CELEBRATING IF ALL OF YOU CAN DO
YOUR PART ENSURING OUR EFFORTS
COME TO FRUITION.
INSIDE DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE HOW
PIVOTAL THIS MOMENT IS IT REALLY
IS KEY AND SO FUNNY YOU SEE
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CRISTINA CARO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PACKAGE OF NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LIBRARY
PROGRAMS.
THIS WAS ARTFULLY CRAFTED AT
THAT A DIRECTION OF THE DOOR THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE UP WITH
SCENIC THE CALIFORNIA LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION AND THE STATE
LIBRARIAN WE THINK IT'S A SMALL
AMOUNT OF MONEY BUT IT WILL DO A
TREMENDOUS GOOD. PARTICULARLY
THE CONNECTIVITY OF THE LIBRARY
BRANCHES WE HAVE CONNECTED NOW
pLIBRARIES SINCE ONLY FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN AND THAT'S REALLY.
A DUE TO A LOT OF HELP FROM HIS
A SUBCOMMITTEE FRANKLY SO WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU AGAIN HOPE YOU
LOOK FAVORABLY UPON THIS. AND
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
AND THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE FOR
THEIR HELP AND WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO JUST.
I SHARE THAT WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THE ITEM THAT WAS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY REGARDING THE LIBRARY
FOR THE BLIND THANK YOU.
HELLO MEMBERS MY NAME IS XENA
ALPERTON I'M A JUNIOR AT UC
BERKELEY WANT TO DIVE RIGHT INTO
MY NARRATIVE I'VE BEEN A
RESIDENT ASSISTANT IN THE UC
BERKELEY DORMS FOR TWO YEARS
NOW.
AND I'VE WASTED WITNESS THE
CONSISTENT TIME AND TIME AGAIN
STRUGGLES OF MY RESIDENTS TO FOR
TALKS.
SEARCH FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND AFFORD FOOD WITH ARE
INSUFFICIENT MEAL PLANS THAT
BARELY ALLOW FOR TWO MEALS A
DAY.
THE STRUGGLES THAT MY RESIDENCE
FEES ARE NOT EXCLUSIVE TO THEM
THEIR REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
STUDENT BODY AS A WHOLE. I
MYSELF WORKED THREE JOBS ON TOP
OF A FULL ACADEMIC LOAD JUST
THAT I CAN AFFORD TO ATTEND UC
BERKELEY.
AN INCREASE FUNDING WON'T JUST
IMPROVE TUITION AFFORDABILITY IT
WOULD ALSO HELP WITH
STRENGTHENING OUR FOOD PANTRY.
FIXING OUR BROKEN INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ADDING RESOURCES TORE FAULTY
FINANCIAL AID OFFICE WHICH OFTEN
TAKES AN ENTIRE SEMESTER TO
DELIVER CRUCIAL A TO OUR
STUDENTS.
WE MUST KEEP COLLEGE ATTAINABLE
AND AFFORDABLE FOR STUDENTS LIKE
ME WHO HAVE DONE OUR PART AND
PUT IN THE WORK TO PREPARE FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION AND OUR CAREERS
AHEAD.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
WHILE YOU THE LEGISLATORS ARE
DETERMINING WHETHER THIS IS
FEASIBLE AND WHILE THE LEG
BICU LEGISLATORS ARE GOING
BACK AND FORTH A FEW COP IN THE
UC REGENTS ABOUT WHO'S SUPPOSED
TO DO WHAT.
UNDERNEATH ALL OF YOU ARE THE
STUDENTS.
SUFFERING.
PLEASE SUPPORT OUR BUDGET ASK
EMPLOYEES FROM THE UC THANK YOU.
HELLO I MY NAME IS SARAH TO SHY
AND I'M A SECOND YEAR STUDENT AT
UC BERKELEY AND I'M HAPPY TO
MISS MY FINAL REVIEW SESSIONS TO
ONCE AGAIN I URGE YOU TO FUND
THE YOU SEE.
TO WRAP UP WHAT IS OR EVEN SAID
WE ARE ASKING FOR A HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE TO
THE GOVERNMENT'S PROPOSED
BUDGET.
THIS NUMBER IS NOT ARBITRARY
I'M IS THE RESULT OF MONTHS OF
RESEARCH NEGOTIATION AS WELL AS
YEARS OF STATE DISINVESTMENT
TUITION INCREASES AS ALSO
SEMESTER FULL OF WEEKLY TRIPS TO
SACRAMENTO WHICH INCLUDES A
COUPLE HUNDRED DOLLARS WORTH. OF
CARSHARE EXPENSES A MORE FUNDING
IS NOT A SERIES FOR EXPANDING
COURSE OFFERINGS IT IS NECESSARY
TO ENSURE STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS
TO SUPPORT SERVICES I'M SUCH AS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACADEMIC
ADVISING. IS NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT BASIC NEED SECURITY AS
WELL AS OUR CRIMINAL AND
RETENTION OF MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS TO
IMPROVE OUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
YEAR OLD INFRASTRUCTURE. I'M I'M
REALLY TIRED OF MAKING THESE
TRIPS UP HERE TO BEG YOU TO FUND
MY PUBLIC EDUCATION.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT US JUST
LIKE US OF TEACHERS WILL SEE DID
LAST WEEK I URGE YOU TO FUND YOU
SEE BY THE FULL FOUR PERCENT AND
I URGE YOU TO PLEASE SEND ME
GOOD VIBES MY FINALS NEXT WEEK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
KELLY ROSENBERG WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE FACULTY
HIRING WE THINK THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH OUR ASK FOR
FIFTY MILLION ONGOING DEDICATED
TO FACULTY WOULD ALSO ASK THAT
FUNDING BE ATTACHED TO SOME KIND
OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND.
DATA REPORTING SO THAT WE CAN
FOR THOSE FUNDS ARE GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT FACULTY IS
IN FACT BEING HIRED THAT WE ARE
GETTING GOOD JOBS TO THESE PART
TIME LECTURES. IN INCREASING THE
DIVERSITY THINK ILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY WITH THAT WE
WILL ADJOURN